Welcome to Jamovi.
Jamovi is an application
for analyzing data and helping
you make sense of the information
around you.
It's also a compelling alternative
to expensive proprietary programs
like SPSS and SAS and Stata.
Instead,
Jamovi is based on the open source
programing language R,
which is designed for working with data.
And what that means is that JR
movie is free.
It's open
and it's extraordinarily friendly.
In fact, once you start using a movie,
you'll simply be embarrassed
that you didn't start using it sooner.
Now I want to mention
one thing about this course.
This is a tools course
and teaching you how to use software.
It works best
if you already know a little about data,
because I'm not going to be
discussing the principles at great length.
On the other hand, it's
easier to learn data
when you have a good tool like a movie.
So it really, either way, works fine.
Just get started and see what you can do.
Go to the movie
Dot org and download the program
and then go to DataLab Dot
CC slash tools, slash GMV to download
all the course files
so you can follow along
with what I'm doing
and start working in your own data too.
And with that, let's go.
The first thing you need
to do to work with your movie
is to get it installed on your computer.
It's a desktop application,
so you'll need to have either Windows,
Mac or Linux
and you install it and run it locally.
Go to Jam Movie Dawg,
and then simply click on this link.
Download Now the beautiful thing is
it's free and it's open source.
Click the in system that you need.
Windows Mac OS or Linux.
Download the file double click on it
and you'll be ready
to start working into movie
in just a few seconds.
When you open your movie,
this is the window that you're going to
see. Now, if you're used to
some other applications like SPSS or SAS,
what's a little different here
is that it's a single window, actually,
that makes it really easy to organize
and to navigate through it.
But I want to show you
a few different parts of what's going on
now over here on the left,
of course, where we have rows and columns
arranged, integrated.
This is where your data goes.
It's your data window.
Right now, we have three
variables, just called A, B and C.
You're, of course, going to replace those
with something else.
And you put the data in.
So it's a one column
per variable, one row per case
over here on the right is the output
window.
It's where we'll see the results
of our analyzes.
Up at the top, we have two tabs here.
The first one that's open
by default is analyzes,
which gives you options for exploration.
If I click on that and come
to descriptive, you'll see, for instance,
it opens up the menu that allows you
to choose what you want to do
and you get a blank version
of the results over here on the right
by the way,
you'll notice that the menus into movie
are designed to resemble those of SPSS.
It's not based on SPSS.
Your movie actually runs on R,
but it's designed to make it easy
for people who are used to SPSS
to really migrate over to G movie.
You can close the windows
by clicking on this arrow,
hide the options
and we have versions of T tests,
the analysis of variance
or ANOVA or ANOVA regression
frequencies
and then factor.
And obviously I'll go over each of these
procedures in separate videos.
You also have a data tab right here
that allows you to paste in your
information to do a setup of the variables
where you define what's in them,
the type it calls them continuous,
although I would call that measured or
scaled or quantitative or null or nominal.
And then you can put down
integer decimal or text,
you can give levels, you can give names,
you can compute new variables,
you can add elite variables in columns,
you can filter your cases and add
or delete rows for cases.
I can hide this right here
at the far left,
the three horizontal two lines
give you the menu to new open save
and so on, as well as recent data
you have at the bottom.
And then one more that's really
important is way over here at the right
click on
the three dots
and you get a number of options zooming
and the number format one interesting
one here is the plot theme.
So when it makes the graphs,
if you really want it to look like SPSS,
you can get the base charts.
I don't like them.
I actually prefer minimal.
Hadlee is a reference to Hadley Wickham.
The person who developed Gigi,
applied to a very common graphics program
for our users
and then minimal is also really nice.
I'll keep it at default for now
and then syntax mode.
If you click on this, then you're actually
going to be able to see the
R language syntax
using the gem V package that allows you
to duplicate any of these features,
any of these analyzes in R.
That's an enormous benefit,
especially if you're familiar with SPSS,
but you're trying to learn are.
And so that's a general orientation
of what's going on in your movie
in the Future videos.
I'll show you
how each of these options work.
Each of the analyzes function
and how to read some of the output that
you get from your movie.
The fastest
way to get started with your movie
is to explore its example data sets.
To do that, come up to the little menu,
the three
horizontal lines
here, and come down to open.
Now in this PC means the ones that are
installed on your computer.
But examples
there are four sample data sets.
The first one consists of big five data.
This is big five personality
characteristics.
I'll click on that and it opens up.
And what it has is five variables
on the personality characteristics
neuroticism, extroversion, openness
to experience,
agreeableness and conscientiousness,
and they're rated on 1 to 5 scales.
And this is a great data
set for doing correlations,
for doing regression,
and for doing data exploration.
Another good dataset,
again to open an examples
is to boost growth.
Now this kind of a funny data set
because it has to do
with the length of teeth in guinea pigs.
But what it has is a single outcome
variable that's called length,
that's for length,
and then sub is for the supplement.
This is an experiment
where they are giving the guinea pigs
one of two different supplements
to aid in their tooth growth.
It's either V.S., which is for a vitamin C
or it's OJ for orange juice.
And then on top of that,
they manipulate the dosage
either 500, 1000 or 2000.
And this allows you
to look at the combined effect of these
two factors
on the growth of teeth in guinea pigs.
It's a good way to get started
with the analysis of variance.
After that,
there is bugs.
This is a peculiar data set
because it has to do
with how people react to insects.
We have a subject number gender male,
only female and region some education.
And then these four mysterious variables
are the level of disgusting ness
and the level of frightening ness,
either low or high on the both of them.
And what this is, is a good example
of the analysis of variance
for a repeated measures or within
subject variation, because everybody
in this experiment gave responses
to all four possible categories.
And the final data set
under again
examples is the classic Anderson's
Iris data, also known as Fisher's
Iris Data.
And what this is, is the measurement
of the Siebel length and Siebel
width and pedal length and pedal
width of three species of irises.
So you have four quantitative
or continuous variables
and one nominal or categorical variable.
This is a classic data set
on how quantitative
measurements can be used to place
observations into categories.
It's also a great way to practice
breaking down explorations by groups
because these species of iris differ
pretty substantially
in some of these measurements,
and so use any of these four data
sets as a way to start exploring
how you can work with some of you.
You'll see how quick and easy
you can get into the data,
get the exploration, start
doing some analysis
and start getting some meaning of the data
that you have in your movie.
One of the things I truly love about
your movie
is how easy it makes it to collaborate
with other people.
And the reason it's easy is
because when you share things with people,
you're sharing a single file.
So for example, here's
a potential analysis that I might do
when I'm working with somebody.
I've got a data set here.
I've got the variables
that came with the dataset.
I've got a calculated variable right here.
You see the formula,
I've got a descriptive analysis.
Let me put this over a little bit.
I've got descriptive statistics,
I've got tables, I've got charts
and box plots and all of this,
and it's saved in a single file.
So let me show you this. For example,
all of this is saved in a single file
that I have got called sharing
files, dot OMV,
where dot OMV is the gem of the extension.
When I work with somebody,
I do the analysis and then I send them
the single file
and I tell them, download the movie
double click on this
and you'll open up right to where we were.
And they'll have all of the data,
all of the calculations,
all the transformations,
all of the analyzes.
They'll have everything
in one self-contained unit,
and that is one of the easiest ways
to share things.
You can email the file to them,
you can put it in a shared folder
like Google Drive or Dropbox or Box.
But anyway, you do it.
The unitary nature of the files
and the fact that they have
all the work that you've done in there
makes it extremely easy to collaborate
and share work.
G Movie makes it easy to share files
by simply emailing
or putting in a shared box.
The file that you've been working on
because it has the data,
it has the transformation,
it has the analysis.
There is, however, a really interesting,
more sophisticated alternative to that.
And it's called
the Open Science Framework.
And if you want to go here to OSX IO,
I can show you a little bit
about how it works and how your movie
is very well adapted to it.
The Open Science Framework
is a free service that really facilitates
collaboration and reproducibility.
In research.
You can create a free account
and one of the important things here
is that it allows you
to integrate a number of other services.
So for instance, maybe you use Dropbox
or Google Drive or Box,
it can bring files in from those.
Or if you're the programmer type, you
might use GitHub or Amazon Web Services.
Again, those are integrated.
Now, I personally like to upload files
one by one into OSPF.
That way
I have a better sense of what's there.
I don't put something in a folder
by accident,
but this is a way to share your work.
Both with specific other people
for collaboration
and to share your results with the world.
I want to show you how this works
by having you go to an example.
If you go to this web address, bit
dot Lee slash
gym movie,
dash poster for Open Science Framework,
then you'll see the page
that I created for these movie tutorials
for that address.
It's a shortcut
and it takes you to this page.
In OSF, I've set up a read
only access to my files here,
so anybody can look at it.
They can see what's there,
they can't change it.
But this is a great way of collaborating
and right now I've got the files
from the first chapter in the Jamo
v course
and one of them is sharing files dot OMV.
Now you may remember what this looks like
into movie itself
right here.
We've got the iris example data
and I've got some charts
that are broken down by categories.
I got some statistics.
Let me show you what those look like
when we're in OSPF.
If you click on this file right here,
it's going to open up in your browser.
I've got it open already,
so I'm just going to move over.
And here what you
have is an exact reproduce
version of the results that we have.
We have the same table, it looks exactly
the same and we push it down a little bit.
We have the same charts
and it's all there.
And in fact,
even though people can't modify it,
they can download it
and then they can open it themselves
into mobi and start working with the data
and see what they can get out of it.
And so this is a wonderful way
of collaborating
and sharing results with people.
And Jamovi is one of the few programs
that opens is files natively and o-F
that makes it so easy to share.
One of the thing I want to point out
is because this is just a web page,
not only does it work on a browser
like a mac Windows or a Chromebook,
it even works on smartphones.
You can open it on an iPhone
or an Android or a tablet, and you'll
get the same results and you can explore
and share the results that way.
So if you want to have a step up
in your collaboration
and then you're sharing and really a way
of disseminating your research
OS The Open Science Framework
can be an excellent alternative
that works so well with Germany.
The base functions that come with
your movie are really powerful
and truthfully are probably enough
to get you all the way through
whatever it is you need to do.
On the other hand, Germany is based on R
these statistical programing language
which has about 10,000 packages available.
They give extra functionality to R
and it turns out
you can do a similar thing with movie
through what are called modules.
Modules are to Jamovi
what packages are to are or to Python.
They give you extra functionality.
So for example, if you open up Jamovi.
modules dot OMV, you'll see that
I have the standard correlation matrix
right here.
You can click on this and then you'll see
the commands that come under regression.
That's where they come from right here.
And I'm looking at the simple length
and the simple with of the Irish data set
and we've got the correlations
here, the p value
and we've got a scatterplot.
It goes down in this one corner.
It's actually built for doing a matrix
where you have many variables.
But you know, we get some cool stuff,
we get the regression line,
we get the standard errors around it,
we get density
plots for the two variables,
and we get the correlation
written up here in small corners.
But there's a module that allows you to do
more than that.
If you come up to modules
and down to G movie library,
what you'll find is there's about a dozen
modules that are currently available,
and the Jamo v developers are making
a strong push for our developers
to convert their
AR packages into movie modules.
They have instructions on
how to do that on their website
and once they're available,
you can sideload them,
which means you download them separately
and then import them into Java.
But it's best if they're available
through the movie library.
We've got one on power analysis,
general analysis for linear models,
we have method
selection, we've got meta analysis.
Scatter is a great one for doing plots
toaster to one side to test base.
R This replicates
the statistical analysis are available
in the base package
and are we have mediation in moderation.
Walrus is a collection of robust
statistics developed by Rand Wilcox,
and we have survival analysis called Death
Watch and even a little video game here
called your movie Arcade.
All you have to do is click on install
and it'll put it in there
and then it'll be listed
here under installed.
Everybody gets this one time movie,
that's the default I've added scatter
and let me show you what it looks like,
why you would want to use
one of these extra packages.
This is the default version
of the scatterplot matrix.
I'm going to close the thing here
by clicking on the side,
but here's the one that I made
using the scatter module
and you can tell a lot of things a lot
prettier has got more colors
going on in it,
but it allows me to break down the
scatterplot by the species of the iris.
And there's a really important thing here.
Let's go back out 1/2 here.
This is basically a flat and
essentially zero regression line
through the data.
But when we break it down by species
and ask you this over a little bit
so you can see all of it,
we see that they all have
a strong uphill relationship in that total
and the red is really strong.
And then we have the density plots
for each variable
broken down by the categories on the side.
And if I click on this again, it
brings up the menu from the scatter module
and that one by the way,
it goes under exploration to scatter
and has two functions,
scatterplot and parietal chart.
But I'm doing this one right here
and it's a great way
to get some additional insight.
And so modules in general,
their role is to bring extra
functionality, extra things
you can do with your data into your movie.
Currently, there's about a dozen,
but as Jamovi grows and develops,
more people who create packages for
AR will learn to adapt them for JR movie
and give it even more power
and even more possibilities.
You may be familiar
with these statistical programing language
are a free, open source language
that is specifically developed
for working with data,
and that's a favorite tool
of statisticians, data
analysts, data scientists everywhere.
One of the great things about R is
how powerful
it is,
and that really you can do anything in it.
One thing you can't do,
however, is use dropdown menu as
you have to type out lines of code
and that makes it intimidating
for a lot of people.
One of the great things about Jamovi,
which is based on R, is that it helps
provide a bridge between
people used to menu driven applications
like SPSS and command line
driven applications like our
show. The Connection between the two.
I have the same analysis
in both a Jamovi file
that jmvPackaged.omv
and as an R script jmvPackage.R
Now you're only going to be able
to open that one
if you have R installed on your computer
and hopefully R Studio two.
But let me show you how Jamovi connects
these two applications.
Here's the analysis open in Jamovi.
It's the Irish data.
And what I have here on the right
is I have some descriptive statistics,
and if you click on that,
you get the commands.
I have the menu.
It looks a lot like an SPSS menu.
I put the variables in there.
I asked for certain statistics,
I asked for certain plots,
and we scroll down
and here is the basic analysis.
I have density plots and box plots
for each of the variables,
and it's really easy to do
if I want to do the same thing in R,
it's really easy to do
using the G movie package,
but to get there you first need to enable
something called syntax mode.
If you come up to the top right
and click on these three dots, you'll
open up a menu and write down here
in the results is you have syntax mode.
If you click on that, then the output here
looks a little bit different.
We now have a momma's based font,
we have some headers here,
and this right here is an R command.
And what you can do is
you can do an option.
Click on that or two finger,
click and do syntax and do copy.
And then from there you go over to r
r version of this file open.
I've got some header information
that I put on all of my files.
You need to install the GMV,
which is short for gym movie package,
and once you've got it installed,
you need to load it by using library.
I'm going to run that command
down at the bottom and just tells us
that the movie now
has precedence on the ANOVA
command over the stats package.
And we also need to load the data sets
because that's where the Irish data is.
So I do those two things
and now I load the data.
Now a funny thing
here is the movie command.
It needs to know where the data is
and an R you say data is equal to
and then you give the name of the data
where the name of the object in the memory
and in this case is called data.
I know it looks redundant,
but it makes it very flexible.
As long as you come back here
and you save your data
set into an object called data,
which I'm going to do right here,
and then you
can see that it's loaded over here,
150 observations with five variables.
I'm going to take a look
at the first few lines
with the head command
just to make sure it's entered. Right.
That looks exactly like it should.
And then we come here to this command
from J movie I've already pasted in here.
It's a single sentence.
This tells us that we're using the jmvPackage.
The descriptors function
here is the arguments that go into it
and then a few extra options.
This is a single command
and when I run that command, what I get
are the same tables and charts
that I had in the Jamovi output. Now
let me make this a little bigger over here
so you can see the tables better.
This is the exact same chart
that your movie produced
is now in mono space fun,
but it's set up exactly the same way.
And over here on the right, under plots,
we have the same plots,
but now it's showing them to us
one at a time.
And this is actually the last one.
And you can scroll through them and see
the other charts that your movie produces.
It's exactly
the same as we had in the application.
And so the purpose of this package
is, number one,
maybe you're more comfortable with our
you can reproduce all these commands
that you did in your movie.
In R number two, it provides a bridge
if you're familiar with SPSS
and other menu driven applications.
Jamovi makes it possible
to set up your analysis with menus,
then copy the syntax and paste it into our
and that way
you can become more accustomed
and learn to use R.
And in fact, because the Jamovi package
really contains
everything you need to get.
For instance,
through an introductory statistics course,
you only have to learn one package,
and that makes it extremely efficient
and extremely user friendly
when it comes to learning.
A powerful language like our
our next chapter
is about wrangling data in a movie.
And if you're not familiar with it,
you may wonder what I mean when I say
wrangling, because I'm not talking about
this kind of wrangling out on the range.
Instead, I'm talking about this
kind of wrangling where you're taking data
that's in a mess, it's in a jumble,
and you're organizing it
and you're getting it
so you can analyze it.
It goes by a few other names as well.
Sometimes it's called data munching,
sometimes it's called data scrubbing.
It can also be called data cleaning.
Or really, it just refers
to the general process of preparing
your data for analysis.
This is really the nitty gritty of data.
It's the part that's not so glamorous
but absolutely critical
to the success of a project.
It also tends to be the most time
consuming part.
In fact, one of the rules of thumb
of any data project is that about 80% of
your time is spent
preparing the data for analysis.
And to help with that,
we're going to talk about entering data
into a movie, importing data,
defining variables.
So you know what you're dealing
with computing new variables to get things
ready for the form that you need,
and filtering cases
so you can focus on subgroups
and get more detailed analysis.
And as we go through all of this,
you'll see this special function
that your movie has to help you prepare,
working with your data and to get
it started
so you can discover the joy of clean data.
The sample data in GMV is wonderful.
It's a great way to learn the program,
see how things go.
On the other hand, you probably came here
to analyze your own data.
And so theoretically,
the simplest way to do this is to enter
the data directly into mobile,
because you can do that.
We've got something
that looks like a spreadsheet over here,
and when you first open it, it's got these
three blank variables called A, B and C,
and you can put your own stuff in there.
So for instance, you can put an ID
number and in fact, it's a good idea
to change the names of these.
So you know what they are.
So I'm just going to change this one to ID
and then I'll change the next one to
first name,
and then I'll change the third one to age.
And so we've got three possible variables
there.
I'll close this window.
You want to use ID number
because you need to be able
to find a particular case
and you need to be able to return
things to the order in which they were.
So I'm going to put number one
right there and let's say first
name, let's put Alex
and let's give an age of 34, okay?
If we were in Excel or Google Sheets,
we could hit return now
and it would take us back
to the first column to movie.
Doesn't do that. Go straight down.
So we need to manually.
I'm going to hit the left
arrow to go back.
We'll do the second one and we'll do Ava
and we'll say that she is 41
and then
we'll do a third one and we'll say it's
Fecri and we'll say that he's 18 anyway.
You can do it this way.
It's really tedious.
It's a laborious process,
and I really don't recommend
entering the data directly into a movie
the same way.
I never would recommend
entering the data directly into SPSS
or to our or to SAS or anything else
like that.
This is possible, but it's not a good way.
Instead, a much better way
is to enter your data in a spreadsheet.
Google Sheets is good because it's online
and several people can be working
on the same sheet at once.
And then you can import that file,
which is what I'm going to show you
in the next video.
The much better way
to get your data into your movie.
Well, as possible, to enter data
manually into Jamovi.
It's an awkward process
and it's much better to save the data
in a spreadsheet, either from Google
Sheets, Excel or some other program
and then import it directly.
And fortunately,
that's easy to do in your movie.
Here I have a blank window,
and what I'm going to do is I'm going
to show you how to import several
different spreadsheets or other formats.
So first,
I want you to see the files themselves.
What I have
are four files with the same data in it,
but they're in different formats.
This first one is an Excel X file.
It's Excel or really it's the Excel's open
XML format.
And you can see
we've got an ID number, recorded
date and response ID,
then we have five questions, queue
one through five
and then a zip code at the end.
And it's a very simple data set.
Now I have the same information
saved as a C
as a V file,
which stands for comma separated values.
This is the really most common version
of a spreadsheet
that basically anything can read,
and we've got the same data.
It's shown a little bit differently
here on My Mac when I do a quick view,
but it's the same data.
You can also save it as a text file
where you have tabs separating the values.
And actually I did this in Excel,
just saved it as text.
And you can see again,
although it's arranged
a little differently, it's the same data.
And then finally
I have the same data in an SPSS save file.
Now it may be depending on what you have
on your computer, if you click on this,
it'll give you variable definitions
when you do a quick view.
Right now, it's not showing me anything.
But here's an interesting thing, Jamo.
You can import most of these,
but not all of them.
Let me go back to Germany.
What I do is I come over to the menu here
with the three horizontal lines
and I hit open
and you'll see that it's able to open
several different kinds of files,
of course, movie files,
and then see V and text files.
It's able to open SPSS
files, data files, SAS files, and Jasper,
which is another program created
by several of the same developers of G
movie, looks very similar
but operates a little differently.
And so these are the options.
Now let's come up here to browse
and I'm going to go to my desktop
desktops right there.
And what you see now is the
as X is grayed out,
I can't open a native Excel file,
but that's okay
because if you're in Excel,
you just save it as CSV and you're
good to go.
So let's start with the CSV file.
This is the most common
kind of file that you would be importing.
All I got to do is double click on this
and then
it opens up in Germany
and there we have our data.
Let me
move this one over a little bit.
Perfect.
It's formatted and you can see that
it even change the data types
to match pretty much what's in there.
Now I'm going to show you how to do data
definitions in later videos.
So I'm not going to worry about that
right now.
But this is the C as V file.
Now, let me show you what it's like
when we open the text file again,
I'll come to open
and because I have this one folder open,
it's my desktop, I can just hit import
text, I double click on that.
It takes just a moment.
And here you see
the data looks exactly the same.
There's no difference.
And then finally
we're going to do the SPSS file
and you'll see with this one
there is a small difference.
I'm going to
come here to import s.A v, that's the SPSS
data file.
I click on that and what's different here
is that in SPSS
you have labels on your values.
And so for instance,
you see the variables.
Q Once your Q five and the other ones,
they were just the numbers
of one through five.
Here they have labels on them,
although you should know
that the numbers are underneath.
I'm going to just double click on this
and when we open that up
you can see strongly disagree as a one.
Disagree is a two and in fact Germany,
you can still treat these
as numeric variables
the same way you would do in SPSS
if you had a variable with value labels.
I'm going to close that now.
There is one other thing
SPSS really didn't like having the date
and the time in the same thing,
so they had to get split into two.
But that's a trivial thing.
And so you can see that
if you have the data in a spreadsheet,
you got it in SPSS or SAS
or some other format.
It's a very quick and easy process
to import that data into your movie.
Here is the format.
It reads the labels
and then you're good to go.
Your computer can analyze data
without knowing what it is.
If it has numbers,
it'll work with numbers.
If that's text it, it'll do something.
But for it to mean
something to you as the analyst
and maybe as your client,
you have to know what things mean.
And that means that you need to define
your variables,
give them their variable types,
as well as put labels on them
that are going to help you
as you try to make sense of things.
So for instance, here's a small data set.
It's based on the one that I imported
earlier.
It begins with an ID number.
That's helpful because you can go back
and find particular cases.
So you always want to start with that.
Then I have three questions Q1, Q2, Q3
that are on 1 to 5 rating scales.
And then I have a question here.
I have called it subscribed at the end
and it's a yes and no are Y and n.
Now, what we need to do is say
what kind of types
each of these variables are
as well as give them labels as necessary.
Now ID we don't really need to worry
about this one, but
by default, if a movie sees one through.
However many numbers, it's going to assume
that it is a continuous scale.
Now we want to change the type.
You can do that either by double
clicking on the name of the variable here
or by going up to data
and then clicking setup.
Either one will work.
And so the very first one is ID.
Now technically ID
numbers are not continuous
or quantitative,
they're nominal where it's one per person.
So I'm going to put nominal,
but I'm going to say integer,
that's fine and we'll leave it like that.
And you see now that its little icon here
has switched from the ruler
to the three circles which indicate
different categories or buckets
that change by the way,
from of ID from continuous nominal,
it doesn't really make a difference.
I'm going to go to the next variable,
which is Q one,
and this is where I actually want
to give it a real name
and I might say something like,
like websites.
So do they like your website?
And now that shows up here.
Now this isn't the label.
I just changed the name of the variable.
I can give it a more thorough description.
Does the user like that?
Companies
website.
Now that label
there is just for our own use.
It doesn't really show up anywhere.
But what I'm going to do here
is I'm going to change the variable type
and I'm going
to change the names of the levels.
Now it turns out that
when you have a small number
of categories, they're one, two,
three, four, five is a small number.
GMV assumes that it's a categorical
or nominal variable.
The thing is,
it doesn't really make a difference
if you're going to be averaging
or if you're going to be calculating
statistics,
it'll do it on these variables.
Even though they're defined as nominal,
you can change it
to continuous or ordinal,
and that's going to affect
the kinds of graphs that you can make
and is going to affect
the ways that you can split the data.
So it's not critical
if all you're going to do is average, but
if you want to do other things with it,
it helps to define them.
Now, a 1 to 5 rating scale,
there's a debate
about what level of measurement it is.
Technically, it's ordinal
because higher numbers indicate
more agreement
or a higher evaluation of something
on the other hand, in
every field I've ever seen, people
actually take a 1 to 5 rating scale
and treat it as though it were continuous
or quantitative so they can average it
and so I'm actually going to come here
and I'm
going to define this one as continuous.
Now, you'll see here
that the levels went away
because now it's treating these as,
you know,
like time, 1 seconds to 5 seconds
doesn't have labels.
So that's fine and I know what it means.
So I'm going to go ahead to the next one
and I'm going to put here like,
like price of
your service
and this one I'll put it as ordinal.
Now you see that the levels here stayed
and that's important.
And the last one
here, I'll just put like, like
product and I'm going to leave.
This one is nominal, but I'm
now I'm going to change these levels,
so I'm actually going
to change these labels.
So for instance, I click right here, add
one, and that's usually strongly disagree.
And then the two is disagree.
The three might be neither,
four would be agree
and five might be
strongly agree.
A lot of people call this a Likert scale.
It's actually a response scale.
Likert scales have more to do
with how you choose the questions
as opposed to the format
in which you respond to them.
But call it a Likert scale if you want.
It's a 1 to 5 rating scale,
and then you can see that
these labels all show up down here.
That's really the convenient thing.
And remember,
the numbers are still underneath there,
so you can still do numerical operations
on these variables.
The last one I want to show you
is this text variable.
At the end you see says nominal text
because I actually typed in the letters
Y and N
and you can do the same thing with these.
I can click on the Y, I can put subscribed
and I can maybe put they're
not subscribe or they can't be websites
I will call my visitor.
And so now you have new names
for the variables.
I change the names.
I change the level of the measurement
or the type of the variable
for some of them, say, for instance,
from continuous or quantitative to ordinal
to nominal or categorical,
and then I change labels.
And so this is a very important
in terms of preparing the data in Zimbabwe
because it's going to make it much easier
for you to interpret the analysis
and then in turn to make sense of it,
especially when you're collaborating
with a colleague
or potentially working for a client.
One of the most common transformations
on data is average in several variables.
That way you can get it, for instance,
a scale score.
It's also a great way of helping balance
out the error variance of different scores
and really get you more generalizable
information.
This is easy to do in Zimbabwe.
What I'm going to do
is I'm going to take this data set.
It has ID and it has these three
rating scale questions
and they're all on a 1 to 5 scale
and they ask people how much they liked
different elements of,
for instance, your website.
And I'm going to click on each of these
first or go to like website
and we have a little bit
of descriptive text and it's a continuous
or quantitative variable
that's just on a 1 to 5.
If we go to like price,
you see it's ordinal
and even though it's ordinal,
you get to specify levels.
Now it just has the 1 to 5. That's to do.
And then like product
you see here in the data, it has text,
it says neither strongly disagree
and so on and it's coded as nominal.
On the other hand, it's important to say
that it's an integer variable,
even if it's nominal.
And then over here
we have levels where we have the one, two,
three, four or five and we've put labels
on each of those levels.
So one as strongly as agree to disagree
and so on.
The reason this is important
is because the numbers
still are there underneath those labels,
and that's what makes it possible
for us to average them.
So close us for just a moment
and we're going to create a new variable.
I'm going to double click right here
and I can either enter a new data
variable, a new computed variable,
or a new transform variable.
We're going to do the middle one
right here and new computed variable,
and it's going
to ask for the name of that new variable.
I'm simply going to call it the mean, and
we can give it a description if we want.
I'm going to put down here the average
or three rating scale variables.
The easiest way to do
this is to come to the function window.
And if you're used to SPSS or to excel,
you know,
you've got a lot of different choices.
There's a
much smaller range in your movie, but
they're basically the ones that you need.
I'm going to scroll down a little bit
and get to me
and I'm going to double click on that
to put it in the box,
and then I need to tell it what variables
I want to include.
I'm going to come over here
to the variable list
and simply double click on the first one.
And when I double click on it
puts it up here and you'll see that
it puts it in back ticks.
Those are sort of back
leaning apostrophes.
That's because there's a space
or a non text character in here.
If you had an underscore or a dash,
it might do the same thing.
It's actually a nice reason
to not have spaces or other things
in your variable names because
then you don't have to do the back ticks.
But I'm always going to do that
first automatically.
Now when you have a range of variables
that are all next to each other in SPSS,
you can give the name of the first one
and then write t o Capital two
and the last one in terms of you need
to specify each of them separately.
So I'm going to put a comma
and then I'll click the second one
and a comma and I'll click the third one.
And now I've got that and I can close this
and you can see
it automatically fills in with the mean.
Even though there are three
different levels of measurement, it knows
that they all have numerical information.
Now, I said it was important that this one
right here was specified as integer.
Let me double click on that again
and then you'll see if I come down here
and I say, It's not integer, but it's
text, then you see the mean disappears,
even though those levels still remain.
But if I come back and tell it again
now it's integer than the mean reappears.
It's able to treat it
as numeric information.
And so that's how you can average
several variables into a movie,
which gets you a long way towards
getting more reliable scores,
averaging out some of the variance
and getting the scale scores
that you may need
for your further analysis.
Sometimes your
data comes to you on scales
that don't have any inherent meaning or.
May not be familiar.
a1254127 agreement scale.
Well, that's common,
doesn't have inherent meaning.
And if you're comparing income information
from Nepal to Turkey to Mexico,
you're going to be dealing
with different currencies
and you're going to need a way
of comparing relative standing.
The easiest way to do that is was Z scores
or standardized scores.
Now, if you've had statistics, you know,
that simply takes the score, subtract
the mean of the variable
and divide by the standard deviation.
And a lot of the people show you
how you can do that manually
and you can set that up in a movie
that way.
But there's a much easier way to do that.
Let's do this one.
We're going to come here and double
click on this empty variable here,
and we're going to
choose new computed variable.
And what I'm going to do is I'm going
to change this to say Z score,
and then I'm going to use the function
window
and scroll
down to the statistical functions
to the last one on that particular
list, it's Z.
I just double click on that
and brings up the function and then I need
to tell it what I want the Z score of.
In this case,
I want the mean that's the mean score
of those three rating scale questions.
I double click on that and
I can close the window and there it is.
That's all I need to do.
A negative Z score indicates
that somebody is below the mean.
A positive
Z score says they're above the mean,
and the numbers themselves
are a unit of standard deviations.
So there's a very fair score
that's highlighted is point
for standard deviations below
the mean, quick and easy
and Jamovi makes it a cinch
and that helps you get on the way
to taking your variables that are
in different scales or arbitrary ones
and putting them into something
that may be more meaningful
and is certainly more comparable
from one variable to another.
When you're getting your data
ready for analysis, sometimes
you need to do the same transformation
to many different scores doing reverse
coding or logarithmic transformations.
Or maybe you need to take variables
and convert them into ordinal categories.
I want to show you an example of how
to use Jamovi transform function
to take Z scores and identify
whether they are extreme or not.
Using the plus or minus
two standard deviation criterion.
What I'm going to do
is I'm going to come over here
and click on this blank space,
and then I get to choose
a new transformed variable.
Now what I'm going to show
you can be done with a computed variable,
but the advantage of doing it
with a transformed variable is it saves
that transformation function,
and then you can apply it
to multiple variables at the same time
if you want.
The first thing we need to do
is we need to define
the actual function that we're going
to use, the transformation function.
And so I'm going to come right here to
transform and I'm going to click on that.
And right now I don't have any transforms.
I'm going to come down here
to create new transform,
and that brings up
another dialog from the bottom.
And now I'm going to label
the transformation.
And again, this is something
that can be applied to multiple variables.
And so it's not the name of a variable,
but it's the name of what you're going
to do.
Two variables
and I'm going to call it extreme
and I'm going to say is score
more than two standard deviations
from mean
and I'm going to be using the Z score so
I don't have to compute everything else.
And then what you have
here is a variable suffix.
And the idea is that
if you have many different variables
like Q1, Q2, Q3 for question
one, two, three,
in doing a logarithmic transformation,
all of them,
it can create a new variable
that includes, for instance.
Q One underscore log or log
and then in parentheses.
Q one there are a lot of different ways
to do it.
I'm just going to put right here
and say extreme,
and then I'm going to do the re code
condition.
Now, right now
it's asking me just to replace it
with something else I have to do ad record
condition and source means the variable
that you're starting with.
And again, you can leave that there
because you're going to
choose that variable
in the next dialog box.
I'm simply going to
say if it's greater than two,
then I'm going to say assign the text.
Yes, and you have to put text
in single quotes
so it knows otherwise
it's going to try to read it.
It's a variable name.
Then I'm going to add
another record condition
and see if it is less than nugget of two.
And then that is also extreme.
So I'll say yes
and then else
says otherwise, just do this
otherwise it's no.
So that's simple.
So I'm going to close that.
And now I've defined
that transform function
and you can see that it's available
now there's extreme right there
and I'm going to use extreme,
but it wants to know what variable it is
I want to transform. That's why
there's the question mark there.
So I'm going to come right here
and I'm going to choose Z score.
And once I do that, you see it fills
in immediately
where we have the notes and down here
we have a Z score of 2.097
that's greater than two.
So it says, yes, that's extreme.
And this is a function
that I could apply to other variables
if they're on the same scale.
And so it makes it easy
to prepare a lot of variables,
sometimes using rather complex functions,
but rather quickly in a way that's easy
to set up and easy to understand
what's happening.
One of the important steps
in analysis is the ability
to drill down,
to focus on specific cases in your data.
Set to movie allows you to do that
by filtering cases.
To do this, I'm opening this data
set that I have called filtering cases,
and I'm showing you a little bit
of descriptive statistics here.
The number of cases, 173
and the minimum and maximum
for two of the calculated variables
at the end of the data set
to get to
filters,
come here to data and click on the filter.
Looks like your porn filter in a kitchen
and when you click on that,
you get the opportunity
to enter your text for a filter.
You can click in here
and you can choose various functions
and you can choose existing variables
and you can simply click on them.
So I can go, for instance, ID,
and then less than ten,
and that will give me the first nine
cases.
Those that have ID numbers, less than ten
and I have a variable over here called ID,
so I'm going to hit return for that.
And now what you see is I have a new
column here called Filter one.
You can't change the name of the filters.
They're just one, two and so on.
And I have a green check mark
for all of the cases that are selected.
And you see them here and a red X for
all of the cases are not selected
and their row as are grayed out.
And now you can see that I have only nine
cases and we have different statistics.
Those are calculated
only for those particular nine cases.
By the way, if you want to close this,
just hit the up button like that.
And there's our nine
cases from our first filter.
But you
probably want to do more than that.
And so Jamo V allows you
to use more than one filter in combination
or trading off with another one.
In the class
you do more sophisticated filter commands.
Let me come back to filters here
and I'm going to add a new filter.
I'm simply going to press the plus.
By the way,
what the eye here does, it shows or hides
the filter column that's on the left.
You see, here's says filter one.
If I hide that,
then you just don't see it anymore.
Even though the filter is still operative.
I'm going to do a new filter and this time
I'm going to paste something and
and what I have here
is a filter
that draws on this calculated column.
So I'm going to hit filter
and I'm selecting all cases
with a mean greater than four.
And if I double click on this, you'll see
that the mean comes from the average
of these three variables
one, two and three.
Even though this one has text. But
note that if I click on it, you can see
that there are numbers underneath it.
I'm going to show you
how that works in a later filter.
But now
I have this second filter
and you can see I only have one case
that's selected because I'm using
both of my filters at once.
If I only want one filter,
I'm going to come back here to filter one
and I'm going to make it inactive
by turning it off.
And now I have more cases
that are showing it coincidentally is
still only nine cases that have values
of more than four on the mean.
I'm going to make another filter first.
I'll turn this one off.
I'm going to make a third filter here
and this time I'm going to paste it in.
And what I'm going to use
is the Z-Score variable.
That's one over here.
Now, the thing you need to know about Z
score is because it's got this dash in it.
I have to surround the name
of the variable with back ticks.
Those are
where the tilde key is
to the left of the one on your keyboard.
Now, if you select this by going to F of X
and you simply click on it,
it will automatically
put in the back ticks.
And this time I'm putting in something
less than two and more than two,
but I'm getting a problem.
And that is
it doesn't want to do it because it says,
I have a V or a column function.
That's because Z score.
Let's go back to this Z score.
Depends on the mean of the variable
that we're looking at, which is mean
and the standard deviation,
which means it has to calculate that
for all of the cases that are in that
column, you can't do a filter on that.
You get sort of an infinite regress.
So I'm going to come back to here
and I'm going to turn that filter off,
but I'm going to show you
the way that you can do that.
Now, one choice is to simply copy
the values in Z score
variable, paste them into a new one,
and now they're no longer formula,
they're just text,
and you can operate them
like any other variable.
But that really compromises
the functionality of some of you.
You lose the ability to easily
replicate the functions
because that's not a formula
based approach.
A better way to do it,
even though it's slightly
more complicated, is to include
the Z score function in the filter itself.
So let me come back here
and click on this new filter.
So you see, I now have a filter
for right here in a paste in a filter,
and now I actually have the
Z formula in the filter.
And when I hit return,
now we don't
see the Z score for this one anymore.
It had a value of 4.33.
That's going to be a high Z score,
but you can see that all of these others
are within a particular value.
Now, this is nice
if you want to choose the cases
that are between two values,
but often when you're using Z scores,
you want to look at the extreme cases
to identify outliers
and the intuitive thing would be
to simply flip around these relational
operators, the less than science
to make them greater than science.
But let me show you
what happens when you do that.
First, I'll turn this off.
I'll create a new filter.
So this filter number five,
I'm going to paste it in.
And you see,
this one is the same as above,
except I flipped around the less than
and replaced it with greater science.
Well,
I'm going to get a problem with that one.
And what it is, is it's excluded
every single case
because of the way it's parsing
the logic of this one.
This doesn't work.
Instead, what you need to do is
you need to do two separate statements
joined by an or so.
I'm going to turn that one off
open it up and paste in this other filter.
And now you see that I say Z four.
The mean score is either
less than negative two
and then or z mean is greater than two.
Please
note in a lot of languages, things like
and or need to be in capitals in Zimbabwe,
they need to be lowercase.
Also, if you're writing in a language
like art, you can use the pipe,
the vertical line character to signify
or that doesn't work here you need to type
lowercase o r and when I run that one
now you can see that
it's selecting cases are unusually high
and also some that are unusually low.
So we can join the two in a single
to filter out and get the extreme cases.
Now, I want to show you one more example
of how filters work for
I'm going to make this one inactive.
So we have all the cases again
and I'm going to press plus
and they're going to paste
in my seventh filter.
And this one uses the variable
like product.
This one right here again,
because I have a space or a
nonstandard character in the title,
I have to put the name
of the variable impacted by the way,
that's a good enough reason
to never have spaces
in your variable names.
That way
you don't have to do something like that.
And I'm going
to select cases that are either
four or five.
Now, in this case I'm using for
because I know that agree.
In fact, let me just run this
and I'm going to click on this again.
You'll see here that for four is agree
and strongly agree is five
and you can use either
the value or the label.
But if you use the label,
you need to put it into quotes,
not back ticks, because back ticks
are only for the names of variables,
but in quotes.
Also,
if you're not familiar with programing,
you know that you don't use equals
because that's usually
what's called an assignment operator.
Say this variable gets this value,
you have to use the two equals signs
together and that means is equivalent to
so like product is equivalent to four
or like product is equivalent
to strongly agree.
That gives me the fours and the fives
the agrees and this strongly agrees.
And so that's an exploration of how
filters operate many different ways.
In Jamo,
they allow you to focus on particular
cases to find the things that are most
interesting in a particular data
set and drill down to focus on those,
give them the attention they deserve,
and hopefully get some new insights
out of your data.
Our next topic
in terms of is exploring data.
And the reason we need to do that
is because raw data
is just completely overwhelming,
even when it's set up in nice rows.
Instead, you need to get a map,
you need to know what you're dealing with
and get the lay of the land
so you can tell a coherent story.
Now in Zimbabwe, we have several options
for exploring data.
First off is regular
descriptive statistics, things
like the mean and the median,
the standard deviation.
But even more useful than that
are data visualizations
like histograms or density plots.
Box plots are violent plots
or a dot plot in this case
combined with a violent plot.
And finally, standard bar plots.
One of the most useful methods
for visualizing data.
We'll also talk about how you can export
these graphs, these tables
to docs like Google Docs
and Microsoft Word and to presentations
so you can share your insights
and get your message across.
Perhaps the
quickest way to get some insight into
your data is to do basic descriptive
statistics like frequencies
and mean as standard deviations.
Fortunately,
that's really easy to do in a movie.
Now, the data set that I have open
here is the bugs data set
where we have a number of people
and they are rating how much
they would like to get rid of bugs
that are either high or low disgusting
or in high or low frightening.
And we have the people's
gender, region and education.
And all we need to do is come over here
to exploration and click descriptive.
Now I have installed the scatter module,
so these two menus show up here.
If you don't have those,
that's not a problem.
Just hit descriptive
and then we get to pick the variables
we want.
And Jamovi will either give us means
and so on or frequencies.
Now I find it useful to start
with the predictor
variables, the ones that you're going
to use to predict the outcomes.
And in this case,
that's going to be these three categorical
demographic things
gender, region and education.
So I'm going to put those over here
into variables.
And what we're going to get is a table
that really only tells us
how many cases there are.
There is 91 or 92, and we're missing
one or two on each of them.
I don't need these other variables
because these have to do with quantitative
or continuous variables.
So I'm just going to
remove those for right now.
On the other hand, we've got
to have nominal or categorical variables.
It would be nice to get a frequency table.
I'm going to click this selection
right here
and then it's
going to automatically expand
and it's going to give me the count,
the number of people in each category,
along with the percentage of the
total data and the cumulative percent.
And so, for instance, we can see that
we've got about two thirds women
and one third men,
and that we've got a lot of people
from North America
and almost 10% from Europe.
But other groups are pretty small
and level of education.
We have a spike at less
and we have 15 people or 16.5% at high,
which I assume means high school.
Anyhow, this is the first step.
Get some basic demographics or the things
that you're going to use as predictors.
Now I also want to look
at the outcome variables which are scaled.
They're measured on a 1 to 10 or zero
at a ten scale.
And I'm going to do the descriptive
command over again.
I'm going to hit
descriptors and then it shows up as blank.
And what I'm going to do
is I'm going to take these four outcomes
and put those in the variables over here.
Now, this time, because these are scaled
or quantitative outcomes,
it's going to give me a mean median
and so on.
On the other hand, there is a few
that I should add to that.
Most importantly is the standard deviation
that's sort of a bare minimum
for how spread out things are.
It's also nice to have the quartiles
now if you want to,
you can add the standard error,
the mean or the variance,
and you can get skewness and courtesies
each with a standard error.
But this what I have right here
is usually plenty.
By the way, you may notice that this table
strongly, the command that you use
in SPSS to get basic
descriptive statistics that's on purpose
j movie is modeled to be friendly
to people who are migrating from SPSS
and then it brings in the power of R,
but it's designed to be accessible.
And so now we have
some descriptive statistics
on the categorical demographic variables.
We have some descriptive statistics on the
quantitative or continuous outcomes.
There is one other thing that we can do
here that's worth mentioning, and that is
we may want to look at some of these
variables.
Here are the outcome variables and break
them down by one of our other categories.
The only one that's going to work
really well here is male or female.
The general rule of thumb
with quantitative variables is
you want to have at least
10% of your sample in the smallest group.
So we would probably have to combine
people to be sort of North America
or other, but I don't know that
that would make a lot of sense.
But what I can do is
I can get the statistics
for these for outcome variables,
how much people want to get rid
of these various bugs in terms
of how disgusting or frightening they are.
And I can break that down by gender.
To do that, I come back up to exploration
and go to descriptive.
I pick the four outcome variables
which again stand for like low,
disgusting, low, frightening, low,
disgusting, high, frightening, and so on.
And then I are normal
or categorical variable gender,
which is text in this case, because
he actually wrote out male or female,
and then I put them down here
and then I'm going to come
and make a few changes to the table
that I'm going to get.
Mostly, I'm
going to remove some of these statistics
because when you start breaking it down
by other categories, it gets really busy.
And so I'm just going to get the NW,
the mean and the standard deviation,
and that's probably going to be sufficient
for what I'm doing right now.
And here you can see how it broke it down
into those categories.
I can click out here.
And so that is a quick run
through of the descriptive statistics
that you can get quickly and easily.
And GMV, again, a very good first
look at your data
and a way to get started on understanding
what you have to help you shape.
And then interpret your analyzes.
The waging movie
is set up when you first
go to explore your data.
It offers you descriptive statistics
or a numerical insight into your data.
On the other hand,
I actually prefer to begin with pictures,
graphics, visualizations, do those first
and then get numbers to provide precision.
That's in addition
to what you get from the graphics.
So in this one,
I'm going to show you the first of several
different visualizations
that we get from Genova movie.
The first one is Histograms.
Now, the dataset that I have open
is the iris data.
This is one of the example data sets.
I'm going to come over here
to exploration, click on that
and go to a descriptive.
Now by default
is going to try to do statistics.
I actually don't want statistics.
So I'm going to preempt that
and just remove this information
right now
so it's not going to produce a table.
So the table's gone.
What I am going to do,
however, is I'm going to select these
for quantitative variables.
These are measurements of the petals
and samples from three species of irises.
I'm going to put those in variables now.
Right now it's doing nothing
because I canceled all of the statistics.
But I need to come to this menu
which has plots,
and all I'm going to do is select
the first one, which is histogram.
Remember, a histogram is a chart
like a bell curve that shows you
how common each score is in distribution.
The width of each bar or the bin with
is arbitrary and a lot of other programs.
You can adjust that manually if you want.
You can't do that in
a movie, but truthfully, right now,
it just makes your life a little simpler.
What we have here is a pretty strong unit
modal distribution for super length.
We have
kind of normal with a big spike
in Siebel width.
We have a strong bimodal distribution
for petal length,
although it might be two separate
normal distributions maybe.
And then for pedal with again,
strong bimodal
with this really skewed distribution
here on the far left.
So this lets us know, by the way,
when you get a bimodal distribution
that generally tells you
that you have more than one distribution
happening there that got combined.
And that makes sense
because in this dataset,
we have three different species of irises.
And with that,
it makes sense to split this up
and look at each of the species
separately.
So I'm going to do this command again.
I'm going to come back up
to exploration to descriptive,
and then I'm going to
select the four variables again,
put those into with.
But this time I'm to add
this one and put species under split by.
I'm going to cancel out
these statistics again.
Those aren't what I'm looking for right
now, but I'm going to get histograms.
Now what we have are separate stacked
histograms for each of the three species.
Now it does a really nice thing in that
it puts all of them on the same scale.
So for instance, here on Siebel Length,
all three of these go from
four centimeters up to eight centimeters.
I'm going to click over here
to close the menu, and it puts
this three different species or three
different groups in different color.
So it's really easy to tell them apart.
And you can see status
as the lowest various of colors
kind of Middle East and Virginia
because a little higher for Siebel with
you can see that
we've got some big differences there
where the choice is now the highest
and verse of color in Virginia
are pretty similar to each other,
although we have an outlier on status. So
and then for petal
length, we have an enormous difference.
So tell us, is way down there at the end
and the other two
are pretty close to each other.
And then finally for Petal with
you can see the skewed distribution
that's really close to zero
for the Sentosa irises.
Whereas versus color is a little bit
medium and Virginia is at the highest.
And so this is a great first step
for getting
a visual exploration of your data
first by combining all the groups in one.
And when you get an indication that maybe
there's something going on there,
then splitting it up
to see if you can drill down
and get a little more explanation
for some peculiar results,
like bimodal distributions or skewness.
And that's what we get from these separate
stacked small multiple histograms,
which are very easy to do in a movie,
and really a great way
to start breaking down your data
when you're looking at the distribution
of a quantitative or continuous variable,
a histogram is usually the first choice,
and that's what I have right here.
And in the last video I made histograms
here.
I have it for the entire variable
with all three groups combined.
And then down below
I have the three groups
separated out
and this is a nice way to do it.
However, another all turn into that
truthfully I prefer is to smooth out
the choppiness of this a little bit with
something called a density plot.
And to do that, let's simply
click on the existing analysis.
One of the nice things about your movie
is that when you click on an analysis,
it brings up the menu that produced it.
And so here we have descriptive.
I've got the four quantitative
or continuous variables here.
I have all the statistics turned off
because I didn't want a table there
and I've got histogram right here.
Now the reason histogram
and density are both listed below.
The histograms title
is because it can layer them.
No, I'm
going to do that to show the relationship,
but then I'm going to separate it.
So I'm just going to click density
right here
and this will be laid
on top of the existing histograms.
And so what you can see over
here is our original histogram,
this little blobby kind of shape over it,
which is a lot
like a smoothed out histogram.
And you can see a similar shape
on all of these.
Now, it doesn't follow it really exactly
because it's averaging across,
but you see this same general trend strong
by modal distributions
and right here as well.
Now, to make it a
little clear, I'm
actually going to turn off the histogram
that'll leave us with
just the density plot.
You can see the density plotted without
the histograms and the scale adjusts.
And so it makes the pattern
a little more pronounced,
but that's our first indication.
We get these blobs
and you can see sort of unit model
unit models really kind of triangular,
but you know, kind of close
to normal, strong bimodal, strong bimodal.
And then we come down to this second set
and I'm going to do
those as well simply
by clicking on the analysis.
And this is where you have the four
variables, but they're split by species.
And again,
all I need to do here is click density
and that'll lay the density charts
on top of the existing histograms,
and then I'll turn off the histograms
again.
And I actually prefer to do density
instead of histograms
because it smooths out and makes
the pattern a little easier to see.
But you can see it does the same thing
where it colors them, it stacks them
by the three different groups
and I'm going to turn off histogram
so we can see what it looks like
without that.
And this is where the pattern
really kind of comes into focus.
We have the three different groups
and you can see the mounds are the piles
of the data in ways that make it clear
that the distributions are basic
you in a modal here,
but they're in different locations,
a little bit different in skewness
it come down to pedal length
and the differences become very clear
and I think that by using the smoothness
of the density plot, it becomes
a little easier to see the overall pattern
and not get distracted
by the jagged edges of the histograms.
And so density plots
are another really helpful way to look
at a quantitative or continuous variable,
either for all data at once
or breaking it down by subgroups.
The more you work with
data, the more you learn that outliers
can be a really serious problem.
They can throw off your analysis
and your conclusions dramatically.
And so you want to pay special attention
to the presence of outliers in your data.
And probably the easiest way to do
this is not with a histogram
or with a density plot,
but with a box plot.
So in this example,
which uses the iris data
and starts up
where we left off with the density plots,
I'm going to do box plots and show
how they relate to the density plots
and the extra insight we can get from them
in terms of identifying outliers.
Now to do this, I'm just going to click
on my existing density plot analysis,
and then when that opens up,
I'm going to come down here to plots
and I'm going to click box plot.
And you know,
this is in a separate column.
And what this means
is it's going to produce a separate chart.
So the density plots aren't to go away.
This will be in addition,
but I'll then remove the density plots.
So here come the box plots curl over.
We'll see that the box is directly
underneath the density charts.
And in the first one
there are no outliers.
This one, we get a few outliers in each.
And that's not surprising
because if you remember your statistical
terminology, this is basically
a kleptocratic distribution,
tends to have a lot of outliers
with people length.
We don't have outliers,
but That's because of the bimodal nature.
The middle part of the box
plot is spread out so much,
and then the same
thing is true here at the bottom again,
when it's spread out
like that, that's, you know, something
really unusual is going on with your data.
I'm going to turn off the density charts
in this analysis.
And so we'll have just
the box plots at this point.
Now, you can do the same thing
with grouped analyzes
where you split it by something.
So I'm going to close this analysis
for a moment and come down here
where we had our stacked density plots
showing the data
for the three different species.
If I click on that,
I can do the same thing that I did.
I can get a box plot,
I'll click box plot,
and it's going to show up
directly beneath each chart.
Now this time we lose the pretty coloring,
but it's easy to see what's going on.
We have an outlier for Virginia.
We have two outliers,
each for citizen Virginia.
You know, these are pretty symmetrical.
They don't look bad.
I'm going to come here
and turn off the density plots
and so we can have just the box plots
and then we come down to Petal with you.
We can see we got something really serious
going on here because this one is so
squished, its distribution is so narrow
and it's so far away from the others
that lets us know that we have something
really important going on.
And then the paddle length, the same idea.
And so box plots are a good way
of identifying outliers.
We don't have any massive outliers
in this data set,
which tells us
that we're in pretty good shape.
But what we do have are strongly differing
distributions.
On the other hand,
if you're doing something
like the analysis of variance,
that's kind of what you're looking for.
And this just confirms our insight
that the three species of iris
differ significantly
in some of their measurements.
The box plots are a good way
to check that.
And again, a good way to check for the potential influence of outliers in the data
jam movie
includes one really kind of unusual,
kind of funny looking graph.
It's called a violin and what it is
and is sort of the box
plot version of the density plot,
and it just kind of spreads out
and you'll see why it's called a violin.
I'm starting with the iris data
set from the example data.
And I'm using the box plots
that I created in the last video
and simply going to click here
where I have the four variables
and I'm not splitting them by anything.
I can come here over the plots.
And again, the reason violin's right here
is because
Jamo is able to stack
all three of these on top of each other.
You don't want to do that
because it gets really busy looking.
But I'm going to show you the relationship
between the box spot
and the violin plot
by simply adding it right here.
Let do that.
You get a shape that looks a little bit
like a Rorschach inkblot
that actually corresponds
to what's happening in the box plot here.
For instance, you can see that
we've got a lot of data here
in the middle, and that's where the violin
plot goes out the most.
We get a funny little manta ray
shaped one here because of our strongly
kleptocratic distribution.
And down here
you can see why it's called a violin plot,
because we get it comes out, it goes back
in, comes out because of the bimodal
distributions
that we have on these two variables.
Now, I'm
actually going to remove the box plot
so you can see
just the violin plot on its own.
And what we're left with
is really just a little bit of squiggles.
It feels like, again, a projective test.
It's a little hard for me to read,
but it's an interesting version.
Again, it's like a density plot,
but oriented the same direction
as the box plot.
You can, of course, do the same thing
with the subgroup analysis
that we have down here where we broke
the measurements by species.
I'm going to click on that
to open up this menu.
And there you can see we have species
there.
I'm going to click a violin and then I'm
actually going to also click a box plot.
Right now,
I know what we have feels like a little
set of drawing of ghosts or something,
but you can see the distributions
for the three different species.
And it really feels like
we're looking at a chart
of animal shapes
as a nice little bat down here.
But you can see this shows
that it's a strongly compressed range
because again, the outcome variable
petal length, it goes vertically here
and then petal with you can see again,
we have a very unusual distribution
for this dataset.
Well,
things are almost kind of sort of normal
for the various of color and the Virginia.
And so
the violin plot, not a very common choice,
but potentially an interesting one.
And it might be able to give you
some extra insight into your data
box plots
and violin plots are a nice way
of summarizing the distribution
of a quantitative or continuous variable,
but maybe you actually want
to see the data directly and dot plots
URL way that allow you to do that
and with the violin plots that I made
using the iris data from the example set,
and then I'm going to click
on the analysis to open up the commands
and I'm going to come back down here
to plots and move this up.
And what I'm going to do is simply add
data.
Now, a lot of times
you don't want to have things stacked
where you have more than one
kind of plot on top of another, the violin
and the data, it works kind of
well because the violins an empty shape.
And here you have the data in there.
Now, what this is,
is every data point in the dataset.
There's 150 in this particular case,
and they go from the lowest score
up to the highest score.
And you can see how they approximately
match the density of the violin plot.
Now, this is called a jitter chart
because every dot should be exactly
on the line here in the middle.
But that makes it hard to tell
how many there are in a particular place
because they might lay on
top of one another and so jittering is
at random, only spreading them out
a little bit to the left, it to the right.
So they're not usually
on top of each other
and it's a little easier
to see the density of the distribution.
I'll show you some others here.
On the other hand,
you have another choice
instead of just jittering.
If you're a nice and orderly person,
you can also select stacked
and what stack does.
Instead of distributing them out randomly,
it puts them exactly where they need
to go and arranges them out in mirror
image patterns as you go up the chart.
And so, again, this will appeal
to those of you who are very fastidious,
but now you can see a little clearer
the distribution of points at each value.
And you can see really how the violin plot
mimics that.
I'm actually going to leave
violin plot on.
Normally I would remove it
because the two go together nicely.
They don't compete
and then they're going to come down here
to where we have
our same violin plots
but broken down by the species.
I'm going to click on that
to bring up that analysis,
and then I'll click on data
and I'll leave it stacked.
Now, it's interesting, as I said, stacked,
but that appears to be jitter.
So I'm going to see
if I can get his attention
by switching back and forth from Girard
to Stack to if it changes anything.
It was just a small glitch, but by going
back and forth, we straighten it out.
And now you can see how the data are
arranged within each of the violin plots
and the height
and the width of each of the violin plots.
Now, it makes a little more sense.
And so a dot plot of this kind, either
Girard
or probably stacked, is a little easier
to read, lets
you see what's going into the box plots
or into the violin plots
unless you see the individual data points
that are going to drive your analysis.
The last kind of chart I want to show you
an exploration
is actually the simplest
and truthfully is often the most useful.
It's just a bar chart.
And all that does is it shows you
the number of cases in a category.
Now, for this example,
I'm going to go back to the bugs data
and this time
I'm only going to be focusing
on the gender, region and education
variables.
Those are the categorical or nominal ones.
And I have frequencies
for each of those over here.
First, I have the frequencies for each
variable without breaking them down.
So I have the number of female
and male respondents,
the frequencies for region where
most of the people are from North America
and the frequencies for education.
I'm going to click on this analysis
to bring up the menu.
And here you can see how those three got
put over here.
I turned off all the statistics.
I turned on frequency table.
That's how I got that.
And now I'm going to do
just one little click here.
I'm going to come and click bar chart
and you'll see that
J movie knows to do that
automatically when you have
nominal
that is categorical or ordinal variables.
And that's what I have here.
So I can click that
and then it's going to produce the bar
charts directly below the tables
that I already have.
You can see that it says Plot now
and then it's easy to see.
We have about twice as many women as men
and we have an awful lot of people
from North America
in this particular sample
and that the education
is spread around
in kind of a peculiar way.
But this is a good way of looking
at a categorical variable.
It's so much easier
to get them from a bars
and especially from bars,
because all they require
is a relative linear judgment
as opposed to a pie chart too.
Movie doesn't even do pie charts.
That's
because they're often harder to read.
So I'm going to close that one,
and then I'm going to come down
to where I have the tables here.
This is where I've broken it
down by gender.
So let me click on this one.
And you can see I'm getting a descriptive
analysis of education
split by gender, and that's why
we have education down the side here.
We have gender across the top.
And I've turned off all the statistics.
I have the frequency table on
and I do bar plot.
And what this is going to do
is give a paired bar plot
or grouped bar plot where it puts them
together for each group.
I'm going to close this window here
and then move this over a little bit
so you can see the whole thing.
And now what we have
are our six different levels of education
from advanced to some.
Again, these are in alphabetical order.
There's a natural order to these things
where more education
should be further to the right and less
education should be further to the left.
But we also have our gender
indicated by the colors.
So for instance,
we have the reddish orange for female in
sort of a teal for male and from
this is easy to see that
we have a lot more women in each category
with the exception of partial
over here where it's just
a couple of people in each in college.
But the other ones have about a 2
to 1 ratio that we have overall.
And so a bar chart and a grouped bar chart
is a simple way of
getting insight
from a categorical or nominal variable.
Again, often the easiest,
the simplest kind of chart
and really can be
the most informative when you're trying
to get some quick insights from your data.
So once you've conducted your analyzes
and you've created
all these amazing visualizations,
you want to be able to share them
with other people
so they can get the same insight out
of the data that you got in the process.
Fortunately,
Jamovi makes that easy to do,
and what I'm going to do here
is in the file, exploring tables and plots
is I have a table that I created
showing the measurements
for the iris data set,
and then beneath it I've created graphs
broken down by species
for each of the measurements,
and I want to show you
how to put these into Microsoft Word,
PowerPoint, Excel, and then Google
Docs slides and sheets.
Let's start with the table at the top
now, what you need to do is you come over
and you do an option click or control
click or a two finger click
and you get the table
and you can say Copy.
Now if you want to copy it, see,
it says it's a copy of it.
And now I'm going to go to word.
So I'll come down here.
I have word open
and I've got a word document
and then come right down here and I'm
going to paste it.
So go to edit and then paste.
And what you find is
it actually looks really beautiful.
It's nice. It is a little tiny bit funky.
Sometimes it has some columns in here
that are invisible.
There's a little in-between column
right there, but it looks really good.
Now, if we want to put that
into PowerPoint,
I'll come down here and open up
PowerPoint.
I'll come to this page
and I'll come over here
and I'll just press paste.
And now it looks kind of weird
because what it's actually pasting
is an estimate table.
You see, it
doesn't even give us the last row of data.
And then of course PowerPoint
wants to do pretty things with it.
I'm going to close that.
But this is a good table.
It worked better in word.
Let me go back to word
and we'll take a look at it again.
It worked.
We got all the lines of data.
It did not work
so well. We went into PowerPoint.
What's usually the best
when you have a table is actually
to put it into a spreadsheet.
I'm going to go to Excel
here and I'm just going to do
the paste command.
And now you can actually see
that it has these empty columns
in between each of the measurements.
So you'll need to move things around
a little bit, you'll need to put the pedal
width, take it from here
and put it over here and so on.
But it also allows you to easily
rearrange, resize things,
make them the way exactly you want.
And so copying a table,
sticking it into a spreadsheet
like Excel is often
the best way to work with tabular output.
There is one other option
I just want to mention.
Let me come back to Jamovi,
and you may have noticed
that you had the option to save.
Now this gives you two different options.
You can save it as a PDF
and I'll just call this table pdf
and once that saved
you see it says is exported.
I'm going to come down to my downloads
folder and I will simply click on that.
It's a very pretty PDF, looks great.
The other option is to save it
not as a PDF but as an h html file.
So I'll call that table
and it's going to put HTML on.
I'm going to save that and then I'm going
to come down and open up that file.
It will open up in a web browser
and there it is.
It looks exactly
like what we had in the movie.
So that's one way of doing all of that.
Now, let me show you how this works
with Google Docs and slides and sheets.
It works a little differently.
I'm going to take this table
which I've copied.
I'll just copy it again. Copy.
And I'm going to go to Google Docs.
I'm going to come right here to this.
I've got a doc right here to come down
a little bit and I'm going to hit paste.
And unfortunately, it doesn't always work
well on this computer.
It's not letting select anything.
There seems to be some kind of glitch
and you can see that
the cursor stop blinking
and it won't let me scroll.
So what I'm actually going to do
is I'm going to close that page
by and then I'm going to open it back up.
And when I do that, it's there
and I can scroll and you know,
you can work with it.
I don't know why it does that.
It's a little frustrating
and obviously things need to be resized
and rearranged a little bit.
But there it is.
It's in Google Docs.
If I want to put it in a presentation,
in Google Slide presentation,
I can click on this page
and I can press paste right there.
Now it's done two things.
First off, it's pasted the table,
but it's also pasted this other square.
And truthfully,
I have no idea what that is.
It's invisible.
I'm going to click off to the side
and then try to come back and click
the square and get rid of it.
Doesn't really matter.
And this one, I can simply resize
it by dragging things over
like this, That's not so bad.
That one works pretty well.
But the best way to do this by far
again, is to go into a spreadsheet.
So I've got a spreadsheet here.
I just press paste in nicely.
It looks exactly like what we had in Excel
with the empty columns in between.
Except this time
the column names are in the right place.
And so if you have tabular data,
you can put it directly into a word
document, a Google doc or a presentation.
But it works best
to put it into a spreadsheet
which allows you
to manipulate the tabular data.
But often instead of a table, people are
more concerned about sharing the graphics.
So let's go back to Jamovi
for a moment.
And when I click on this, I'm
going to come down and I've got a graph.
I actually have several graphs here.
Let's take this one right here, petal
length and I'm going to do an option.
Click this a two finger, click on my Mac
and I can save it and I can save it
as either a PDF or as an email
like I did with the earlier ones.
And it's going to look exactly the same,
but I wish I had a copy and paste it.
I'm going to go
copy since it's been copied.
Now let me go back to word.
I come here into word, I click down here
to scroll up a little bit.
I press paste beautiful.
It looks and we're good to go.
And obviously if you want to,
you can resize that.
I can click on that
and drag it down a little bit.
Similarly, if I want to work in
PowerPoint, I can just open this up.
I can go to a new slide and I can paste it
and there it is and it wants to give me
a lot of abilities to animate and stuff.
I will click that,
but that's a great way
to share your information.
It's big, it's clear. It's it's nice.
By the way,
these have transparent backgrounds. So
if you put it on a slide of the different
background, it'll show up that way.
And so that's a nice way.
Just copy and paste things, work
a little differently in Google Docs
and then Google Slides
and let me show you how that works.
I won't go back to my browser here
and I'm
going to try to paste in this image.
I'm going to come down here
and I'm going to press paste.
And what happens is it
says, unable to create some
images, dismiss,
and it acts like it's doing
something, but,
you know, it's not going to get anywhere.
So I'm just going to delete that.
And the same thing happens in Google
Slides.
The easiest way around
this is to do a small intermediate step,
and actually this is a good thing
to know how to do.
Anyhow, let's go back to your movie
and I'm going to take this graph.
I'm going to right click on it.
And instead of doing copy,
if I'm going to go into Google Docs
or Google Slides, I'm
going to want to save it first.
Now, by default,
it wants to save it as a PDF file.
And then what's actually nice about that
is PDFs are infinitely scalable because.
They're vector graphics.
That's nice,
but I don't want to do that for this one.
I want to save it as an image file
so I can to come down here to format
and it can save it either as a PNG file,
a ping file which has transparent
background that's kind of usually used.
But you have two other options, the SVG
and the EPS.
And so depending on the programs
that you're using,
you may want to use one of those others.
But I like the PNG
even though it's now a set resolution, so
I'm going to come right here and I'm going
to save it as a graphics. PNG
and now I can go back to
my document here
and I can come down to my downloads
folder and I just drag it in
and there it is
and I can do the same thing in my slide
and come right here to my slide.
I'm going to go to my folder and drag in
and I'm going to center it.
And there you have it.
I have now successfully imported
both tables and graphics
into Microsoft Word and PowerPoint
to table and to the spreadsheet
and similar things for Google
Docs, Google slides and Google Sheets.
Although the way you go about it
is sometimes a little different.
But all of these make it possible for you
to take the analysis that you worked
very hard on in your movie
and find a way to share your insights.
Find a way to share the possibilities
you got in your data with other people.
In our next chapter on T tests into movie,
we're going to go from that piece
to the whole.
That is, we're going to start with
inferential statistics, which allows us
to describe a sample of data
that we have in front of us
and then use that to describe a population
something larger
and more than what we observed.
We are using the sample to infer things
about the population and the t test
is the simplest and most direct way
to get started with this.
In this chapter, we're going to talk about
three kinds of t tests.
First, we'll look at the independent
samples, tests
that you use to compare
two groups means to each other.
The second is the paired samples
or repeated measures.
T Test for you looking for changes
in scores from time one to time,
two for one group of people,
and third is the one sample teachers
where you're taking one samples
and comparing it to a known population.
Mean taken together this three these serve
as an excellent introduction
to the concept of inferential statistics
and going from the specifics
of your sample at hand and generalizing
to the population at large,
one of the simplest,
inferential tests that you can do
is the independent samples t test.
This is where you comparing
the means of two different groups.
Very easy to do in a movie
and you can actually do several at a time,
although there are going to be separate
comparisons to show you how this works.
I'm using the example data set bugs,
which talks about how much people
want to get rid of bugs that are either
low, disgusting, low fright,
low discussing high fright
or through high disgust in high fright.
And they try it on a zero
not at all to ten very much scale.
And we have information about people's
level of education.
The region they live
in, gender is coded as male and female.
And so I'm going to use the gender one
and compare
the male and female respondents
on these four different variables.
Now, before you do a t test,
before we start doing inferential
tests, it's a good idea to take a look
at the variables and to see how
well they meet the assumptions,
because certain things like normality or
similarity
and variance are important for a T test.
So I'm going to come over here
to exploration and descriptive,
and then I'm going to pick my four outcome
variables right here.
I'll put them here under variables,
and then I'm going to split
the whole thing by gender.
It's not really the table
that I'm most worried about,
although you can see that
we have more female respondents
than males.
It's not a big deal
and the means are pretty well.
There's a one point difference.
There's a two thirds,
there's a half point.
So they vary.
What I really want here are the plots.
So I'm going to come over here to plots
and I'm going to get a density histogram
or density chart
and box plots
for each of these comparisons.
And so what you see is these ones are kind
of sort of close to normal.
These are female respondents here.
These are male respondents here.
Distributions are pretty similar.
The box plots show
there's no outliers there.
Actually, there's a lot of overlap.
Okay, here's where we start getting non
normal distributions,
which is in a sense a problem.
But because of the central limit theorem
and because we're really working
with sampling distributions, it's
not the end of the world.
We can still go ahead and do things.
We got a couple of outliers,
similar distributions.
Okay, so now we see a little bit
what's going on.
So with that as context,
I'm now going to do the regular T test
and so I'm going to come over here
to T tests
and do independent samples t test.
And all I need to do
is pick my dependent variables
or you can just call them
outcome variables
and dependency for usually for
when it's a randomized experiment.
And then the variable is the thing
that I want to split them
into two different groups on.
I'm going to use gender here,
so I'll click that over here
and it gives us this table by default
and it's going to give us the T test
and the P value,
which is for the significance test.
And we can see from this right now
that actually there are no significant
differences between the male
and female respondents on any of these.
The closest we had was a P value .161.
And the rule of thumb is
it needs to be less than .05
to be considered
statistically significant.
This one down here is a lot closer.
It's 0.06, nearly significant.
That's this last comparison right here.
But there's a
lot more you
can get from the T test function in GMV.
And so I'm going to do
a few of these things
now if you are familiar
with Bayesian statistics
where we can incorporate that, it's
kind of nice.
I'm going to come over here
and get the mean difference.
So that's the mean of the women, minus
the mean of the men.
And you can see they're about 2.55..606.
Okay. I'm also going to get
the confidence interval,
which by default is better than 95%.
And if I scroll this over a little bit,
you can see the whole thing
and also you can see that they're negative
on one side, positive on the other.
So they include zero, which
is consistent with the differences
not being statistically significant.
I'm also going to get the effect size
and this
case it uses Cohen's D, which tells you
how many standard deviations
there are between the two groups means.
And in this case,
they're pretty small from close to zero
to the biggest point
for standard deviations.
I'm also going to get normality checks.
So we know that the distributions
are not entirely
normal, meaning bell curve shaped.
And the test that we have
here is the SHAPIRO Wilk test.
And it lets us know that really
none of them are exactly normal.
We could tell that by looking at them.
But again,
it's really not the end of the world
because we're
using the sampling distributions
and not the raw distribution.
I'm also going to check
for equality of variances.
That's something
that's also important for the T test.
It says that the two groups
need to be spread out approximately the
same amount, and this is going to use
Levine's test for the quality of variance.
And you can see on this one,
none of these are significant.
In fact, they're all really
0.4 is the lowest.
And so there's no significant difference
in the variability
of the two distributions,
which is what we want.
I'm also going to click descriptive
and that's going to
give me the means
and whatnot of each of the groups.
And so you can see the mean, the median
standard division and the standard error
which is used in the inferential tests.
And then finally the descriptive plots.
And in this case,
what it gives us are confidence intervals
for the means as well.
It shows the median for each group.
And since these are
the ones that correspond most closely
to the inferential test of the T test,
it's probably the best one for actually
whether there's a difference.
The general rule of thumb here
is that if the confidence interval
that's a vertical line for a one group
overlaps with the mean
the other group, then they're usually not
significantly different.
And we've got a lot of overlap here,
a lot of overlap
and these ones are pretty separate.
And so this one was nearly significant.
Anyhow, that's how you can do
the independent samples
t test
using a single categorizing variable.
In this case, I used male
and female respondents and you can use
several outcome variables simultaneously.
And it's an excellent
first step in getting a look
at what's happening in your data
through inferential statistics.
Sometimes you have data
from one group of people
and you're comparing them either before
and after some kind of intervention or.
You comparing them
on two separate measurements
and you want to compare each person's
score with their own score.
So you're looking for changes
from one variable or one time another.
And this is when you want to use
a paired samples t test.
And it's very easy to do here in Germany
for this example,
I'm using the same bugs data talks
about how much people want get rid of bugs
or insects that are low disgusting,
low fried, up to high disgusting and high
frightening goes from zero,
which is the lowest
to ten, which is the highest.
I'm going to come
up here and I'm going to use
paired samples t test.
That's the test that we're doing here.
And what we have to do
is we have to specify pairs of variables.
Now, there are a few different ways
that you can select the pairs
that you want to do.
So, for instance, you can click
one variable and push it over here
and then you simply click
the second variable.
So maybe I'll do this one.
And so that sets up a pair.
You can also click one and do a command
or control click and select the other.
So you get both of them there
at the same time and that gets a pair.
Or if you have a bunch of compare scenes
all in a row that makes sense to do,
you can select the whole thing
by just doing a shift click.
And what is going to do is it's going
to put the variable all together in order.
So number one goes with number two
and number three goes with number four
and so on.
Now what I have here, by the way, is
a violation of the independence
of observations.
Normally, you wouldn't want to be doing
the analysis quite like this
because we're looking
at the same comparisons in different ways.
This is more like a post hoc test
from an analysis of variance, but
the procedures for doing this
are the same,
and so it's a valid damage
titration of the process in your movie.
So what I have right here
are my four pairs of variables
and you can see that right over here.
It's done all the tests already.
We can see that, in fact, all four
comparisons are statistically significant.
So in one sense, that's the simple thing
and we can stop right there.
Fortunately,
J movie gives us some other options.
I want to take a quick look at them.
Let's look, for instance,
at the mean difference.
How big is the difference?
Or rather, we
also want to look at the mean difference.
And what that does is
it gets the difference
between the first variable
and the second variable for each person.
That's a different score and then it gets
the average of that difference.
And so here we have the differences
and you can see these ones went down
across the comparison.
One went up, by the way,
whether it's positive
or negative is arbitrary,
is simply a matter
of which of these you put first
and which one you put second.
And we have the standard error.
I'm also going to get the confidence
interval for the mean difference.
I got to scroll over a little bit
so you can see that
we'll get the effect size,
which is Cohen's D
and in this case it says how many
standard deviations there are
between
these scores at time one and time
two or the scores on the first variable.
On the second variable.
Really what it is,
is the mean of the different scores
divided by the standard deviation
of the different scores.
And you can see
these ones are actually pretty big.
That's almost a full standard deviation.
We can also get descriptive,
which gives us the means and the medians
of the variables.
We can do a normality check, which can be
important because t tests are valid
when they're working with normal
or bell curve shape distributions.
On the other hand, not really the raw
distribution that's important here,
but the sampling distribution
and that's a slightly different thing.
And even though have some statistically
significant things here, I usually don't
personally worry about it very much
because it's the sampling distribution.
As long as you have a large enough sample
and we're pretty good,
you're probably okay.
I'm going to finish
with the descriptive plots which
give us confidence intervals
for the differences.
So I'm going to wait a
second here while it updates
and then
we'll scroll down here to the plots.
And so what this shows us are the mean
and the confidence interval for each of
the variables in the comparison.
So this is low disgust,
low fright and high disgust. High fright.
That's the biggest difference
available in the data.
And you can see
they're very far away from each other.
There's no overlap at all.
The square is the median.
And what's funny here is
you can see the median is actually
above the confidence interval
because we had a ceiling effect there.
People gave really high scores to that
and the means only lower
because there were outliers on the low end
and. You can see similar distributions
for some of the other ones.
And so this is a good way of making
comparisons for the same group of people
on one variable versus another where
they're looking at two different things.
Or often when you're doing something before and after a particular intervention,
the simplest
version of T test
is the one sample T test,
which allows you to compare
the mean of a single group
that you have data from
to a chosen hypothesized value.
It might be a national average,
it might be a theoretical value
that represents the baseline against
which you want to compare everything.
Now, this is really easy to do
in your movie here.
I'm using the example dataset Big Five,
which contains a number of ratings
where people evaluate themselves
on five major personality characteristics
neuroticism,
extroversion, openness to experience,
agreeableness and conscientiousness.
And these are all rated on a 1 to 5 scale.
And I want to show you how we can evaluate
all five of these simultaneously.
But before you jump into T tests,
you always want to do
some exploratory analysis
to see if your data are going to work
well with the intended analysis.
So let's go first over here to exploration
and let's go to the descriptive.
And what I'm going to do here
is I'm going to pick the five variables
and put all of them
into the variable list.
By the way,
Jamovi updates frequently and in fact,
from the time
that I started this this morning
and I'm finishing it now, it's updated
and we have a few extra options
available now under descriptive.
So here we have the mean, the median,
the minimum and maximum by default.
I also want to get the standard deviation
and I may also want to get,
for instance, a normality test.
And this is one of the new features.
This is just a p value that lets us know
whether something is normal or not.
And so this one is nearly not normal.
This one's far away from normal
and so on and so forth.
The important thing
here actually is going to be the graphics
and I even have some more choices here.
I'm going to do a density charts
like a histogram smoothed out.
I'm also going to do box plots
which are good for identifying.
And then I'm going to do the new option
here,
which is a Q coupon,
which stands for Quantile Quantile Plot.
And it shows how well the observed data
match up against, for instance,
a normal distribution
that has the same mean
and standard deviation
as the observed data.
So I'm going to click that as well.
And the charts look a little different.
They're colored differently,
but here we have
neuroticism that looks basically normal
and the box plot shows that it's basically
symmetrical with the EU high outliers in
the Q Q plot.
It shows information on a diagonal,
and if all the dots were exactly on
the diagonal,
that would tell you that the matches
what you would expect
from a normal distribution.
We're really close here. We have
some small variations at the tails,
which is how it normally works.
Extroversion,
you see, it's a little bit skewered.
We've got some low outliers and you can
see that happening here at the bottom.
Openness is symmetrical.
It's slightly funny looking.
You can see how it tapers
off here in here.
But these are not major deviations.
They're statistically significant
because it's a large sample here.
We have some low outliers on agreeableness
because most people want to say
that they're really agreeable
and then conscientiousness,
same general idea.
And so that's
some of the important background.
And what I saw here
is nothing really worrisome.
And this is just confirmation
that our data
probably work well with the assumptions
of a one sample t test,
which includes normality,
and we can go ahead and do our analysis.
So now I'm going to come over here
to t tests and click on one sample t test
and when
I do that, I can select my variables.
I'm actually going to select
all five of them simultaneously.
You only want to select multiple variables
if they have
the same null value
that you're comparing them to.
Now, a lot of times that no value
is going to be zero.
That's a silly thing to do in this case
because zero is not even in the scale
these are rated on a 1 to 5 scale.
And so what I'm going to do
is I'm going to come down here and I'm
going to change the test value from 0 to 3
because that's the midpoint of a
1 to 5 scale.
And when I do that,
you see how this table over here updates
it's doing student's t test.
It's the one sample T test
and can see that
all of them the mean is
significantly different from three.
This is not a surprise
because most of these
there's a positive
or a desirable end of the scale.
People to be agreeable,
they want to be open.
And so we tend to have high values.
But I'm also going to look
at the mean difference how far away are
each of these variables means
from the hypothesized value of three?
And you can see
they're not really big differences.
You know, 2/10 of a point,
about six of a point.
We're going to get the effect size
for each one of these, which compares
how far the mean is of the sample data
to the population.
Mean divided by the standard deviation.
And here because the standard deviations
are not big, this value of Cohen's
D the common effect size for
this is pretty big.
For instance,
openness is 1.7 standard deviations
above the hypothesized mean a three.
That's a big effect.
We can also get the confidence interval
for the mean difference by
which is going to add a few columns here
and you can see that it's all positive
because our means or above,
except in the case of neuroticism,
because people don't want to be neurotic,
we can also get a normality check
which is going to put this separate
column here.
We have a SHAPIRO Wilk test
and this actually these p values.
Here are what we had up at the top table
when we checked off under descriptive.
So that actually is a more convenient way
to do it.
I'm also going to do descriptive
s, which repeats a lot of the same
information we had before, but sometimes
it's nice to have it down here.
An important thing is to look at the see
the standard error,
which is the standard deviation divided
by the square root of the sample size.
And you see that
these are tiny, tiny values.
They two hundredths of a point.
And that is what leads to a very funny
descriptive plot
which normally shows you
a confidence interval for the mean.
But when our standard error
is microscopic,
you end up with invisible confidence
intervals.
In each case here,
the circle shows the mean of the variable
and the square show is the median
and they're super close.
And you can tell, for instance,
that openness is a little higher,
even though at this point
the labels don't automatically adjust.
So they are a little squished together.
But this Latino that yeah, everything's
different from three three
would be straight across right here.
Four of them are above
one of them neuroticism is below.
But this is a very compact and concise
way of looking at several variables
simultaneously.
And if you're simply trying to get
a first quick look at how your sample
data matches up with some expectations
about the population,
then this is a very
good and quick way to go.
In our last chapter on the T test,
we looked at methods
that allow you to compare
two things at a time two groups where
you're looking at the mean between them.
But what if you have more than two things
you want to compare?
Or maybe you even have a whole bunch of
different groups that you want to compare
and you're trying to get insight
into how those groups differ
and how they affect the outcomes
that you're interested in.
Well, in that case,
you're going to want to use analysis
of variance, also called ANOVA or ANOVA.
And in this chapter,
we're going to look at a few variations
on the ANOVA theme
that GMAT makes available to us.
The first is the standard factorial ANOVA.
This is where you're looking at
how one factor,
a categorical variable
that splits people into different groups
influences your quantitative
or continuous outcome variable.
You may have one factor.
You may have several factors
simultaneously.
Also, look at the repeated measures
analysis of variance
where you're looking at people across
more than one measure mean time.
Then we get into some things
that really are rather sophisticated
the analysis of covariance and kova
and the multivariate
analysis of covariance,
where you have several outcome variables
and you have some quantitative variables
you're putting into the equation as well.
It's an amazing thing
that your movie makes these available
and it makes them easy to work with.
Then finally, we'll look
at a couple variations on non
parametric analysis of variance
where instead making an analysis
based on means and standard deviations.
We're looking at ranks and taken together,
all of these variations
on the analysis of variance give you
a much broader of situations that you can
analyze and a lot more potential
for getting inside out of your data.
And so let's take a closer
look at the analysis of variance.
Certain fields of
research tend to use different methods.
So for instance,
if you're doing economics research, it's
very common to use linear regression.
If you're doing experimental research
is extremely common
to use the analysis of variance
that's also called ANOVA or another.
And what it lets you do is it lets you
compare the means of two or more groups.
Also breaking them up by one or more
categorical variables simultaneously.
To demonstrate this in terms of
I'm going to use the built in example,
data set tooth growth.
Now it's a curious topic.
It's about the growth of teeth
in guinea pigs who were given
one of two different supplements,
either vitamin C, which is shown here
as Vichy or Orange Juice,
which is written as OJ.
And then it comes in three different doses
500, 1002 thousand,
I assume it's milligrams
and they're looking at the length
of the teeth that's Len here.
And what we can do is
we can look at the combined effect
of the supplement and the doses to,
see how those jointly as well
as separately affect the tooth growth
in these guinea pigs in this experiment.
But before we get started
with the analysis of variance,
we need to do a little bit of background
work.
This is always an important first step
and we need to look at the variables,
both the outcome variable.
Len All by itself
and then breaking it down
by the categories that we're going to use
in the analysis of variance.
So I'm going to come over here
to exploration
and click on descriptive,
and all I'm going to do
here is I'm going to come down
and select Len for length,
and I just
need a little bit of basic stuff here.
We have 60 observations total.
We have a mean median minimum and maximum.
Great.
What I really want though are the plots.
So if this isn't already,
you just click on it to get plots
and I'm going to get the density chart,
which is like a histogram,
a box plot,
which is good for showing outliers
and a cute Q plot
that stands for Quantile Quantile Plot,
which is a way of assessing how closely
the observed distribution matches
a theoretical bell curve or normal
distribution, some of the same parameters.
And so when I scroll down here,
I see that Len length is all it's
basically in the models,
not exactly a normal distribution,
you know, it's
not pathologic cli different
see it's symmetrical and the box.
But there are no outliers
and the quantile quantile plot
is a little funny kind of waving.
If it were a perfect bell curve,
every point would fall exactly
on that diagonal line.
But it's not too far off.
It's not going to cause any real problems.
On the other hand,
I also want to break it down
by the groups that we're going to use it.
So I'm going to close this dialog
and I'm going to do it again,
except this time I'm going to take Len.
That's my length,
that's the outcome variable.
I put that there
and then I'm going to split it by both sub
and dose that supplement and dosage.
And it's going to give me a really long
table here where it's breaking down
the end for each of these
and the number of missing
and so on and so forth.
And while that might be really important,
we'll get a condensed version of it later.
What I really want right
now, though, are the charts.
Again, I'm going to ask for density
and box plot and Q, Q plot.
If I scroll down
and I'm going to move this
over just a little bit
so we can see more of it.
What I have is paneled
density plots,
so we have here orange juice,
which conveniently is in orange and Vichy
for vitamin C on the bottom.
And we see, yeah, they're not really
perfect normal distributions.
I mean, this one's kind of close,
the other ones are a little wavy
on the other. And that's
because they're also very small samples.
There's not many observations
within each category,
but they're not again,
they're not pathologically different.
We see we have some outliers
here in the box plots.
There's an outlier right there.
That's for vitamin C at a 1000
milligram dose,
and there's another one for OJ.
But again, not terrible.
And then here
are the quantile quantile plots.
And we don't have many observations
in each group.
So we have
the dots are easy to distinguish,
but again, not horribly different.
So I think we're pretty good and ready
to go ahead with the analysis of variance
because we seem to some of the core
assumptions of the technique.
So what I'm going to do
is I'm going to come over to ANOVA
or ANOVA for analysis of variance,
and I'm going to click this
first one analysis of your entire ANOVA.
And what you have here
is an option to do either
what's called a one way or one factor
analysis of variance.
That's where you have a single variable
like for instance, supplement,
and you're looking at how that affects
the outcome variable.
Len Or length in this case.
But you can also
put in more than one category
and you can look at the interaction
between them
because that's the most common approach
in many fields,
especially in experimental research.
That's what I'm going to demonstrate here.
So I'm going to take Len
and put it into independent variable
and I'm going to take setup and dose.
I'm going to do a shift click to get
both of them and put them over here.
And it puts it under fixed factors.
And you can see the analysis of variance
table is there and it's filling up
and we get our immediate results.
See that for instance, the supplement,
if I come way over here, that's a big
value for F and the probability value
which is used for statistical significance
testing is really low.
It's less than .05,
which is the common cutoff
for statistically significant findings.
So we have a significant main effect,
meaning supplement
makes a difference on the tooth length
all by itself.
Same thing is true for dose.
In fact, it makes an enormous difference.
You can see that the value of 92, it's
going to be much less than 001.
And then there's also an interaction.
So we're going to want to get
a little more detail about all of this.
The first thing I'm going to do
is I'm going to get an effect size.
The effect size that's generally used for
analysis of variance is called
ETA squared.
That's this little Greek letter
that kind of looks like a lowercase
and it's an ETA.
Now, if we had a one way
analysis of variance,
we could do the regular H squared.
But because we have these interactions,
we should do what's called a partial
eight esqueda, which looks at the unique
contribution of each of these factors.
That's what showed up right here.
We have an RN squared,
a P partial and A squared
and it goes from 0 to 1
and it can be interpreted
as the proportion
of variance in the outcome variable
then that can be associated
with that particular factor.
And we get a lot for CEP, we get 20.4
for dose, we get
a huge amount, 77.3
and then we have this 13.2.
And again, these don't add up to one,
but they give you an idea
of the relative strength
of each of these things put together.
What I'm going to do then is I'm going
to go through some of the options.
Now you can specify the specific model
I'm using, the very general approach,
which looks at the two main effects
for the two categorical nominal variables
that I'm using as predictor variables
and their interaction.
That's how I want to do it.
So I'm just going to leave that alone.
I'll close that.
The assumption checks homogeneity tests
because your different groups are supposed
to have approximately the same amount
of spread in the outcome variable.
So I'm going to click that one and that's
going to bring up a new table here.
We're doing the test for homogeneity
of variance using Levine's test.
And what we have here
is the important part is this P value.
At the end it's point one or three,
so it's more than oh five.
So it's not a statistically significant
difference.
That's good.
We're also going to get a Q
Q plot of the residuals
or the variability in the data
that's left over
after we control for SUP and dose
and the interaction.
And again, if it were perfectly uniform,
which is kind of what you want,
it would be right on the diagonal,
but it's really close, so
it looks like it meets the assumptions
of the analysis of variance.
I'm going to close that.
Now you have an option of specifying
specific contrasts in your design,
especially if you don't want to do
just this omnibus main effect.
Me In effect, interaction.
This is a more complicated procedure.
I'm not going to get into it
except to let you know that it's there
and you have several choices
for how you make those contrasts.
I'm going to close that
and come to post-hoc tests,
and this is when you find
significant effect,
you need to determine where it is now.
It's easy if you only have two levels or
categories within your nominal variable.
So for instance, for soap,
we just have orange juice and vitamin C.
So if there is a difference,
we know that's where it is.
But for dosage,
where there are three levels, 501,002
thousand milligrams, you don't
necessarily know exactly where they are.
And it's more complicated
with the interaction
where there are six possible groups there.
And so what we're going to do
is I'm just going to select all of these
and move them all over to the right.
And we're going to get a big table
that looks at possible
cell by cell comparisons.
Now it is a lot
and you get to choose the correction.
A lot of people use the CFA
or the BONFERRONI.
I personally prefer the Tukey test.
That's from John Tukey who developed it.
And what we see for instance
is that oh JVC
well there's only one comparison
possible there.
Yeah. That's significant
for the dosages that
we see that all three of them are
significantly different from each other
and then the interaction,
it gets a little more complicated
because there's a lot
of possible comparisons here,
but you see that
not every one of them
is statistically significant.
We have a few that aren't,
but that's going to be a lot easier
to figure out if what we do is
we look at the charts,
we get the descriptive plots,
and so what I'm going to do,
they're going to take the supplement
and put that on the horizontal axis
and the dose and make that separate lines.
And then we'll get a 95%
confidence interval.
And we've come down here, it
sometimes takes a second for Jamovi to catch up.
You have here is orange juice on the left,
vitamin C on the right,
and the three dosage levels,
this is 500 milligrams, 1005 hundred.
And what we see here is that, yeah,
the 500 is the lowest
orange juice, a little higher than vitamin
C, that the 1000
is definitely higher on both of those,
but about the same amount.
But things flatten out
when we get to 2000.
In fact, there's no difference between
orange juice and vitamin C at 2000,
and there's really no difference
between orange juice at 1002 thousand.
And so that lets us know
really where the important differences
are in the data.
Now, the last thing is
we have a couple of additional options
and we can get the descriptive statistics.
Now, this is going to mirror to a certain
extent the statistics we did
at the very beginning
when we were checking things out.
But it's going to create this small table
that looks at the two variables
crosses in with each other
and gives us really the bare minimum,
the number of observations
within each cell, the mean for that
particular cell
and the standard deviation.
And now you have the data that actually
is shown in this chart right here.
So for instance, we have this 7.98
and the 13.23 way down low.
And you can do some more detailed
analysis there if you want.
And so this is the walk through
of the analysis of variance in MRV.
Again, what we did is the preliminary work
by looking at the outcome variable
on its own
and breaking it down by the categories
that we were using to predict
in this case what the supplement was
and what the dosage was.
And then doing
the analysis of variance with interactions
and several of the options
that Jamari gives us makes it very simple
and is a good way to break up
your data to get the results,
especially of an experimental analysis.
Any time you're analyzing data,
you are making comparisons.
You may be making them explicitly
or you may be making them implicitly.
They comparison.
That's usually most important
in research is, for instance,
a control or baseline condition versus
some sort of experimental or manipulated
or intervention condition.
The idea is that if
people are randomly assigned
to one condition or another,
then the differences
between people balance out.
And you can look the effect
of just that manipulation.
But a really interesting and powerful
alternative to this and powerful meaning
statistically powerful.
Easier to find the effect fewer people
is what's called
a repeated measures design.
And this is where everybody in your study
gets to serve as their own control,
their own comparison or baseline.
No way you do that is by gathering data
from them in more than one condition.
If you have four conditions,
you get it in all four conditions,
and then you compare the change
one condition to another for each person.
Again, a much more powerful design
if your study allows for it.
Now the example data set that I want to
use is the Bugs dataset,
and this is where everybody in the study
was asked to make evaluations
about bugs in four different categories
bugs meaning insects.
They looked at insects.
They were either low on disgust
and low on fright, low on disgust,
high on fright, high distress, low
in fright and high disgust, high fright.
And the thing they're being asked is
how much you want to get rid of this bug.
And it goes from zero and not at all.
Butterflies are very pretty.
Nobody wants to get rid of them
to high disgust, high fright,
which might be really big cockroaches
or something like that.
And people want to get rid of them.
And so what this means
is that people are making evaluations
in each of these different categories
and they get to serve
as their own control.
And this allows for extra power,
although it also introduces
a lot of additional complications
into the analysis.
One of the nice things about JMB
is that it actually has the ability
to do this kind of repeated measures,
analysis of variance and other programs
that functionality may not be there
or may have to pay extra for it.
But here we have a built in right away.
Now, as I do in all the analysis,
before you do
the actual analysis, you want to do
some of the background checks.
So let's take a quick look at these four
variables, these outcome variables.
I'm going to come here
to explore in descriptive.
And even though we've looked
at these in other videos, it's
worth doing them again right here.
And we're going to get
some statistical summaries.
But I actually find it
a lot easier to use the plots.
And so I'm going to come down here
to histograms, actually,
and so I'm going to come down here
to Density.
Click on that.
Now, unfortunately, I can't get side
by side density plots for each of these.
I would like that
and maybe that'll be available
in the future version of your movie.
But right now what I can do
is I can look at these distributions
and I can compare them one to the other
half.
Here is lower disgust, a little fright
where you see it bumps up against ten
and it goes all the way down to zero
loads, gets high fright
almost really goes down to zero.
We get things a lot closer to ten.
Hi. Discuss a little fright again
pretty close to ten
and then high discuss high fright.
Basically
Everybody wants to get rid of those bugs
out. But now what we can
do is instead of looking
at the distributions overall,
we can look at the changes
from one to another.
So what I'm going to do is I'm going
to come here to the analysis of variance
or ANOVA or ANOVA,
and I'm going to select repeated measures.
ANOVA Now the way you set this up
may not be immediately obvious
if you haven't done this before,
because you have to specify
how the various measurements
fall into the categories or the overall
that you want to combine.
So it's asking
for my repeated measures factors,
and what I have is disgust and fright.
And so I'm going to double click on this
first thing
right here,
and I'm going to write the word disgust.
And then I hit return and it asks me
what is the first level of disgust?
And I'm going to call it low disgust.
It might not be high and low.
You might be doing right or left
or up or down or something like that.
And I'm going to do that for the next one.
Now I'm going to skip over level three
and go to our AM or repeated measures
factor two, which is fright.
And for that I put low fright
and I put high fright.
By the way,
you see that it's filling in over here
and it's also coming down right here.
And what it wants me to do right now
is to come over and find the variables
that correspond
to the combination of these factors.
So which cell, which variable has the
outcome for the low disgust, low fright?
Well, fortunately, it's abbreviated that
LDL stands for low disgust left right.
So I just drag that over
and then low disgust,
high fright goes right here.
High disgust, low fright.
HD Olaf goes there and then finally high
disgust, high fright goes right down here.
And so now it knows where the data is
and it knows
how to pass them into the variables
that we're interested in.
And it does the analysis right here.
Now, if we want to,
we can put in a between subjects
factor like gender as well.
That makes it a lot more complicated.
So I'm going to leave it out
for right now.
But what you see here is, that
disgust changed how much people want
to get rid of the bugs, fright changed
how much they wanted to get rid of them.
And there wasn't really an interaction
between them.
So disgust and fright
didn't depend on each other.
And so that is our initial result.
But we have a lot of options with the
repeated measures analysis of variance.
So I'm going to scroll up here
a little bit.
Again, if I had a between separate
factor like gender or
where
people, I could put that in here
if I wanted.
And if I had a covariate
like a person's age or
their level of exposure to bugs,
I could put that in there as well.
I'm just going to come down here
and get an effect size.
And for a study like this, it's
good to get a partial ADA squared.
This little letter here
that looks like an ad is a Greek ada,
and it's the common measure of effect size
for the analysis of variance.
And here we can see, for instance,
that this point
1 to 3 means about 12 point
percent of the variance
in a person's response can be attributed
to the variations and disgust
over twice as much can be attributed
to variation in fright.
And that there's just 2.4%
that's associated with the interaction
that's negligible.
And then I
can come down and I can specify the model.
Now I'm just going to use
the regular built in main effect,
main effect interaction model.
So I'm not going to change that at all.
I can look at assumption checks now
and the repeated analysis of variance.
A common test is what's called Sphere
Tricity,
and it's sort of the repeated measures
version of a normality check.
And I can click it,
but it's not going to be really relevant
because what you find is that
we only have two levels in each of these.
We have high and low discuss
high and low, right?
So it's always met.
There's only two. If we had three or more,
then this would be important.
So I don't really need that.
Now, in a normal
analysis of variance, I could also do
the equality of variance test.
In fact, I'm just going to click on
that right here as Levine's test.
But you know, it's irrelevant for this one
because I don't have a between subjects
factor like gender.
So we can ignore that one.
I can do post-hoc tests if I want,
and so I can, for instance,
look at disgust and fright
and I can put them over.
It's not really necessary
to do the post-hoc test
because I only have two categories
within each one of them.
And so it's obvious where the difference
is if we look at the means.
But if you had more
than two categories within each factor,
this would be something
that would be important
for you to do that.
I want you to see how it works.
You also have the choice of the correction
that you do.
The shift in Bonferroni are very
I prefer the Tukey test
and we can scroll down and we can see it's
calculating all sorts of things.
So these two correspond
to the analysis of variance results.
We earlier and is going to
look at these specific comparisons.
It makes for a very long table.
And what it's telling us
is that several of our comparisons,
these first three are all significant
in the last one, but not the middle two.
And that's a lot easier
if you were to go back
and have a means chart, but it gives you
the means and you can look at specific
quickly these possible comparisons.
Now, the last thing we can do is
we can come to estimated marginal means
and we can look at the effects.
So I'm going to come right and do discuss
drag it right there and get a new term.
I'm going to get fright
and drag it down right here
and we're going to get a means plot.
I also get a marginal means table
and I can scroll down.
And this is going to make it a lot easier
to see what's happening in our data.
Surprisingly, when a bug is disgusting,
people want to get rid of it
more than when it's not.
And here are the numbers to go with that
as well as the 95% confidence intervals.
And when a bug is frightening,
they want to get rid of it.
And you can actually see that the
difference for frightening is much bigger
than the difference for disgust and.
Then we get the numbers right there.
And so this is really the collection
of information
you can get from the repeated measures,
analysis of variance in your movie.
Some of these options
aren't really necessary when you have just
two groups within each factor
or you have a simple interaction.
But even with more complicated designs,
it's nice to know that the options
are there and available in general
to allow you to use the more powerful,
repeated measures design
to find out what's going on in your data
and start
getting insight into your results.
Sometimes when you
looking at the differences between groups,
you both want to compare their means,
but you also know
that there is another variable
like a quantitative variable
that's associated with the outcome
you're interested in.
And if you want to put that in, one
common choice is
to do an analysis of covariance
or an and cova.
And this is actually really easy
to do in your movie.
For this example,
I'm going to be using the iris data set
from the example data sets,
and I'm using this
because we have four quantitative
or continuous
variables, the simple length and people
with petal length and petal width
and have a categorical or nominal variable
species with three different groups.
And that's a situation
where you really would want to use
an analysis of variance,
but we can throw in some other
to try to predict something.
So what I'm going to do in this particular
example
is I'm going to look at the simple width.
That's one of the four measurements
of the flower of an iris.
And before we get started,
it's a good idea to explore
what that variable looks like.
So I'm just going to get sample width
and put right here
under variables and it's going to give us
some descriptive statistics over here.
I may ask for standard deviation also.
That's helpful
but mostly I want some plots.
I'm going to get a density plot
and I'm going to get a box plot
to look for outliers.
And that's going to give me my first
take on the outcome variable
or the thing that I'm trying to predict.
We see that we have 150 cases.
The mean is 3.06,
I believe at, centimeters,
medians close to that standard deviations
about half a centimeter.
And here is the distribution
of all three species of put together.
It's kind of cone shaped,
but it's even a modal
and it seems to be pretty well-behaved.
And here's the box, but
we've got a few outliers on the high end
and one on the low end, but it's pretty
much a well-behaved distribution.
And so if we're trying to model
Siebel with this
looks like a good variable
to be working with. Now,
when I'm doing the analysis of variance,
I actually want to break it down
by a categorical variable
and the one that I'm going to use in
this example is the species.
And so I'm going to do this
analysis here over again.
I'm going to go back to Explorer
and go to Descriptive, and I'm going to do
Siebel Width again, but this time
I'm going to break it down by species.
Now I don't need any statistics, so I'm
actually going to just cut those out here.
Really,
all I wanted this exact point is the plots
and I'm going to do density plots
where it's broken down by group.
And here you can see
the three distributions shown by density
plus are like histograms, but smoothed out
for the status the versa color.
And the Virginia is three different
irises.
You can see we've got a little
bit of an outlier down here
and things are kind of bumpy over here.
And so if we're trying to explain people
with knowing what species in irises
is going to be a little bit helpful
because we can tell
this zero says at least a little different
from the others.
And so let's do an analysis of variance,
which would be a common way of looking
at the difference between these.
I'm going to close this and go to ANOVA
and going to do
an analysis of variance,
just a one factor or a one way ANOVA
where I'm going to put Siebel
with as the dependent variable
and I'm going to put species
as the fixed factor.
And I'll just do a very basic one
actually.
I will get and partial a two squared and,
then I will come down here
to descriptive plots,
I will get species on the horizontal
and let's see if we have anything else
here, some descriptive
and that would be enough for right now.
And what it's showing us here is that,
yeah, there definitely is a difference
between the three species
on their Siebel width.
The value of P here are less than oh one.
In fact, the value of F of 49 is huge
and the partial eight
squared is point four.
So about 40% of the variance in the sample
with can be
at least associated
with the three different species.
And you come right here
and you see a really big difference
when we're looking at just the mean
with the confidence interval,
but we might be able to do better in that
by throwing in a covariate
or a quantitative or continuous variable
that is associated with the outcome.
The people with.
And maybe that would be helpful.
So what I'm going to do
actually is I'm going to do a little bit
of exploration first.
I'm going to come and do
a scatterplot using the scatter module.
Now, if you don't have the scatter
module installed, you get it by coming
over here to modules under General Library
and select scatter under here.
And once you click install, it's
going to be available right there.
I'm going to use that one
exploration and scatter plot
and I want to look at the simple width
as the outcome.
So I'm gonna put that on the Y,
but let's put the Siebel length,
by the way, a C pulls like a,
they alternate the petals
and the spores alternate
as you go around the flower.
And I'm going to put a smoother through it
as it's like a local regression line.
It kind of follows the pattern in the data
and we'll even put
the standard error on there.
And so you can see that there is in fact
an association between the two variables.
And so maybe throwing in the simple length
would be a helpful thing.
In fact, if you want to really see
what's in here,
you see how we have this
nonlinear association,
it kind of jumps up here
and it comes down here.
Remember, we have three different species
and there may be an important difference
between them.
So going to come back here to exploration,
I'm going to draw scatterplot again.
That way I create another chart
that going to put Siebel width
under the Y axis of possible
length under the x
and I'm going to do the smoother
with the standard error.
That's what I had before.
But now I'm going to throw into it
species as a grouping variable.
And because I can, I'm also going to put
density plots on the marginals.
That means across the top and on the side.
This shows the distributions of each
variable for the three different groups.
And so
when we look at this, I'm
going to move this over a little bit.
Actually, I'll close that first
and move it over a little bit.
Now you can see that there's
a really strong association that the Tozer
Iris has very different association
between sample length
than people with, and the other two
are pretty similar to each other.
So we have something
important to work with here
when we're trying to get the association.
I could also do
a linear association, in fact,
because that's relevant
to the analysis covariance.
I'll do exactly that.
So I'm going to repeat this analysis
and do the same thing.
But instead of using the curved smoother
that goes through the data,
I'll use a linear
or straight line regression.
So I'm going to come here to exploration
and scatterplot and I'm going to put width
again on the y axis length on the x
axis species on the group.
And I'm going to put linear
regression line
with the standard error
and I'll still put on this time.
Instead of doing densities,
I'll put box posture
so you can see what that looks like
when we run it.
Different way of looking at the data.
I'll close this menu
and bring this over a little bit.
And now you can see
that we have this really strong straight
line association here.
And this is where
the analysis of covariance is important,
because not only do the three groups
have separation between them,
which is something you would expect for
with the analysis of variance.
But they have different
slopes on the association.
That's going to be an important thing
for the analysis of covariance.
And we have box plots
for each of the variables
and they break them down by groups.
So we can see
we have a little bit of outliers
and a little bit of overlap between them.
So let me now
set an analysis of covariance.
And the way I do that is I come to ANOVA
and I come down to this third
option and Cova,
which is short for analysis of covariance.
And what I'm going to do
there is I'm going to take
my dependent variable, the outcome,
the thing I'm trying to predict
and that's going to be simple width.
I'm going to put that right here.
Now the fixed factor is the thing
that defines the distinct groups
that's going to be species.
So I'm going to put
that under fixed factors.
And this so far is just like
the analysis of variance I did earlier,
but now I can put in a covariate,
another quantitative continuous variable
that is associated with the outcome
and may help me get a better understanding
of what's happening in this case.
I'm going to use simple length
because we saw that there's an association
with it.
I'm going to put it here under covariate
and you see that the table
expands slightly
and we now have two inferential tests.
We have one for species.
We get this enormous F ratio, 94
and it says,
yeah, it's statistically significant.
So there is in fact a difference on
the species as far as Siebel width goes.
And we also see that the sample length
also has a significant association,
even when the both of them
are put in the equation together,
we can get a partial data squared here
to look at the effect size and we see that
the species makes more of a difference,
but they're still both really big, robust
findings.
Now, let's look
at some of the other options we have here.
We can look at model and I'm going
to stay with the default model.
If I want to put in an interaction I can.
And actually, now that I think about,
I will put an interaction
because these lines have different slopes.
And so I'm going to select
the two of these.
I'm just going
do a shift and click to get both.
Come right here and say,
give me a two way interaction.
So that's going to add the species
by the Siebel length.
And now you can see that that interaction
is also statistically significant.
And again, it's because they have
different slopes here in chart.
Now let's come down and check
some of our assumptions.
We can do a homogeneity, a variance test
because the three groups are supposed
to have approximately equal variance
on the outcome variable.
The simple with and we can also get a q
q a quantile quantile plot of residuals.
By the way,
the homogeneous the test variance is,
is not statistically significant.
That's a good thing.
It means that we are not violating
our assumption
the AQ or quantile quantile plot.
The residuals
assesses another
assumption of the analysis of covariance,
and that is that the residuals
or the errors in prediction,
how far off you are by your model,
that should be approximately spread out
the same for each of your groups
and it should be approximately normal
kind of a bell curve.
If it were a perfect bell curve,
every dot would be on this diagonal line.
But you can see they're really close.
So we're doing well.
Now. It may be that you have a situation
where you have specific contrast
you want to look at,
so maybe you want to look at just
ceteris versus
the other two kinds of viruses.
You can set that up here.
I don't want to do that.
So I'm just going to close that
and leave it alone.
I could do post hoc tests
and that's where I look at the two.
And because I know that one of them is R
from the other two, I'm
actually going to slide that over here.
I can pick correction.
I'm going to stay with the default tukey
and when I come down here, you see it's
going to compare status
with versus color in Virginia
and then racial color with Virginia.
So there are three possible comparisons
when you have the three different groups
and what you find
is that the very color in Virginia are not
significantly different from each other.
That makes sense
because they overlap a lot,
but the status is different
from the both of them.
In fact,
if we come back up here just for a moment,
this the total over here
and this is the very color of Virginia,
you can see that they're very similar.
And so to us is pretty different.
So that result makes sense.
Scroll back down.
And then in terms of descriptive plots,
I can get a means plot
by moving species
to the horizontal axis and get intervals,
and that'll take just a second to pop out.
It's confirming what we already knew that
the sample
with varies
for our three different species
and under additional options
we can get descriptive statistics.
We got some before,
but I might as well just click it here
because it puts them right
next to the chart.
And since the things
that go into the chart,
it's a little easier
to put it all together.
And so this is kind of
an extended presentation
because I spent time
going through the preparatory analyzes,
doing the univariate exploration
and then breaking it down by categories
and then doing the normal
one way analysis of variance.
And then looking at the associations
between Siebel width and people length
and sort of building up this,
the narrative arc of the analysis.
And when we get through the whole thing,
we see, yeah, there is in fact
not just a difference
between the three species,
but also the relationship
between the simple length
and the width is different
for the three species
that we got by having the different slopes
of the regression lines.
And so it gives us some nuance.
It gives us a little additional insight
into what is even a very,
very simple dataset.
And that's some of the power you can get
from the analysis of covariance
and working with your own data.
Some of the options
that Jamovi gives you in working with
data are really kind of surprising
because they're not usually found
in other statistical software, at least
not in the standard installations.
So if you're working in SPSS
and you want to do a multivariate
analysis of covariance,
you might have trouble,
you may be included there in the base
package, or you may have to download
additional things in other programs
to make it work.
But a sophisticated analysis
like a man cover
is available
as part of the base package in your movie.
And that's an amazing thing.
Now Minerva stands for Multivariate
Analysis of Code variance,
and the multivariate part means
you have more than one outcome variable
and you're trying to model
the group differences.
So on all of those simultaneously,
plus because there's the C in the middle,
that means covariance and you could use
a quantitative or continuous predictor.
You don't have to
because you can do either of the above
with a mankatha option in your movie.
Let me show you how this works
with the iris data.
Again, all I'm going to do here
is I'm going to see
if there are group differences
on all four of these variables.
Now, I'm
going to begin with the exploration,
something that I say that's a good idea.
So I'm going to come up here
to exploration and go to descriptive.
And what I'm going to do
is I'm going to get these for
quantitative or, continuous variables,
put them
here and then and break it down
by species, split it by species.
Now, I actually am not concerned
very much about the statistical table
at the moment, so I'm just going to unclip
all of this and close that up.
When I do want is the plot
and I'm going to do the density.
That's the like a histogram smoothed.
It's going to break it down
by the three groups.
We can see what sorts of differences
there are between
those groups in the data.
I mean, for Jamovi to get there.
But now what we have is the simple length
and looking at the three different species
of iris flowers,
we have a status of visit
color in Virginia
and you can see that
there are differences, that things
go up a little bit
as we go from one species to another.
The pattern switches around a little for
Siebel with where status is the highest.
The other two are really close
petal length.
We have enormous difference with Soto,
a way down here on the low end
and the other two
are still distinguishable
and then petal width
we actually have this nice separation
between, the three of them,
and we can look at each of these
separately if we want to
do four separate analysis of variance
analysis, we
look at the group differences
on each of these separately.
The Minova or the Manqoba allows us
to do all of them at once,
although I'll let you know that
sounds like it would be a big improvement,
but it's often
pretty hard to interpret the results
because the math that goes into this
gets a much much, much more sophisticated.
But let's see what Jamovi
can do to make this procedure
at least a little more accessible.
So I'm going to close this and I'm going
go over to the ANOVA and come down to man
cover, which again stands for multivariate
analysis of covariance.
And when I click on that,
the nice thing, it's not giving me
all the possible options you could get
because there would be a million.
But the easy thing is what are the
dependent or outcome variables?
I'm actually going to pick all four
of these flower measurements,
put them over here, and then factors
that says what defines the groups?
That's this species here.
Now, if I wanted to use
one of these measurements as a covariate,
or if I had something else with covariate,
like the age of the plant
or the height of the or something,
I could put that in there too.
I'm not going to do that because
it doesn't change the output very much.
And I just want to focus on what we have
right here.
The important thing is,
we really just have this one table
that's kind of all that is given to us.
In fact,
we have the same analysis really done
for different times
when we come here to multivariate tests.
The question that these four things are trying to tell us is, are there differences
on these four
variables simultaneously
between the three different groups?
And it turns out that all four versions
of the math
that goes into the multivariate
analysis of variance are covariance
they're all giving us
the same answer in this case.
They're all saying that, yeah,
there's this huge difference.
It's a highly significant difference.
The p value you're looking for, something
less than five is much than that.
It also does univariate tests,
whereas looking at the variables
separately
so we can look at Siebel length again.
This is the one factor,
a one way analysis of variance.
And we can see, yeah,
there are differences
between the groups on all three of them.
Now remember,
with the analysis of variance,
it doesn't mean
that every group is different
from every other one.
If we come back up to here, for instance,
you know,
we can see
that status is different on people with
but there's a and Virginia
are very similar to each other
and so there's a difference
somewhere in the mix
even if not all three are different
from each other.
And That's what we get here.
I'm just going to finish
with one of the assumption checks
we can do the Q plot of multivariate
normality.
Again,
something that we're generally looking for
because a normal distribution or a bell
curve is a good idea.
And a multivariate normal distribution
means that
if you have one variable,
that would be a bell curve.
If you have two variables, it's
doing it in an X and Y dimension
and you're
looking for sort of a smooth pill.
And if it's three or four variables,
then you get into, you know,
higher dimensions.
And it's really hard to visualize.
But if we just look at the quintiles,
that is that's what the.
Q stands for is the quanta.
So we have the chi squared
quantile across the bottom and the squared
at mahalanobis distance on the side,
which is also a quantile
and idea here is that if all the dots
which are data points
fall on the diagonal line,
then you have what is basically
a multivariate normal distribution.
We're really close to that.
So I think we've met
these assumptions, but really
the options that we're getting in
Jamovi are pretty simple for
what could be an extremely complex
and sophisticated analysis.
Basically is telling us that, yes, you
have a statistically significant Minova,
I could call it a man cover,
but I didn't actually use a covariate
this time around.
And Then it follows it up with univariate
ANOVA as for one factor at a time,
and it's enough for us to be able to say,
Yes, there's something there.
And if you have the theory
that says what the differences should be,
you might be able to tell that by looking
at some of the univariate
analyzes as well.
And so the nice thing again about intimacy
is it
makes this really sophisticated
kind of question easy to answer.
It gives you just enough information to
get the yes or no that you're looking for
if you're doing hypothesis
driven research.
And that's going be a very significant
first step in understanding what's going
on in your data.
Each version of the analysis of variance
that we've looked at so far in
Germany has in common,
and that is that they all rely
on population parameters
or assumptions about population parameters
like the population mean
or the population variance.
So the one factor or two factor
analysis of variance,
the repeated measures
analysis of variance, the end
cover, the analysis covariance,
even multivariate analysis of covariance.
All of them have this parametric
assumption in comments very really typical
among analyzes,
but there are other options.
These are called non parametric tests
and there are ones that don't make
assumptions about population parameters
and traditionally they're based on ranks.
And so for the analysis of variance,
the one way version, the non parametric
or ranked version of it
is called the Cresco Wallace Test.
And it's actually really easy to set up
if you're concerned about non normal
distributions,
this might be a good choice.
Now I'm going to use the Irish data.
We've looked at it lots of times
and I'm going to look at the Siebel
with and break it down
by the three different species.
But let's take a quick
look at the Siebel with
and break it down
in a couple of different ways.
And I go over here to exploration
and go to descriptors.
And what I'm going to choose is Siebel
with as the only variable
that I'm looking at
and I'm going to split it by species.
I'm not really concerned about this
great big table,
but what I do want, the plots, there's
two kinds of plots that I want to get.
I want to get the density plots
that will split up by species.
And I also want to get not the box plot,
but this time I want to get the data plot.
It's a dot plot
and I have a couple of options on that.
One I can do.
Girard, which it randomly shuffles them
from left to right.
Let's see if I come down here,
if it's showing up yet,
but I'm going to actually get the nice
and orderly stacked version
because it makes a little easier to tell
what we're with.
That was the jitter that popped up there
for just a second version.
Now let's take a quick
look at these analyzes.
What you can see from this is that
in terms of Siebel with the Irish status
there, Siebels are a little wider
than the Siebels
on the Irish variant of color or Virginia,
which are pretty similar to each other.
If we were doing a parametric
test, we'd be looking
at the means of each of these
and we've done that previously.
But the Cresco Wireless looks at rings,
and in that case you're sort
looking at where is the highest score?
This is the number one.
This is the second highest.
The third highest. The fourth.
And if you go through
and as you come down to here,
you have to start saying, well,
this might be the 17th highest
and this one here might be the third
or fourth highest.
And this one is 125th highest.
You take every single data point
across all three groups and you rank them.
And so this one I know there's 150 total.
This will be the 150th right here.
So go from rank number one to rank 150.
And the question is
whether the ranks are evenly distributed
across the three versions.
That's the question that the Chris
Wallace test is trying to answer.
So let's go and see how to do the go.
WALLACE It's
actually really simple. Just come to ANOVA
and then under
non parametric or to one way ANOVA
where says Chris Wallace.
And we click on that
and it's actually a very small dialog box
and only ask me for two things.
It says, What's your dependent variable?
What's the thing you're looking at?
I'm doing just Siebel with
and what's your grouping variable?
And I am using the species of the iris
and I got this tiny little table
that just has three numbers in it.
It gives me the test statistic
which is actually a chi squared.
I know that looks like an x,
but it's a Greek C,
it's a capital chi
with two degrees of freedom.
And this is a highly significant result,
meaning that there's
these aren't even remotely close
to identical distributions.
Now, normally when you get a significant
analysis of variance, you want to do
some sort of follow up with post hoc
and we're using ranked
non parametric data.
We need to do something
a little bit different.
And Jamari gives us the option
of the DCF pairwise comparisons,
which stands for Dwarfs.
Still, Critchlow and Flickinger
are filling your pairwise comparisons.
You can think of them as similar
to the HFA or Bonferroni or TUKEY
because what it does
is it gets every possible comparison
and with three groups
there's three possible comparisons.
It calculates a test statistic
and then this part here at the end
that's important is the p value
that tells us
whether it is statistically significant.
Now, you can see this one's taking a while
and that's one of the things about
when you're dealing with ranks
and especially if you have a lot of data
is an iterative procedure and takes
a long time to get through all of it.
But here we have it
and you can see that in all three cases,
the p value, the probability value
of this happening at random,
if the null hypothesis is true, is way
less than the standard 5%.
This is 0.5% and here they're even lower.
And so these all serve to reject the null
hypothesis that everything is similar
or that their ranks are sort of randomly
distributed across the three groups.
And it gives us the same
general impression that we got from doing
the one way analysis of variance earlier
that the three groups are not different.
Obviously this one's really high.
These two are here,
but Even then, the rank shows us
that there are still differences between
these two groups because of the way
their ranks are divvied up between them.
And so the Cresco Wallis is a
non parametric or rank
based analog to the one factor or one way
analysis of variance that you can use,
especially when you're concerned about non
in your data.
One final variation
of the analysis of variance
that's available in movie is what's called
the Friedman test, a non parametric
analog to the repeated measures
analysis of variance.
The idea here is
that you have several outcomes that you've
for a group of people and you're
looking for changes across those outcomes.
I want to demonstrate how this works
with the built in example data from bugs
where people who are rated
on a number of demographic variables
evaluate insects
and how much they want to get rid of them.
Where those insects vary
according to low and high disgust
and low and high fright
and they rate it from a zero, meaning
they don't want to get rid of it all
to ten, want to get rid of it immediately.
And we've done this analysis
before with the standard repeated
measures, analysis of variance,
but we can also do it
with the ranked version,
the Friedman test.
And this is an advantage if you're worried
about normality in your data.
So most analysis like to have bell curves
and normal distribution
if you don't have that
and we actually know that we have some non
normality in this data, then a non
parametric test might be an appropriate
and informative choice.
But let's begin by looking at
the distributions of these four variables.
We've looked at them before,
but I'm just going to come here
to exploration Descriptive
and then
I'm going to pick these four outcomes.
Low disgust, low fright,
up through high disgust, high fright.
I'll put those under variables.
And I'm not so much concerned
about these statistics as I want
the plots
that we can get for each of them.
So I'm just going to hit density
and unfortunately I can't
get them stacked right next to each other,
which would be most convenient.
But we can still compare going up
and down in the list to see what we have.
An important question is
are they normal in or out?
They on the same scale.
Now this first one low discussed low.
Right.
It's not exactly normal,
but it's not different.
We've got a pretty strongly skewed distribution with the low disgust, high fright,
also strongly skewed with the
high disgust fright and then really skewed
with the high disgust high fright.
And so this is a situation
we're using a non parametric test
based on race
as opposed to a parametric test
that also assumes things like normality.
This might be a good option.
So let's close this and come over
to the analysis of variance
and drop down to the last choice here.
It's under non parametric
and it's the repeated measures.
ANOVA or the Freedman test
is what it's also called
and I click on this and you know, there's
not too many options here in the jazz
movie dialog, but there's enough
to get what we need out of it.
So What I need to do
is I need to pick my measures
that I'm looking at
and I simply pick all four of them.
I click.
The first I do is click on the last
and I move them all over.
And in this situation, I'm
not breaking them down into categories
like disgust
and fright like I did with the regular
Parametric analysis of variance.
But I do this way now I get this
tiny little table, just three numbers
that shows us that there is, in fact,
a significant effect here.
The first number here,
the 55.8, is under the chi squared.
That's the distribution that use
and that's a capital chi.
We have three degrees of freedom
and this deviates
significantly
from what we would expect at Rand M.
And so
we do find a significant effect here.
And if you want to,
you can get pairwise comparisons
there like the post-hoc comparisons,
the bonferroni or the Sheffield tests
that we get with other procedures.
And what we have
here is a comparison of each
set of variables here with.
The four variables
we have six possible comparisons.
So low disgust, low fright to low disgust,
high fright.
That's statistically significant
and in fact all of them are statistically
significant one way or another.
Let's
get the descriptive statistics for these.
This would be a very small table.
And because some of that is similar
to what we had
when we got this information up
here, it's just arranged differently.
And then
we can also get a descriptive plot
and we can choose either means or medians.
But since we've been talking about means,
I'm going to leave it right there.
It's just a little dot plot.
It's not showing us a confidence interval
because that really works
differently when you're talking
about a ranked situation.
And even though are means,
they still let you know that
all four of these
are different from each other.
And because of this paired comparisons
using the Durban Conover test,
we can tell that all of these comparisons
are significantly different
from one another.
So that's a very quick run
through of the freedom in test
is an repeated measures
analysis of variance analog
for using non parametric
or ranked data and again
depending on how far your data deviate
from normality, this may be a good choice
for analyzing and finding the hidden
meaning in your data.
In our next chapter
on regression in the movie,
we're going to look at associations
specifically
through correlation and scatter plots,
and we're also going to look at the ways
we can use many variables
to predict scores on one variable
how we can use predictor
to look at an outcome or criterion
variable, and we'll do this primarily
through variations on regression to movie
gives us actually a great set of choices.
We can do standard linear regression
and one of the most powerful,
flexible and useful procedures available.
We can also do binomial
logistic regression where the outcome
variable is not a quantitative
or continuous score,
but a dichotomy, this or that.
And you're trying to use a collection
of variables to predict
which of two categories
a case will go into.
Then there's
multi nominal logistic regression
where have several categories
in your outcome variable.
This is actually a very sophisticated
procedure and it's a surprising thing
that your movie includes this
and it includes it for free.
And then finally we'll look at
ordinal logistic regression
recently added to your movie,
which allows you to use again
a collection of variables to predict
which of several ordered categories
a case falls into.
And between this set linear regression
binomial mountain
oatmeal, ordinal logistic regression.
We have an extraordinary collection
of tools for getting more insight
out of our data.
And in each case, what we are doing
is we're using several variables
to predict an outcome on one.
I like to think of it
as the statistical version of E Pluribus
Unum, a motto The United States,
which means out of many one,
and in this case, out of many variables
and many data points, one conclusion.
And so let's look at the ways that Germany
let us use an entire collection
of regression techniques to explore data
and get useful insight out of it.
Perhaps
simplest way of looking at the association
between variables is with the correlation
coefficient, specifically the Pearson
product moment correlation coefficient
usually just called R,
and it's a great way
of looking at the association between
two quantitative or continuous variables,
although it's actually much more flexible
than.
That and I want to take a moment
to show you how we can do correlations
and correlation matrices
and scatterplot matrices in Germany.
Now to do this, I'm bringing in a dataset
and it's called a state data,
and it's
based on a little bit of information
that I've compiled from different sources.
One is the name of the state, its code
the region is from.
I looked up whether their current governor
is Republican or Democrat
from a few years ago.
A study done on categorizing states
by their personality characteristics,
putting them as temperamental or friendly
and relaxed or traditional.
Another study
that classified states by their Big Five
personality characteristics extroversion,
agreeableness, conscientiousness
and so on.
And here at the end, I went to
Google and I got state by state data
on how common certain search
terms are in each state.
These are Z scores.
So they tell you how many
standard deviations above or below
that state is from the national average.
And I put in some that I felt
were at least kind of relevant to the Big
Five personality characteristics.
I have some social media ones,
I put in some business.
He went to Entrepreneur.
GDPR stands
for the General Data Privacy Regulation
that the European Union just put in.
It's a big deal if.
You're in e commerce
and we have universities and
and mortgage and volunteering and museums
and scrapbooking.
My favorite one modern dance.
And let's take a look
at some of the associations
between a few of these variables
and then we'll explore
some of the other associations as we go
through this chapter on regression
in Germany.
Okay.
So the first thing I'm going to do
is I'm going to pick
a small number of variables.
When you go to regression,
your first choice here is correlation
matrix.
And you know, truthfully,
you could put in a hundred variables.
You just end up with this
absolutely gargantuan matrix
and not be able to make sense of it.
I'm going to be a more selective and pick
just a few.
Right now,
I'm going to pick one of our personality
characteristics here, extroversion.
So really, how
outgoing social person is versus
being introverted.
And I'm going to pick
just a few other things to go with it.
So maybe extroverted
people might be on social media more.
So we'll pick Facebook and they may
or may not be concerned about privacy.
Let's see what that looks like and then.
How about volunteering?
So are they offering to do things for free
to help people in their community?
Okay, so I put those in there
and you see that this table builds
up and it fills in almost immediately.
What we have
are the correlation coefficient
arranged in the top right
diagonal of the table,
and there's nothing in the bottom left
because those two are mirror images.
They're because the association between
extroversion and Facebook is the same.
The association between Facebook
and extroversion down
the diagonal are just these lines,
because that's each variable with itself,
and that's always a perfect correlation,
but it doesn't mean anything.
So what we have in this are two things.
We first have the Pearson's R, this is the
product of correlation coefficient.
It from negative one, which indicates
a perfect negative linear association
through zero, which indicates no linear
relationship whatsoever to plus one which
a perfect positive linear relationship.
And we also have the p value
which is used
for the statistical hypothesis testing
and we're looking for a number there
that is less than oh five now.
It's going to be easier
to see what's going on
if we come over here and click flag
significant correlations.
It'll put asterisks next to them,
which makes it a little easier to find
instead of having to compare each number
in your own head.
And so we see, for instance,
that we have three
significant correlations out of six.
So it turns out
extroversion is not associated
with any of these things,
which is kind of surprising.
But states that search for Facebook
more on Google, search less for privacy.
They also search less
for volunteering and.
Then states that, search more for privacy,
search more for volunteering.
These are pretty good correlations.
And again, it's on a state by state level,
not a person by person level.
It's on the states.
By the way,
the dataset only includes 48 states.
It doesn't include Alaska or Hawaii
or the district Columbia, Washington, D.C.
That's because that's what was included
in the one that categorized
these states by personalities.
And so this gives you something to look at
now one interesting option
that your movie gives you
is to do confidence intervals.
And so we click on that and it will expand
this table and give us a 95% interval.
You can change it to
something else if you want,
and I'll give you the upper bound
and the lower bound.
So for instance, you can see that
this one goes on either side of zero.
So it's this and this here.
However, this association between Facebook
and volunteering has statewide
search terms.
We go from -0.451 to -0.789.
So it may be that you want confidence
intervals, your correlations,
it makes for a busy matrix,
but they're available.
The other thing I want to mention is this
It's always nice to have a graph and.
I actually would have called
this a scatterplot matrix
as opposed to a correlation matrix,
but either one works and what it is,
is it's a similar rows and columns,
but this time it has separate
scatter plots for each of the associations
and they get kind of busy.
But you can see that
we've got a strong negative association,
a strong positive association, and
some others that are pretty close to zero.
It's set up a little bit differently here.
We have stuff on the bottom left diagonal
as opposed to the top right diagonal.
But again, it's symmetrical.
We can also get the density charts
on the diagonal
so we know what the distribution
like for each variable.
And from that you can see
that extroversion and Facebook
are kind of normal.
We got a peculiar shape here with privacy
because we have outliers
and volunteering is bimodal.
And then also we can get statistics
that'll give us the actual correlation
coefficients displayed on the upper
right side of diagonal in the
scatterplot matrix.
See, these numbers
correspond to what we have up here.
There's the 0.036
and there's the same thing down here.
And so we have both a numerical summary
of the correlations,
the associations between these variables,
as well as a graphical summary.
That's generally how you want to do it
anyhow.
And so correlations are a fabulous
first step at looking at the association
between variables, especially when they
are quantitative or continuous variables.
Again, it's more flexible than that,
but that's the canonical usage
of correlations in a movie and elsewhere.
Sometimes
you want to just do more with less.
And if you want to be able to do
as much as possible
with the smallest number of tools
as possible, then
linear regression is going to be by far
your best bet.
It is the general purpose data
analytic tool,
and so many of the other procedures
that we look at are actually special
versions
or variations on linear regression.
The basic idea here is you're
trying to take one or more variables
and use those to scores on a quantitative
or continuous outcome variable.
Let me show you how this works.
Using the state data that I have.
This again, has information
about whether the current governors,
Republican or Democrat,
some psychological information
about states on the big
5% of the characteristics
and a bunch of Google search information
that's given in Z scores.
Let's try to predict one variable here
in particular and let's look at openness.
That's an interesting one.
It has to do with being open to new ideas
or sometimes with art,
but mostly it's associated with being open
to thinking about new things
and trying new perspectives.
It's a nice thing.
So let's come up here to regression
and let's
do linear regression
and what we're going to do
is a we're going to pick open this
as our dependent variable.
It isn't really a dependent variable
because it's not
from a manipulated experiment,
but it's the outcome variable.
And the idea here
is that the outcome scores
depend on the other variables
we put into the model.
So let's take openness.
Now I have a small data set.
There's only 48 cases in this
because it's the contiguous United States.
And so I can't go hog
wild and throw everything in there
because I'm going to violate
some of the assumptions of regression.
So I'm going to be a little bit selective.
Just a little bit.
It's not going to put everything in there.
I'm going to pass up some of these things.
I'm going to leave these other
big five personality
characteristics right here
because they're not supposed
to be associated.
But I am going to come and get
Google searches.
And again, what it tells us is
what is the state's average on
this as a proportion
of their total number of searches
and it's given as Z scores
compared to the rest of the United States,
trying to select all of those
and put them over here in the covariates.
And actually, I, I will take one of these
categorical variables.
I'll get.
Governor, this is a dichotomous variable
in this particular dataset.
It only has two values Democratic
or Republican.
There actually is an independent governor
right now, but he's up in Alaska.
And Alaska wasn't included in this dataset
because we don't have the psychological
information for them.
So we can treat it as dichotomous.
And you put that here under factor
and you can see that off to the right.
The regression
table has filled in immediately.
We can tell a couple of things here.
First off, the multiple correlation,
the big R here is 0.831.
Again, correlation goes from negative
one to positive one.
And this is a strong correlation
with multiple regression
like we have right here.
It's more common to look at the R squared,
actually, the adjusted R squared.
I'll show you in a minute.
But this can be interpreted
as the proportion of variance
in the outcome openness
that's predicted by these other variables
in this 69%, which is truly kind of huge.
And if we want to, we can come down here
and look at these individual variables
and how they contribute now keep in mind
these coefficients, these are the things
that you multiply each number by
are only valid
when you take this set variables together.
This is not
how much is associated on its own.
This is as a whole.
So if I were to drop
one of these variables out or add
another one
in, all these numbers would add
just a little bit
because it's the unity here.
This is important.
That said, we can tell that some of these
seem to matter more than others.
We're looking for p values
that are less than oh five
and we're not getting much here
on any of these until we get ten.
Here at the bottom
scrapbook,
this is how much does that state
search for the term scrapbook
compared to other states?
And that makes a difference.
States where scrapbooking is more common
of a lower
level of openness, at least when taken
in the context of this entire set of data.
And then searches for modern dance
are in fact significantly associated
with higher levels of openness.
Again, within the context
of this set of variables.
And then down here gov is a dichotomous
variable that takes two values.
And the nice thing about your movie,
it's able to simply take
a categorical variable
and throw it in there
and prepare it to work
well in a regression.
On the other hand,
we see that this one is nowhere
close to statistically significant,
so we don't really need to worry about it.
But let's come over here
and see what some of the options
are for linear regression in J Movie.
Scroll up here a little.
Let's go to Model Builder and this is
if I wanted to put the information
in in blocks,
that actually might be a good thing.
In fact, let's try that.
Let's do blocks where I'm going to take
all of these variables out right here
and I'm going to make the first block,
just the governor,
whether that person's Democrat
or Republican.
And then I will add a second block
that takes all of this other information
and we'll just
drag them over to right there.
It should show up in a second
and dragging all of them at once.
Going to try adding them one at a time.
Here, I'm going to click Instagram
and I'll drag that over right here.
And what this is going to do
is, it first creates a model
that has just the governor in it,
and then it's going to see how much better
the correlations get.
The associations get.
When we put in these other variables,
I'm just dragging them over one at a time.
It's going to take a moment
to update everything here.
Privacy and, University
and mortgage
and volunteering and museum
and scrapbook
and modern dance.
So we'll see what those are able to add.
In addition, it's going to take a moment
for it to update the results here.
Comparison of two different models,
because I entered them in blocks.
The first one has just the governor
and it actually is
associated a little bit there.
If you want to see the specific results,
we can come here and click
model one
and that shows us just the governor.
And what's interesting is when we have
only whether the governor of a state
is Democratic or Republican,
we actually get a strong association.
And that reminds us that's very different
from what we had
when we entered everything at once.
Now, let's take a look at model two,
which in addition to that,
as the other variables.
Now, by the way,
when is just the governor?
You see, we have an R squared of 0.148.
That's not bad.
When we throw in the other variables,
it goes all the way up to .69.
And that change from model
one to model two where the R squared up
by 0.542 is statistically significant
in and of its own.
But let's look at model two here again.
And now we can see again.
The funny thing here is
when we put in all these other variables
that the governors, Republican
or Democrat, it doesn't matter anymore.
Again, it's changed by the inclusion
of these other variables.
And this gets to the results that we had
previously.
We're scrapbooking.
They're in a different order
because I drag them in differently.
Scrapbooking nearly significant,
and maintenance is the only one that's
significant on its own within this group.
By the way, you may notice
we have the option
of variables in blocks,
block one and block two.
BLOCK three.
That actually is a good way to go.
If you want to look at the separate
or additional
predictive ability of one variable
or another,
one thing you do not get to do in GMV
and some people say
this is a very good thing is you can't do
step variable selection.
You can't throw a whole bunch of variables
at it and say, look,
you just sort through it
all on your own and tell me what works.
That's an easy
way to do things,
but It tends to really magnify
the result of weird
flukey results in the data,
and you tend to get results
that don't generalize.
Well.
And so that's not even an option here.
You can, however, do blocks
where you choose
what goes in at one point
and you examine what's happening.
I actually prefer blocked entry like this
for reference level that's for categorical
or nominal variables
and you get to decide
which category is baseline one
and which one gets the regression
coefficient that goes with it.
Right now it's Democrat is the baseline
and Republican goes on top.
I can just flip around
and then you can see that
this will switch over here to the end.
It'll just change the sign associated
with it so it doesn't change anything big.
Well, that's refreshing.
I'll close this and come to assumption
checks.
There's a number of things
that need to be true for the results
of linear regression to be meaningful.
Now, autocorrelation is if you had stuff
like week one, week to week three
where the week three results,
you know, are going to be at least
partially associated with week one.
We're not dealing with that,
but we are going to be dealing with
curling reality where the predictor
variables are associated among themselves
and what causes the associations to change
dramatically when variables
are in different combinations.
If no variable was associated
with any other, it wouldn't matter
the order that you put them in
or whether they were in there
with the others or not.
It would always be consistent,
but because these variables
are associated, it becomes very sensitive
to the way that you enter them.
Let's roll down a little bit and let's
look at two colony already statistics.
The first is via F,
which stands for variance Inflation
Factor, and the second is tolerance.
And you can take the two of these
as an indication of how associated
each of these variables
is with all of the others.
Now, I can tell by looking at this
that we do have some
CO linearity or multiple linearity.
So between them
it's not the end of the world.
I'm going to go past it.
We can also look at something
like the Q Q plot of residuals.
That's the quantile.
Quantile or plot of residuals.
When you do
a regression, the residual is the distance
between the predicted values
you give people and their actual values.
It's the error, the leftover part,
and in theory
that should be normally distributed.
You shouldn't always be higher,
always be low, should be spread out
basically like a bell curve.
And if our residuals were
perfectly shaped like a bell curve,
they'd all be exactly on this line.
But you can see they're really close.
So that part is nice.
You can get separate residual plots.
It'll do one for every one
of the variables that you put in there.
You can also get Cook's distance,
which is a way of looking at
how influential a single data point is.
I'm going to skip over those
and come down to model fit.
We have R and R squared
and if I come back up
here, you'll see where those things go.
Adjusted R squared
is probably going
to be a better choice in this situation,
especially because we have a small
data set.
There's only 48 cases
and you can see that there is a change.
The R squared is 69
and the adjusted R squared is 572.
This is going to be a more accurate number
in terms of generalizing
to other data sets.
We have other information
we could use like the AIC
that's, the key information criteria
or the Bayesian information criteria.
We can also do the overall F test.
Let me click on that
and you'll see how it expands
some of the information
that we have in here.
That is, it adds a few more columns here
where we're doing the overall model.
Now we have two different models.
We have two entries.
When it was just the governor,
we had a highly significant result.
And when we added on all that Google
search information,
we got an even stronger result here.
In terms of model
coefficients, one thing you can do is
you can do the omnibus F test.
We've basically done that.
But what I would like
to do is these standardized estimates.
So instead of T tests
here, we'll actually get Z scores
where we compare the regression
coefficients against each other
and can even get a confidence
interval, 95% confidence interval
for those two over just a little bit.
And the standardized estimate,
these are Z scores
for each of these variables over here
as opposed to TS.
And then we have confidence intervals
for each of them.
And you can see, for instance,
that we have one here that is going to be
the modern dance, one where the two sides
of the confidence interval
have the same sign.
They're both positive, which corresponds
with it being statistically significant.
And then finally you can get estimated
marginal means.
So for instance, we can come down here
and we can put
Governor
one of these, we can put it right there,
and that will produce
a new chart down here at the bottom
and well, that working on it.
I'm going to add another near term.
Let's say, for instance,
let's put modern dance in there
and you do this for each of them
if you want
to. Showing us is the level of openness
for the state broken down
by whether that state currently
has a Republican or Democrat governor?
And you can see that there's an enormous
amount of overlap between those two.
And then this is the more fun one
when you take something
that is on a quantitative scale,
you get sort of this regression
line in terms of how open people are.
And this is the standard error estimate
or a confidence interval
for the regression line.
So you can see that as modern dance
becomes more common as a search term,
that the level of openness for the state
goes up as well.
And again, you can do that
for one of these other variables.
It's just going to be an enormous amount.
But the general idea here is that
this is the set of tools
that your movie gives you for doing
linear regression, which is probably
the single most important
analytical procedure
you can have
when you're working with your data.
In the first
video on Linear Regression,
I showed you how to set up the most basic
version of linear regression,
which is called simultaneous entry,
where you take all of your predictors
and you put them in the model at.
And when it gives you
is this one that we have right here,
which gives you the T
values and the P values
allow you to hypothesis tests
on all of your variables,
but only in the context of each other.
And if you select different variables,
or sometimes
if you put them in different order,
you can get results.
Now, I want to show you
some of the options that your movie
gives you for this.
And to do that, I'm
going to come back to regression
and I'm going
to pick linear regression again
and I'm going to set up a new analysis.
I mean, I scroll down a little bit here.
The outcome variable,
the dependent is openness.
So I'm going to pick that right here.
And this is where I can start choosing
which variables
I want to include in the analysis.
Now, what I did
is I picked all of these Instagram down
through modern dance,
which are Google Correlate terms,
which have to do with the relative
popularity of these search terms
on a state by state basis.
And I can pick those.
And I also chose gov,
which is simply whether
the Governor of that state was Democratic
or Republican when the data was gathered
and we have this table right here,
but what I'm going to do is I'm going
to come down here to model
and here
I have an opportunity
to do data in blocks.
Now, a very common approach or something
that a lot of people want to do
is something called entry,
which you simply tell the computer,
these are all the possible variables
and I want you the computer
to go through and pick
the one that has the highest
individual correlation.
Stick that in the model,
then pick
the one that has the highest correlation
after that and put it in and so on
and so forth.
The problem is stepwise models
tend to really build on the idiosyncrasies
of that particular data set.
And so you get a model that's really well
tailored to what you have,
but it doesn't generalize well
and it can actually mislead
you in a lot of different ways.
Jamovi doesn't
even give you the option for that.
What you do have the option
for is what I personally call
block regression
or block entry or block wise regression.
And that is you can set up several models
that sequentially
add additional variables.
And so what I'm going to do
here is I'm going to first
take all of these search terms.
I'm going to get all of them out.
And so right now.
BLOCK One is just whether the state
has a Democratic or Republican governor.
And you can see right here
that in terms of openness, it's
doing subtraction,
Republican minus Democrat.
And what that means
is the Democrat governors
or the states with Democrat governors
tend to have higher levels of openness
than the ones with Republican governors.
That's
because have a negative coefficient there.
But let's add a second block
and see how things shift around.
Now, I do want to come up here and change
this to include the adjusted R squared.
So I'm going to come down
and say model fit
and add that on right there
and I'll close that.
So now we have our model it simply knowing
whether a state has a Republican
or Democrat governor predicts
almost 13% of the variance in the outcome.
The openness of this state as a whole.
And that's kind of remarkable on its own.
But I'm going to come over here
and add a new block.
And in block two,
we're going to try to put several other
variables, say, for instance,
come down and pick just these last
few museums, scrapbook and modern dance.
And I'm going to put those into block to
just as a main effect right there.
And then I can compare the model
with just Governor
and then the model with governor
and these three in it.
And so that's what I have right here.
We have this first one is just governor
and we have an adjusted R-squared of 12.9.
It explains 13% of the variance
in the outcome openness.
When we add these other three Google
search terms, the relative popularity
of those on a state by state basis,
it goes up to 52%.
We've now explained it
over 50% of the variance in the outcome,
which is openness.
Now that makes a little bit of sense
because openness often includes or
creative openness, though it can include
a lot of other things as well.
And this one right here, this
model comparisons, tells us
that there is a statistically increase,
which makes sense
because it's a huge jump.
And then here we have the variables.
Now, this is from model two.
If we want to look at model one,
we just on this
and we get to one with just governor.
And you can see there's
a statistically significant effect there.
That's the 0007 right here.
But let's go back to model two
and now we can see that gov is no longer
statistically significant.
That's because it was a spurious
correlation as predicted by other things.
And then music doesn't seem to matter.
But we have strong and statistically
significant effects for both scrapbook
and modern arts to creative interests,
and we see that one's and one's positive.
So in the states that have higher levels
of interest in scrapbook as a search term,
there are lower levels of openness
and in states that have higher interest
in modern dance,
there are higher levels of openness.
Again, that's because we have these
negative and positive coefficient ints,
but remember, it's always
within the context of one another.
Now if we want to,
we can add a third block where we take
on, for instance, these other ones.
We go from Instagram
and then I'll do a shift, click
down to volunteering,
and I'll put those in the third
block as main effects only.
We're not looking for interactions
right now,
and when I do that we can see that
adding those variables improved.
The adjusted R-squared from only 0.5 to 5,
that's 52 and a half percent to 57.2%.
And in fact,
you can see here that that increase
from model two to model
three is not statistically significant.
The increase
has a P value itself of 0.180.
So we didn't get anything helpful
by adding those extra variables.
In fact,
we lost degrees of freedom by doing that.
So that tells us
that we're probably best off
going with Model two,
which had a substantially higher
rate of predictive ability
compared to the one I had just governor.
And the results make sense and it's that
theoretical interpretation that matters.
And so this is one of looking
at the relative contribution
of different variables.
Now, this one's theory driven
because you decide what the blocks are
and you enter them in
and you interpret the results
your own to see if they make sense
and how applicable they are.
And really,
whether it's something
that you can put into use, whether you can
do something productive with it,
that is the goal of linear regression
and this blocked entry
is to find the information
that's going to be most useful to you
in solving the problems
that you're dealing with
before you
take the results of your linear regression
and you go running off to market
and making massive changes,
you do want to make sure
that you actually dotted
I's and cross your TS
and you want to make sure that your data
met the assumptions that the model has
and that your data is leading
you in the right direction.
This becomes a matter of checking
what are called regression diagnostics,
a number of statistical
and graphical methods
for looking at how
well your data fits the model.
Now, I'm going to do this
by coming back to the same model and data
that we used before where we're looking
at variables to predict the openness
of people on a state by state basis.
And I'm going to click on this model
right here
and what I'm going to is I'm
going to come back not to model builder,
although that is where I specified
the blocks that I was going to use.
But I'm going to come down a little
to assumption checks
and this is where the most important
things are going to happen.
Now, there are a few here
that are particularly important
if you have data that's measured
repeatedly over time,
like quarter one, quarter to quarter
three results,
then you're going to need to deal
with auto correlation to see
how much a carryover effect
there is from one time to another.
We don't have that right here,
so I'm not going to deal with that.
But we do need to be worried
about coloniality or multicore linearity.
And that's what happens when your
variables that you're using to predict
the outcome are correlated
with each other.
Now, really, the easiest way to check
that is to get a correlation coefficient
and look at the associations
between your various variables.
But the statistics
that are specific to linearity
within linear regression
also tell you important things.
We come down here, it's
giving us two measures in particular,
and we're looking at model two.
That's the one I have selected.
The first is VHF,
which stands for the variance
inflation factor
and the second one is tolerance.
And there's a correlation
or an association between those.
And what they're both referring to
in different ways is the association
of each of these variables
with the other predictors in the model.
And I can tell by looking at this that
we do have some crossover between them.
The actual ways that they operate
gets a little complicated,
and that's beyond what I'm trying to do
here.
Mostly, I want you to know
that Jamari is able to do this for you
and you can interpret the results in ways
that to make your model more robust,
you can also do the Q.
Q part of residuals.
I have demonstrated that elsewhere,
and it's here to the residuals
or the leftovers from predictions
based on your model
need to be approximately
normally distributed.
They need to not flare out
on one end of the model or the other.
Now, I do see that there's one down here
dipping kind of low.
The rest are basically on the line
and we come off a little bit.
It's not horrible, though.
You may want to do a little more
of a drill down
analysis to see what's happening
in this particular dataset.
There two ways you can do that.
One is with the residual plot,
and that's going to do separate plots
for each of the predictor variables
that we have in the model.
And so it's going to a moment
to catch up with all of those.
And the other one is
what's called cooks distance.
And that's going to give you a measure
of the influence of specific cases.
Now, because we have only 48 cases
in our data,
it's the 48 continental United States
that's not such a horrible idea.
And here we have
the plots that we're looking at.
We see, for instance, with openness,
there's this pattern
in the residuals
that we don't have in other things.
And so that's issue
we may be concerned about.
I'll click on Cook's Distance as well,
and Cook's Distance actually shows up
above the charts that we have right here.
And it's simply giving us the mean,
the median standard deviation
and the range of these.
And so you can look
at the individual scores that you have
and try to find out
what's on in the residuals plots
to see if there's something
that is deviating really sharply
from your expectations or the assumptions
of the modeling technique.
I do want
finish with one other thing,
and that is the estimated marginal means.
Now this will be more helpful
in some situations than in others,
but what you can do here
is, you can actually try to get a chart
that shows you how these variables
predict your outcome.
So I can take governor,
which is an easy one
because there's only two categories there
and that's going to make a chart.
It'll be down here at the bottom.
This simply gives me
the mean level of openness
for the states with Democrat governors
and the mean level of openness for states
with Republican governors.
And you can actually see, well,
the means are a little different.
This dot is a little lower than.
This the confidence intervals overlap
substantially.
And you can do this with other terms
if you want.
We can take, for
instance, modern dance here
and we can put that in.
And it's going to be a little different
because this is a quantitative
or continuous predictor, whereas
the governor was a nominal variable.
And we'll scroll down a little bit
and what it is
is kind of like a scatterplot,
but there's no data points on here.
And Instead, we're looking at a regression
line with a confidence interval
around it at the association
between the two
as how modern dance predict
the expected levels of openness
and you see as the relative interest
in modern dance
goes up to about a level of four point
something that the average level
of openness for the state goes up as well.
And so this can be a way of
also seeing how well
your data, the assumptions and fit in
with the approach of linear regression,
which after all is one of the most common
and most powerful methods
of using data to model specific outcomes.
And something that Jamovi makes
incredibly easy to do and to interpret.
One really common task in analyzing
data is cases into one category or another
based on a number of other variables
you might have.
So for instance, with
your computer is trying to decide
whether a particular email is spam or not.
We are trying to decide
whether a particular person is likely
to buy your product or not,
and those are dichotomous classifications.
And a common method for analyzing
or predicting dichotomous outcomes
is to use what's called binomial,
which means two names
binomial logistic regression.
So it's a form of linear regression,
but it's adapted for placing cases
into one group
or another based on the probabilities
that are predicted
from your other variables.
Now, this is really easiest
to simply show how it works.
So I'm going to use the data
I have about state data.
I've got a number of variables
about personality
characteristics
on a statewide basis and search terms.
But the dichotomous variable
that I have in here is whether the state's
governor, their current governor
right now is Republican or Democrat.
Now, let's start with
just a little tiny bit of exploration
so we know what we're dealing with.
I'm going to take governor,
put it over here
and we're going to get a frequency table
and we will also get a bar plot.
And so at this exact moment of the lower
48 states in the United states,
about two thirds of them
have Republican governors.
And so we're going to see if we can use
some of the other data
we have in this dataset to classify
states or predict
which ones have Republican governors
and which ones have Democrat governors.
And so the way we want to do this,
I'll just close
that is to come to regression
and come down here to logistic regression.
Two outcomes or a binomial again we're
binomial means to names or to categories.
I'll click on that.
The first thing we
need to do is put our dependent variable
as the outcome variable thing
we're trying to predict.
And that's going to be
and I don't even have to tell it,
you know,
this is what this means
is what that means,
because I actually have it
written as words in the dataset
and the nice thing is that Jamovi
is smart enough to be able to tell
that those are categories
and then we get to pick some covariates.
Now, I could pick a lot here.
Let's pick
just the social media ones, just for fun.
So I'm going to come down here
to Instagram, Facebook and retweet.
By the way, the reason says retweet
is because Google Correlate
wouldn't let me search for Twitter.
I don't know why, but since Retweet
is exclusively a Twitter word,
it seemed like a good substitute.
So I'm going to put those
all into covariates.
And those are the three variables that I'm
going to use together to try to predict
which states have Democrat governors,
in which states have Republican governors.
And you can see right here, we've got a
model that's actually working pretty well.
We've got three variables.
We have The Intercept, which is not zero.
Instagram is not statistically
significant.
Facebook is in retweets.
No, we're close.
But there's a lot of other information
we can get through the options
that we have in movie.
So let's just take a quick look.
Let's take a look at model builder
and this is how we want to enter things
and we can put stuff in blocks
if we want to.
I don't feel
the need to do that in this case,
but I showed how that works in the video
on linear regression.
Let's look at reference levels
and one
of the categories needs to be taken
as the baseline and we're trying
to predict a change to the other category
because there are more Republicans
governors.
Let's just have Democrat as the baseline
and we'll go up from there.
Assumption
checks colony parity isn't the issue,
especially because I'm
pretty sure that these three social media
terms, as Google search terms are related.
And from that we get both the VHF, the
the variance inflation factor
and the tolerance.
And there's indications here
that we've got some colony ease,
but nothing awful.
We have a few choices
on how we assess fit.
I'm going to leave this with the default
where it uses deviance in the AIC,
which is the key information criterion.
Then we go to the model coefficients.
A common choice when you're dealing
with binomial logistic regression
is the odds ratio, and it's also nice
to get a confidence interval
and that's going to add
a few columns on to this table right here.
You see we've got the odds ratio
right there now
and so many other statistics, zero
is the base value and things either go
positive or negative, but the nothing's
happening value for an odds
ratio is one that means a 1 to 1 ratio
and it goes below one,
but it doesn't go all the way down
to zero, can't get all the way down there
and can go up from there.
And so you see, for instance,
that the intercept well,
the intercept is reliably above zero,
but you can see that it's a odds ratio.
Both of these numbers are above one.
This one one's below one, one's up these.
Both of them are above one.
They're on the same side.
And so these give us an idea
of the variables
that predict
the odds of a particular state.
Having a Republican governor
based on these three
social media variables
that we have from Google Correlate,
if we come down a little further,
we can go to estimated marginal means.
And so, for instance,
Facebook was significant
within the context
of these three predictor variables.
Let's take that and stick it into here
for marginal means
and actually gets a nice curved chart
that goes with it.
If I come down here for a moment
and what this
shows us is the probability of a state
having a Republican governor
going from 0 to 1.
That's 0% to 100% based on the Z score
that State has on searches
for Facebook, on Google.
And you can see here that when states
search less than other states
for Facebook, they are less likely
to have a Republican governor.
But when they search more, they're more
likely to have a Republican governor.
And so this a nice way
of looking at the effect of that,
because binary logistic regression
does work on a curve system where it's
drawing this probably changing over time.
This one shows you just the one variable.
It actually uses all of the variables
together to calculate probabilities.
But another
nice thing about categorization
tasks like this is
you can get a classification table.
So I can click on that one right here.
And what is going to tell me
is what it predicts
the states will have versus
what they actually do.
And what's interesting too
is you can change the cutoff value.
So for right now, it's
only getting 40% of the Democrat states.
Correct, it's
getting 91% of the Republican ones.
But let's take a quick
look at what's called a cutoff plot,
which gives us a chart of what's called
specificity and sensitivity.
You can think of sensitivity, meaning like
it's very likely to set off an alarm
or to give you the answer if it believes
it has a Republican governor.
And specificity means it's
going to do that only if it does.
And in many situations these two lines,
this is specificity going up here
and this is sensitivity going down.
Often
they cross right here at the 50% point.
But these ones are a lot closer to 0.7.
So what I'm actually going to do
is I'm going to change the cutoff
from point five, 2.7,
and do that right here.
And you'll see that it changes
the way the classification table works,
because now it's going to say,
well, only put them as Republican
if they have over a 70% chance
of being Republican.
And that actually makes sense to
because it's about two thirds Republican
governors
slightly over in the country as a whole.
You see this cutoff lines
lot closer to where these two crossovers
usually where you want to get it
because it's going to be maximum utility
there and it's changed
the classification table instead of 40%.
We now have 73% correct
for the Democratic governors
and we've gone from 91 to 73.
But now it's sort of balanced
in terms of how accurate it is
for the two different conditions.
And so these are some of the methods
that Jamovi gives you
for looking at the relationship
between several predictor variables,
like the three social media search terms
and how they can be used to predict
the classification
of a dichotomous outcome like Republican
or Democrat Governor or any other time,
you have two distinct outcomes
that you're trying to predict.
We're at a point where things are going
to get very complicated.
At least they could very complicated.
Multan Normal logistic regression
is potentially
a very sophisticated analysis.
What you're trying to do is several
predictor variables in a regression
equation to predict not two categories,
but several categories.
And although it may not sound
like a big change,
the processing behind
it becomes exponentially more complicated.
Fortunately, Jamovi makes it possible
to do a relatively simple, multichannel
logistic regression.
I'm going to demonstrate this
with the state data,
and I want to look at this one
category here, which actually has to do
with psychology profile
for the various states
in the United States.
Let's start by doing this.
Let's do a quick exploration
and get descriptive
for psych regions.
I'm going to put that over here
and I want to get the frequency table
and I want to get the bar plot
and this is based on an analysis
of people's online behavior
and other characteristics.
And the researchers ended up with three
category is what they called a friendly
and conventional, which is half the states
in the sample, relaxed and creative.
That's ten states who are about 21
and temperamental and uninhibited.
That's 14 of the states in their sample.
And here's a bar chart. You can see them.
And unfortunately, labels
don't automatically adjust
in a movie at this point,
but that'll happen eventually.
But let's see how we can use
other variables to predict
which states into which categories.
And what I'm going to do for
that is I'm going to come back up here
to regression and go to an outcome
that's multi normal logistic regression.
And when I click on that,
the first thing I have to do is
pick what my dependent variable is, what's
the thing that I'm trying to predict?
In this case, it's the regions.
So I'm going to put that right there.
Now I've chosen one
with just three categories.
That's going to be the simplest.
If we had only two, we do binomial
and if we had more than that,
it just gets so complicated.
It's hard to deal with
in terms of covariates.
What I'm going to do is I'm going to pick
the five elements of the big
five personality factors.
So that's extraversion, agreeableness,
conscientiousness, neuroticism
and openness.
Mind you,
this is not a nice person by person level.
It's a state by state level.
I'm going to slide
that over into covariates
and then from there we can start
looking at the model that it creates,
it takes a moment
sometimes for it to run through this
because there's a lot of calculating
that goes on behind it.
Let me close this
so I can slide this over for a second.
We have a pretty big table here.
The first one is the fit measures.
So we have deviance, we have the AIC,
and you'll see that a lot of
this is very similar to what we had
in the binomial logistic regression.
We also have the model coefficient
where it's comparing the different groups,
the relaxin creative minus
the friendly and conventional.
And it's looking at these various
elements, the personality factors,
and we have the P values over here
and we see that, for instance,
when distinguishing between
relax and creative,
none of these seem
to make a big difference.
When we look at temperamental
and uninhibited
versus friendly, conventional
do get one and two conscientiousness
is appears to be an important one
and neuroticism is nearly there.
Now, let's take
a look at some of the options we have.
Click back on this
and then come down to Model Builder.
I can put the variables in in blocks
if I want.
And there may be situations where since
and there may be situations
in which I want to do that.
But with just these five personality ones,
I'm not going to do blocks.
But I did demonstrate that in linear
regression.
So you could take a
at that reference level is what's the one
I want to compare it all to.
I actually think I'm going
to take the temperamental and uninhibited
and make that the reference level
and you can see how the order
just switches around over here.
So this is friendly, conventional,
minus temperamental and uninhibited,
and it just changes the sign
of some of the comparisons.
Although you see down here,
neuroticism becomes an extremely big thing
for distinguishing
between the relaxed and creative
and the temperamental and uninhibited.
We're going to follow up with that.
We'll come down to model fit.
These are the standard choices here.
We'll keep those as they are
and model coefficients.
Now this is where we have the estimates.
Those are coefficients,
but it's nice to have odds ratios
and confidence intervals those as well.
And when I do that,
I just get a few more columns over here.
Now you can ignore this one
because it's for the intercept.
We don't expect anything particular there.
It's the rest of the ones
that we're interested in.
And you can see, for instance, here this
second, the bottom one, this is
relaxing, creative,
minus temperamental and uninhibited.
We're looking at neuroticism,
which has to do with
kind of having a lot of mood swings
or also getting irritable.
And we have a significant association
here.
The odds ratio, 0.73.
Remember the null value for north
ratio is one.
If it's either below one or above one,
then you have something going on.
And especially if both sides of the
confidence interval are on the same side
of one as we see here.
But this is all going to be
a lot easier to interpret
if we get the graphs.
And so I'm going to come down here
to the estimated marginal means,
and that's going to take a moment
because I'm
going to put all of them in here
and I have to do them one at a time.
I'm going to take extroversion.
Put that over here.
I'll add a new term to agreeableness,
add a new term to conscientiousness,
had a new term to neurotics ISM
and add a new term and to openness.
And then I'm going to close this
for right now.
And what we're waiting for
are all the groups that are
come at the bottom
really pretty graphs.
What they are are lines
that show the probability.
So we have our three regions, each
of which is shown by a different color.
So this gray line right here
is the friendly and conventional.
And by the way,
this shows this extroversion
where the mean is about 50
and it goes down to 30, up to 70.
And so as extroversion goes up, there's
a much higher probability that that, say,
is in the friendly and conventional.
You can see that when extroversion low,
it's probably relaxed and creative
and the temperamental
and uninhibited is just kind of low
all the way through on that one.
Agreeable,
friendly and conventional is really high.
All the way through.
You can see that the temperamental
and inhibited low agreeableness.
So they're a little cranky.
They're as it comes down.
It comes less likely that they are
one of the temperamental and inhibited
because they're more agreeable
conscientiousness, this amazing crossover
where friendly and conventional
as conscientiousness increases
friendly and conventional, the probability
a state being friendly, conventional
increases dramatically
and we have the exact opposite
for temperamental and uninhibited,
much lower levels of conscientiousness
and it doesn't seem to really figure
into the relaxing and creative states
and then neuroticism
with this really peculiar huge crossover.
This is temperamental, uninhibited,
as neuroticism levels get higher,
relax, it gets low.
And then we have a funny little peek here
for friendly and conventional.
And then
we see
that the friendly and conventional
as openness increases,
they start out on the low end and then
it drops off and the other two pick up.
So there's a tradeoff there.
And so this is a really neat way of seeing
a visualization of the probabilities
and how each fact eater
goes into determining
whether a state falls
into one of these
three different categories.
And this is probably how you're going
to get the most information.
And then the most insight into your data
is through these marginal mean graphs,
but you also get an idea
for which ones really matter overall
by looking at the calculations
and the numerical summaries
in the multi normal logistic regression,
one final variation of regression
that we can get engine movie, that really
is kind of surprising considering that's
not always available in other programs
is ordinal regression or specifically
ordinal logistic regression.
And the idea here is you're
trying to take several variables
to predict where a particular case falls
in ordered categories,
say, for instance,
from lowest to middle to highest.
Now, you could
theoretically have an entire ordinal scale
where you rank every case from one
to however many there are.
But when you have a small number of cases,
this is where ordinal
logistic regression
is going to be most useful,
and another time that it shows up
is really
handy is when you have data
that really deviates from normality
now I'm going to use this example
data of state data that I uploaded,
and we have, among other things,
how much different states
search for different things.
And one that's kind of interesting
here at the very end
is searching for modern dance.
Now Let me show you what this looks like,
because then you'll understand
why the procedures necessary
if we put modern dance right here,
it'll give us some statistics.
But what we're really interested in
here is the plot, the density histogram.
So we have data from 48 contiguous states
and you can see it's mostly normal,
but man we got this big gap
in this bump up here.
I happen to know
and this is Utah where I live.
Utah,
it turns out, leads the national mindshare
for dance,
which is kind of shocking anyhow.
This is not a normal distribution,
and outliers like this
can really cause problems
with regular analysis.
And so every doing the data,
transforming it
and possibly putting into categories
might be one method of dealing
with this and ordinal logistic regression
makes that possible.
Now what I want to do to make that happen
is I want to split it up into categories.
So, for instance, let me come back to this
just for a moment where I was.
And let's go to statistics and say
what are the cut points
to create for equal sized groups?
So we're going to take quartiles.
And what this says is, well, the minimum
Z score is -1.4 for the 25th percentile.
The first quartile is -0 .6.8, the 50th.
This is about negative .23 in
the 70 is positive 0.45
and it goes up to 4.7.
I think that's
where Utah is a way up here.
Now I'm
going to round these off a little bit
and what I did is I came in here
and I created this new variable.
I'm calling it Modern Dance Quartiles.
And what I'm saying is if the Z score
is less than negative five, put it in one.
That is, put it in the first quartile.
If modern dance is less than zero
but above negative point five,
but in the second quartile,
if modern dance is less than positive 0.5,
put it in the third quartile and otherwise
put it in the fourth quartile.
And so that's a way of nesting
if statements to create these categories.
And when I do that,
I can come back and do exploration again,
except this time we'll do it
for the quartiles.
I put modern dance quartiles right there.
We'll get a frequency table
and then we'll get a bar plot
and then you'll be able to see that
it's a little better behaved
because we've brought in the outliers
and we've created four groups
that are approximately equal size
and they're pretty close and.
The reason they're not exactly the same is
because I intentionally chose
to make the cutoff points, something
that seemed a little more sensible.
But now we have an ordinal variable.
We have the states categorized
into the lowest quarter,
the second lowest,
the second highest, and highest quartile
in terms of their relative
search preference for modern dance.
And so I'm going to come here
to regression
and come to this last option
here, ordinal outcomes.
And when I open that up,
the first thing I need to do
is specify the dependent variable
or the outcome that we're looking at.
And that's going to be modern dance.
And I come back up here, I go to select
and I'll just click it over here
and then we put in covariates.
We can put in a lot of variables
if we want,
but because have a small sample size
only 48 cases, I'm going to limit it now.
Modern dance
because
it's an art
form should be most associated openness
because in certain studies
I'm big 5% of the characteristics
open to seem
to also have something to do with art.
So I'm going to click that
and put it over here in covariates
and then also I'm going to show you
how to use a factor.
I'm going to take the psych regions
because that included
friendly, conventional, but also relaxed
and creative, which seems like
it would be important for something
like of performing arts.
And so if we take those
we have this table right here,
it lets us know about the deviance
and the AIC,
which are methods
of assessing the fit of the overall model.
We have these predictors.
Openness, it turns out, is significantly
associated with modern dance quartiles.
So that's something that we all
of hoping for.
That openness
or being open
to new ideas and possibly
to esthetic experiences
seems to be associated
with the number of searches,
relatively speaking, that is state
does for modern dance.
We also see that the psych regions
matter, that the relaxed and creative
and the friendly conventional,
it makes a difference.
And what's interesting
actually in both cases
is that relaxing, creative doesn't
more than friendly in conventional does.
That's because this is positive
and also temperamental and inhibited
does more than friendly
and conventional does in both cases.
So let's take a look
at some of the options we have.
The model builder.
If I wanted to put things
in a separate box, I could
the reference levels
let's go to model fit.
This is where we have two choices
the deviance, the AIC and the McFadden's
R squared. All seem like great ideas.
I want to leave those
and the model coefficients.
That's this table we have right here.
I'm just going to throw
one more thing on to it.
I'm going to do the odds ratios and the
confidence intervals for the odds ratios.
The null value for the odds ratio is one.
And so if we are
consistently below one in the confidence
interval
or above, that lets us know
that we have something important here.
And for instance, let me close this
so we can see more of this output here.
I'll drag this over.
So openness, the odds ratio on both ends
of the confidence interval are above one.
So, you know, is significant.
But really
the amazing one is this here temperamental
and uninhibited states versus friendly.
In conventional states,
the odds ratio is 17.54.
That's really big and the confidence
interval goes all the way up to 91.
So this is a very influential difference
in trying to predict what a state
ranked category would be in
terms of the quartiles went through four
and their searches
for modern dance on Google.
And so it turns out that this is actually
a really easy analysis set up.
We could theoretically
have a lot more options available to us,
but jive always keeping it pretty simple
and this is a good way to get started in
dealing with ranked information
as opposed to the outliers
that we had in the original distribution
and using a regression model
with both a quantitative
or continuous predictor variable
and a categorical predictor
to try to find out where states
would fall
into that ranked continuum that we created
in this section on analyzing
frequency is in January,
we get a new way to deal with data.
Specifically, we are now dealing
with counting as opposed to measuring.
Now measuring means when you say
how long does it take to do something
or What's the average score here?
Counting
is like counting the number of rocks where
able to enumerate the cases
and put the frequencies in as your data.
And this requires a different approach.
In GMAT, we have several options
for analyzing frequencies.
The first and simplest is
what's called the binomial test.
Binomial means two names, and it's fair
when you have two categories of outcomes,
like flipping a coin and getting the
of heads and the number of tails.
If you have more than two outcomes,
say for instance,
you have baskets of several
different kinds of mushrooms.
You can use the chi squared
goodness of fit test to see
how things are distributed
across those multiple categories.
If you want to look at two
categories at once
and look at the association
and say, for instance,
you want to look at something
like the number of World
Cup teams from different countries
and break it down by male or female,
you know, because know
that in soccer the American women
have done fabulously well.
The American men
didn't qualify for the World Cup.
Most recently, that's looking
at an association between two categories.
And you can analyze that with what's
called the Chi Square test of association.
You also have something
called a McNamara's test.
This is a relatively unusual one.
It's for looking at tables
where you have related data, paired
observations like data from twins,
because they go together
and you have to take together
that consideration.
And also, if you did the same person
at time one and time two,
then the frequencies
have this built in association
and you need to compensate for that.
McNamara's test lets you do that.
And then finally there's also log linear
regression.
It accomplishes a lot of the same things,
but it uses a different
mathematical approach.
It's based on regression.
There are some pretty serious equations
that go into it,
but it is often a very flexible
and very powerful technique
for modeling the number of cases,
the observation genes are frequencies
within different cells of your data.
And so
taken together,
this gives us a great range of options
for a data analysis,
for counting infrequent CS In Germany,
probably the simplest data situation
is trying to analyze
just two possible outcomes.
You can call that dichotomous data
because it's split into two pieces.
You can also call it binary.
And in this case
we're going to look at the binomial test,
which literally means two names.
Think it as heads
or tails on or off, yes or no.
And in this example,
I'm going to use the state data
and I'm simply going to look at Governor,
because that's the only binary variable
I have in here.
And let's do this first.
Before we do a binomial test, let's get
a little bit of descriptive statistics.
I want to come over to Explorer version
and go to descriptive
and all I need to do is get governor,
put it over here into
variables is going to tell me some things
I don't really need to know.
Might as well remove the
statistics that
really only work for quantitative
or continuous variables.
But what I do want is a frequency table
and what I do want is a bar plot.
And when I get the two of those, it
tells me what percentage I'm dealing with.
In terms of governors from state to state.
We have 48 states represented
because remember, this data only
is for the lower
48 states in the United States.
And we have 15 Democrat governors
as of about a week ago and 33 Republicans.
And here's a bar chart
that shows the difference.
And so that's really easy to see.
It's about 2 to 1.
Now in terms of binomial test,
what we're doing is trying to tell
whether our observed proportions differ
significantly from some value.
In a lot of inferential tests, it's really
obvious that the null value is zero.
Well, in the binomial test
you have a few choices.
Now let me close this
and come over to frequencies.
And the first thing we're going to look at
is the two outcomes or binomial test.
It's under one sample proportion tests.
If I click on that, it's
actually a really simple dialog box.
All I need to do is pick the variable
that I want.
I'm going to use gov
and move it over into this box.
You can tell it's looking for
that is coded in g movie
as either a nominal
that is a categorical variable or ordinal.
And right now it's already done the test
and it has me that these proportions
are both significantly different
from a null value of 50%.
And I can get a confidence interval
which actually is a really nice idea
in this particular case.
And this lets me know
that the percentage of Democrat governors
has a 95% confidence that goes from
18.7% to 46.3%.
And we have the flip side of that
for the Republican governors now.
I'm going to close this for just second
so I can open it up again.
This one is done with a null value of 0.5
or 50% each.
And maybe that's not the value
that we want to use.
You know, right now
we have 68.8% Republican governors.
Let's say we want to compare it
to maybe ten years ago.
And I don't know what the proportion of
and Democrat governors in the 48
contiguous states was ten years ago.
But let's just say, for instance, I'm
going to do the confidence interval here.
Let's say it was 60, and we want to know
whether there's been a change
in the last ten years.
Then I can do this.
And now it's going to compare
these two numbers to 60%.
And what we see here
is it's a little different.
Let me close this so we can see this
in the first case
because we're comparing to this 50% and.
Each of these two values,
because they have to add up to
100% are equidistant from 50%.
The p value is the same
for the both of them on.
The other hand, when we move the null
value away from 50%, in this case
2.6 or 60%,
then the P values are very different.
We find that the current observed
proportion of Republican governors,
which is 0.688,
which is the same as 68.8%,
that does not differ
significantly from 60%.
On the other hand,
the number of Democrats does.
And so we have this big difference
depending on how you set the null value
and is going to depend what value you is.
If it's something that really should be
just as likely yes is no,
then the default value of point
five is good.
But if you're looking, for instance,
at a game that has four players,
then the default value of any one player
when you point to five
and there can be other values
depending on what you think
is most likely to happen at.
But no matter how you do it,
the proportion test is a very easy test
to do in movie and it gives you
the simplest kind of data.
Just a simple yes no outcome.
And it does both an inferential test
with a probability value
and a confidence interval.
When you're
looking at the number of cases,
either of two categories,
you can do the binomial test,
a very simple test,
and we've show that elsewhere.
But when you have more than two
categories, but still in a single variable
or a factor,
then you get to do the Chi square
two goodness of fit test.
And it's kind of a silly long name,
but it's test you use for comparing
multiple categories in the same variable.
Let me give you an easy demonstration
of this using the state
data that you can download
from DataLab Dot CC.
In this example, I'm going to use this
variable that's called psych regions.
It's based on psychological research
that builds profiles
states in the United States.
And we're going to start
with an exploration
where we get basic descriptive of this.
All I'm going to do is pick psych
regions, move,
whatever the variables,
and I'm going to change the statistics.
We don't need these ones
because those are for quantitative
or continuous variables.
There we go.
I'm going to get the frequency table
and I'm going to get a bar plot.
It's really simple stuff.
Now, of the 48 contiguous states
that the researchers looked at,
they classified 24 of them.
That's exactly half as friendly.
And convention.
That's our biggest bar right here.
I'm sorry that the labels are overlapping.
I'm sure that will be fixed
in a later release of movie.
The next category is relaxed and Creative,
which includes ten of the 48 states.
That's about 21%.
And the last category is temperamental
and uninhibited.
That's 14 of the 48 states, or about 29%.
And so we can look and see, for example,
whether the states are evenly distributed
across these three categories.
Now can tell by looking at the bars
that obviously they're not all the same.
The question is whether that difference
is statistically significant,
and that's where we do
the Chi Square two goodness of fit test.
Now there's an important choice
we get to make, and that's
how we define our null values by default
is going to assume
equal frequencies
or equal proportions in each category.
So let's go to the frequencies
here and go to any outcomes.
That means more than two outcomes,
an arbitrary number
and that right there is chi squared.
It looks like an ax.
It's actually a capital Greek c,
it's called chi chi squared.
Goodness of fit.
So we're going to click on that one.
And all we need to do
is take our variable here
as psych regions
and put it right here and the variables.
Now this option for counts
is when you have a summary table
in your data set and I'll show you that
in a later video how that can work.
But because we have a raw data where,
everything is listed as one uppercase,
which is most common.
That's the kind
we're going to use right here.
And what we have over here
is a proportions test where it says that
a proportion of 0.5,
that 50% are in this 128 to 9 two.
And it tells us that the chi squared
goodness if, it gives an inferential value
where the calculated value of chi squared
is 6.5,
two degrees of freedom
gives us a p value of .039.
The standard of P or probability that
we use for significance testing is 0.05.
So this would be
a statistically significant finding.
But I want to show you two
other things we can do.
One is exactly what is the algorithm
comparing these values against?
Well,
is comparing them against expected counts.
And the way it does expected counts,
is it right now?
It just takes however many values we have
and it splits them evenly across
a number of categories.
Well, 48 states can be divided evenly
into three categories by having 16 each.
And what the Chi Square does is
it looks at the deviation
between 24 and 16, ten, 16 and 14 is 16
does some on those.
And that's
where the value of chi squared comes from.
And so if we are looking for exactly
the same number of states
in each category, we have a result
that is significantly different from that.
But let me close this
and do another analysis
where we're not looking at
strict equality across the three.
There are lots of times where you expect
a different number of people
to be in each category.
So, for example,
if you're looking at the number of left
handed and right handed people,
there's more right handed people overall.
You don't expect it to be split
totally evenly.
So there is another way you can specify
values other than strict equality.
Let me put psych regions back in here
and we'll still get expected counts.
But now I'm going to click on this menu
to get expected proportions.
And what I can do here,
as you see, is saying that by default it's
going to split it up across the three.
So 33.3% change,
I can put it as a different value
and you put in the ratios here
and that means like 2 to 1
or 3 to 1 if you want,
you can enter them as percentages.
So you can say like,
Oh, let's have 60 here
and let's do 25 here and let's do
15% here.
And that gives us the values that we would
expect in each of these conditions.
I think that adds up to 100.
And now what you see is our values.
We have different expect ID values
and now we still have
a statistically significant result.
But I was able to specify different values
and you can see how up here
the expected are 16
and it's the same in each case here.
The expected values
change from one to the other
according to the values that I gave it.
It's still a statistically
significant result.
In fact, it's, uh, there's a slightly
greater deviation than we had before.
But the idea here is we have one factor,
and that is which personality category is
the state put into?
We have three options
the friendly and conventional,
the relaxed and creative,
or the temperamental and uninhibited.
And depending on
how we want to set up our know values,
we can compare our observed frequencies,
how many there are in each category
to what we might expect.
If the null hypothesis of random variation
were true.
And in both cases here
we find that we have a statistically
significant deviation from that
based on using the proportion test
or the chi squared goodness of fit tests.
In Germany, if you want to look
at the association between two categorical
or nominal variables, the most common
choice is the chi squared test of
also called
the chi square test of independence.
And let me demonstrate how this works
by starting with a split frequency.
Let's come up here to exploration
and descriptors and let's look at,
for instance, psych regions.
This is in the state data data
set that I supplied.
I'm going
to put that here under variables,
but let's split it by whether a state has
a Republican or Democrat governor,
because it's possible
that there is some association between
the political party of the governor
and the state's personality
is rated by some researchers.
Now, right now,
all it's telling us is that there are
48 cases in the data.
I'm going to remove this
extreme permission that I don't
need.
Eric, right now,
the table is a little bit smaller.
I do want to get a frequency table.
I'll click on that.
And this is going to tell me
how many people are really
how many states
there are in each combination.
And then I'll also ask
for a bar plot at the same time.
And what we have
here that we have 20 Republican
governors of states that are considered
friendly and conventional.
We have six Democrat governors of states
that are considered temperamental
and uninhibited and we can see that
in the chart down here.
Again,
I apologize for the overlapping labels.
I'm sure that'll be fixed in the later
version.
The blue lines are Democrat
and the yellow gold ones are Republicans.
And what you see is this huge spike
in terms of friendly and conventional.
The vast majority of those states
have Republican governors
where the other ones appear to be
somewhat split, a little more Republicans,
the temperamental and uninhibited.
But let's find out whether this difference
is statistically significant,
whether there is
in a statistical association
between the personality of the state
and whether the governor is Democrat
or Republican.
So we'll use the chi squared
test of association for that.
Let's come up here and go to frequencies
and then I come down here
to independent samples.
What that means is
we have different groups of people
in each of these categories
or different groups of states
and it's chi squared test of association
also called the test for independence.
And I'll click on that
and here's what it's going to ask me.
I need to give it the rows and the columns
for what's called a contingency table.
That's just a table of rows and columns.
So I'm going to start by putting psych
region as the rows
and I'm going to put governor
as the columns that will mirror the table
I already created
and I could add extra layers,
but that gets really complicated
and hard to interpret.
What that would
mean, by the way, is putting in another
categorical variable here.
So we'd end up with a
three dimensional table, but
you don't
want to deal with that's too hard.
We have a choice for statistics chi.
Squared is just fine for what I have here.
These ones, the comparative measures,
including the confidence intervals,
only apply when you have
what's called a two by two table.
And that means two rows and two columns.
We have three rows and two columns.
So these ones don't apply
to what we're doing.
We have some other choices.
We can get a contingency coefficient
or a Phi and Cramer's V,
let's hit a contingency coefficient
and that's like a correlation coefficient.
Here at the bottom
we can do some ordinal statistics.
We have categorical data, not ordinal.
So I'm going to leave that alone.
And then we have some choices about what
we put in the table.
Now, right now what we have
are just observed frequencies.
The number of states
that fall into each combination.
We can also put expected frequencies.
And that's important because that's
what the chi squared test
is, comparing these observed values too.
So For instance, up here in friendly
conventional, we have four states
with Democratic governors,
but if the data were
completely randomly distributed,
it would be seven and a half.
On the other hand, down here
we have eight states
that are temperamental and uninhibited
and have a Republican governor.
But we would expect,
if things were random, to have 9.3.
The way it gets that, by the way,
is by multiplying the column totals
by the raw totals and then dividing
by the grand total for each of the cells.
But the important part stays the same.
Down here we have our chi squared test
and we get a value of chi
squared of 4.89
with two degrees of freedom.
We a probability value of 0.087.
Now that's something that's
not very likely to happen by chance,
but because it's greater
than the standard cutoff of 0.05,
we can clear that even with this
really big difference right here,
that these results
are not statistically different from what
we would expect through random variation.
So even though it looks like
there's a big difference, it doesn't
hold up under null hypothesis testing.
And that's one of the values
of doing the Chi Square test,
even something that looks at
an eyeball level like a big result.
When you do the actual numbers
and get the inferential test,
it may tell you a different story, which
is exactly happened in this situation.
One of the things
I really love about your movie
is that they include some really unusual
or specialty tests,
make them really easy to use.
One of these is McNamara's test,
and this is a test designed
for contingency tables.
But instead of being independent
variables, it's for repeated.
Now, I have to admit,
I've been doing research for 30 years
and I've never had to do this.
But it's always good to know
that when you come up against
this kind of question,
you can get the right tool,
which gives you greater power
and precision in your research.
So McNamara's test is four categories,
and it is for frequencies
in those categories,
but where the categories are repeated.
Now what I'm doing here is a little bit
different in my other examples.
I've had one row per observation
and so I've had these long datasets.
Right now I'm using a summary table
and it's kind of nice
that Jamovi lets
you do this in a number of situations.
That way I can do it this instead
of having like 85 rows of data.
The data that I'm using actually comes
from a table that I saw
on the Wikipedia article
for McNamara's test,
and it's about patients
with Hodgkin's disease
and whether they and their siblings
had tonsillectomy.
I don't know the association
between the two,
but it's an interesting example
because the sibling goes
with the patient, so there's a connection
between the two of them.
Let me show you how we set this up.
Using McNamara's test in Germany,
we come to frequencies
and we come down right here
and they call it McNamara test.
If you go to Wikipedia, McNamara's
possessive test, I'm going click on that.
And what
we need to do is simply take our data
put in what variable has the row labels,
what variable has the column labels?
And then the variable
that has the counter,
the actual frequencies themselves.
That's because I'm setting this up
as a summary table,
so I'm going to take patient
and put that in rows
and you can see how it starts
to fill it in right here.
And then we take sibling and put it
into columns and it fills in the table,
but it doesn't have any values yet
except to say that.
In theory, there's just one of each.
But then I take the N that's a variable
that tells you how many cases
there are in each category.
And I put that right here
and it fills in the table
and it does a couple of things.
Number one,
it gives us that there are 37 cases where
the patient with Hodgkin's did not have
a tonsillectomy and did the sibling.
But there are 26 where they both
had tonsillectomy,
and so there's an association in that way.
We also have the actual result
here, McNamara says, is
based on the value of chi squared.
And it's interpreted in the same way
that if the value of P,
the probability value
or the probability of the observed effect
size,
if the null hypothesis is true, is .088.
Now that doesn't meet the standard levels
of statistical significance.
It's in the direction.
I do want to show you
a couple of other things we can do
that can be really helpful,
and that is anytime
you're dealing with a table
and especially when you have samples,
different sizes.
Now you see we have 44 Hodgkins patients
that did not have tonsillectomy
and 41 that did.
Those numbers are really close
to each other, so they're easy to compare.
But for the siblings is 52 and 33
and that makes the comparison
a little more difficult.
And so what you can do
are get row and column percentages.
Now do just row percentages first.
What this means is that for the patients
that did not have a tonsillectomy,
84% of their siblings also did
not a tonsillectomy, whereas 16% did.
So they add up to 100% going across.
And that's going to be true
all the way across.
So this really just tells us
that 60.2% of the siblings
did not have tonsillectomy and 38.8% did.
Independent of that, you can
get column percentages going to turn off
the row percentages for just a moment
and we'll get column percent.
And now what this does is it
adds up to 100% going down.
And this is what's nice when you have
different overall frequencies.
So we have just 52 people
without tonsillectomy as 33 that did.
And so we can say that of the
that did not have a tonsillectomy, 71.2%
had patients, siblings who did not
and 28.8 had patient siblings who did.
And we can compare
that to the percentages over here.
And that allows us to make it
sort of an apples to apples comparison,
even though the total frequencies
are different because often
you're more concerned about the rates.
And that's something you can do with
any kind of chi squared table.
You can do it in the binomial,
you can do it in the chi squared test
for goodness of fit
for the chi square test of associations
that getting the percentages
is often easier to interpret.
And the same thing is true
in McNamara's test, which allows you to do
continued in table four paired data.
Another
surprising but useful option in Jamovi
for analyzing frequency
data and associations
between them is log linear regression.
Now what this is is a form of regression
where instead of trying
to predict a person's score
on a quantitative or continuous
outcome variable, you're trying to predict
the number of observations,
the frequencies
within cells of a contingency table.
It's actually now it's a powerful method,
although it can be confusing
to read the output.
My goal here is simply to show you
that it's easy to put these together
into a movie. You decide
that this is something you need.
Then you're going to want to consult
your other resources on how to design
and how to interpret a log linear
regression, but calculating it into movie.
Very simple.
Let's do this.
Let's look at the association
between two of the categorical variables
in the state data.
Let's look at psych regions where the 40
contiguous states of the United States
are classified according to their
personality characteristics,
whether they're friendly
and conventional, temperamental
and uninhibited or relaxed and creative.
And then let's also look
at whether that state currently
has a Republican or Democrat governor.
It's not the most compelling,
but it's a useful comparison.
What I'll do
is I'll come here to frequencies
and come down to this last option,
which is log linear regression.
When I that it asks me for what
the factors are.
Now, please note it's not saying
which one is the predictor
and which one is the outcome
because the model really
is kind of symmetrical.
It doesn't matter.
It's Just trying to put together
the entire table without necessarily
saying This one causes that one.
So what I'm going to do is again here
and get psych regions, I'll move that over
and then I'll also get governor
and I'll put that over
because I have a table
that gives one real problem surveys
and I don't need to do the count,
but is my initial results.
Let me scroll this over a little bit.
It's kind of a big table,
but you can see, for instance,
that we have an intercept at the top.
I'll close this so.
We can look at the whole thing at once.
You can see that what we have
here are a collection of coefficients.
This is like an irregular regression
and we have the estimate,
the actual predicted value
for that coefficient.
It's standard error, the z score,
which is this one divided by that one
and the P value that goes along with it.
Now, we aren't surprised
that the intercept is significantly
different from the zero.
The two
four psych regions are not significant.
Democrat versus Republican.
We have a major effect there
and then we have a nearly significant
interaction for these two regions
relaxing, creative versus friendly
in conventional Republican versus Democrat
in terms of trying to reconstitute
the frequencies within the table.
Now, let me click on this and let's
look at a couple of our other options.
By default,
it gives us the one factor for psych
regions, the other factor for governor
and the interaction, which is what we want
that gets a more nuanced model
even when we're dealing
with a really kind of small three
by two table.
In terms of the other options,
we get to pick our reference levels.
So let's we can pick instead
temperamental and uninhibited
and that's going to switch the way
the table over here is displayed.
And if we want to put Republican
the default value for governor,
we can do that as well.
And that's going to change the way
that some of these values are calculated
over here.
So now you can see, for instance,
we have this value up here,
friendly and conventional
versus temperamental and uninhibited
that's now statistically significant.
And this value here that compares
the two with Democrat and Republican,
it's changed a little bit.
So overall, it's
going to give you the same values.
It's just going to pass it out
differently.
You Have several choices
in how you evaluate, modify.
We'll just leave it
with the standard deviance
and AIC as well as McFadden's R squared.
Those show up here in the table top.
Actually,
I am going to add the overall model test
that's going to give us
a few more columns here that gives us
the Chi Square test and allows us
to do an inferential test for the model.
And here we have a chi squared value
and we can see that
there is a significant deviation
between the observed and the expected
frequencies or predicted values.
We can also come down
and get some of these other values, say,
for instance,
a confidence interval for the estimates.
And that's going
add another two columns over here
in case you want a little richer picture
for the values you have.
And then we can come down
and can get estimated marginal means.
Now I find it handy to do this.
This gives us charts.
I'm going to add a new term
and I'll do a governor right here.
I just click that in and then that's going
to give us marginal means plots.
And this is probably the single best way
to look at the results of the log linear
regression
to come down and see in terms of
the counts that we get for psych regions
along with our confidence intervals and
the confidence intervals for the governor.
And so there's more
that you can do with this.
There are some important distinctions
to be made
when conducting a log linear regression.
But the amazing thing is that movie
includes this and it's an option
for a free, open source
and user friendly program.
And so depending
on the nature of your data,
you could do either
the chi test of association
or independent, or you could do something
a little more sophisticated
with the log linear regression.
And the great thing is that the movie
gives you the choice of one or the other.
Our next topic, engine movie is factors.
And the idea here is that really
data is a jungle and it can be confusing
and it can overwhelming.
And truthfully, sometimes
less is more specifically with data.
What that means is going
from a thousand variables
to maybe a dozen or two
that you need to deal with.
It's much easier to find the order
and meaning in that
you also tend to have more reliable
and stable measurements.
And the first procedure we'll look at into
movie is analysis because, you know,
sometimes you want to
talk about the flock, the whole,
and not each individual sheep.
Perhaps you want to combine the variables
you need to get a single scale score.
But to do that, you first
need to make sure that you're dealing
with similar variables,
that they're measuring similar things
and reliability analysis, whether
with chromebox Alpha or McDonald's.
Iomega can allow you to do that,
or if
you're trying to find the main dimensions
that make up your data,
like finding the main streets
in the city,
you can try a principal component analysis
or the closely related exploratory factor
analysis,
which well being based on different
mathematics and a different
about the relationship
between observed variables and implicit
factors accomplishes
basically the same thing.
And both of these approaches
are exceptionally easy
set up and interpret into movie.
Or maybe you already know the beans
that you want the variables to go into,
and in that case you can use confirmatory
factor analysis where you put together
the factors that the variables go into
and the observed variables
and you see how well the variables
match up with those factors
and how well your model
explains the covariance in your data.
But whichever technique you use,
it'll help you get some clarity
in your data so you can start on path
towards insight and action.
In design, you'll hear
the saying less is more,
and the same thing is true
to a certain extent in data analysis.
Instead of trying to analyze
50 different variables,
why don't you collapse them into a smaller
number of more manageable variables?
That's going to give you more reliable
information and more stable insights.
But in order to do this, you need to first
establish that you can collapse
the data, that there are correlations
you're trying to combine, like with, like.
And the most common way of doing
this is with a reliability analysis
which looks at
the relationship of several variables
that you would like to combine.
This is very common
if you're working with survey data
and you're asking several questions about
the same general concept or construct
in data set, which is based on
real data
on the big five personality factors.
And we've talked about those before
because Germany has a built in dataset,
but it had the summary data or rather
it was already collapse.
This is a data set
that has the ten questions
for each of the five scales Extroversion
Agreeableness, openness to experience,
conscientiousness, neuroticism.
And so we've got 50 personality
variables here.
And this is originally
from an open source dataset
that has nearly 20,000 cases
in the downloads.
For this chapter,
there's a folder called Big Five.
It gives the references
and the notes for this dataset.
What I've done is
I have a randomly selected
1000 cases that we're going to work with
to demonstrate reliability and really
the scale functions of GMV.
So let's start with this.
We're going to just see what we have here.
We have a dataset with an ID numbers
that's a row ID that I put in there,
the age of the respondent,
their reported gender.
And then we have a whole bunch of
questions that they rated themselves on.
And the data information
that you can download
contains a description
of what each of these questions were,
but they're all rated
on a 1 to 5 response scale.
And the numbers up here, for
instance, and four and five mean
this is the neuroticism fourth question.
Neuroticism the fifth question.
And so on there's a for agreeableness,
C for conscientiousness
and oh, for openness.
And that gets us to our one.
So there's ten variables on each and then
we want to see if we can combine them.
So we're going to come up here.
Two factor now factor is an umbrella term
because of these procedures
have a lot in common.
They all have to do with fundamentally
whether there is correlation or
covariance between the variables
that you're looking at.
But we're going to start with this one
scale analysis, a scale
meaning a questionnaire or a survey
where you have multiple questions
designed to measure or scale
the same thing.
So we'll hit reliability analysis
and here are our options,
is simply asks us what the items
or where the questions are.
They're supposed to go into the same scale
that are fundamentally
measuring the same thing.
Now, the nice thing
is this information we have
is already labeled E one through E ten.
These are ten questions
that are designed to measure extroversion
as opposed to introversion.
So let's just take those ten and,
move them over.
So when do we run the reliability
analysis?
This is our default table and it gives us
something called Chromebox alpha.
That's a lowercase Greek, alpha, r, a,
and it's like a correlation coefficient.
And what you're hoping for here
is to have a positive value
that is close to one, maybe 0.7 or higher.
We have a negative value
which is really bad and it's a low value.
This is happening
because we've got some funny things
going on with the data, but that is
something we're going to be able to fix.
But let's do a couple of things
really quickly.
I want to come back to these scale
statistics and I want to click
Mean and I want to click
Standard Deviation.
Now, right now we have a mean
that's really close to three and that's
on a 1 to 5 scale.
That's going to be the midpoint.
So that's great.
The standard deviation. Yeah, there it is.
I find it really helpful to come over here
and do item statistics
and get the Chromebox Alpha
if the item is dropped.
So we've got ten items in this scale.
What is it going to do
on each of these is say, well,
if you got rid of that one
and kept the other nine, what would it be?
And you see it bounces around,
but it's always negative.
But a graphic can also be really handy
here.
Let's click on this one.
Correlation Heatmap.
It's kind of a cute thing,
especially when you have positive
and negative correlations.
We're going to scroll down here
and in a second
the correlation heatmap will pop up.
Happens is when a correlation is negative,
it shows up as a red.
When it's positive shows up as a green,
and we've got this
nice little checkerboard pattern.
And the reason that's happening
is exactly what our analysis told us here.
This has it looks like
five of these variables are reverse scaled
now, something that you do occasionally
when you're doing surveys
to make sure people are paying attention,
you flip it around.
And if we were in SPSS
or some other program, we would then
have to go and manually reverse variables
and do this all over again.
But fortunately, the package
this is based on the psych package and R
makes it really easy to do this.
All we have to do
is scroll down here and tell it which.
Ones are reversed and it tells us
right here e two, four, six, eight, ten.
So I'm going to go to
four, I'm just double clicking six,
eight and ten
and look what happens over here.
It's going to recalculate the alpha
for this scale.
And now it's recalculated the scale.
And you can see, for instance,
that we've got these little A's here
to indicate that these variables
have been reverse scaled.
And look what's happened.
The Chromebox
Alpha has gone from a negative two point
something to a positive 0.89.
And you can tell that dropping
one of these variables, it's
not going to help it.
Overall,
this is a very tight group of variables.
So let's come down and look at the heat
map. Now it's all green.
Everything is correlated with everything
and that lets know
that we are now safe
to average these ten variables.
And so instead of having ten variables
that measure extroversion,
we can combine them
and get a single scale score
that gets a more reliable
and stable measure of extroversion.
And of course, this is for the first
of five major personality factors.
This is there are several others,
and we would simply repeat this analysis
for each of them as we go down.
But the general concept is the same.
We pick the variables
we want it calculate Chromebox
Alpha, which is like an average
correlation between the items.
It lets us know
if any of them need to be reverse coded.
It's very easy to set that up in the menus
and then we can see
how each item contributes
or if it seems to be pulling away.
In this case,
the numbers support the whole thing
and the graphical representations
supports the whole thing too.
We have consistent data, we can average it
and then we can have
the less is more fewer variables, but more
and potentially more meaningful data
to work with in our other analyzes.
When you
have a novel data set either
because you created your own questions
and you got your own data,
or you're combining things
that you don't really know
if they've been put together before.
One of the big questions is
how can you combine things or
what is the emergent structure of the data
that you have?
One of the most common ways of assessing
this is
was something called a principal component
analysis.
There's also the very closely related
exploratory factor analysis,
which we'll cover in another video.
Principal component analysis
works on the principle of covariance
which is closely related to correlation.
Right now we've got a data set here
that is on the big five personality
factors.
It's included in the data
that you downloaded from Data Lab CC
and it addresses extraversion and openness
and conscientiousness and so on.
And the question is how
well do they go together
and what is the structure
that shows up empirically in the data?
We know how
they're supposed to go together,
but what actually appears in the data
that we have
well,
let's come up here to factor and click
on principal component analysis.
And what we need to do
is first feed the variables that we want.
It needs ordinal or scaled or quantitative
or continuous variables.
So Let's come here to one
and let's go way down here
to oh ten.
By the way, you'll notice that
these all have the three little circles
that indicate that they're a nominal
or categorical variable,
but generally smart enough to know
that they're really
can be treated as scaled variables
from a 1 to 5 response scale.
Just click to put them over here
and it starts
giving us the results immediately.
Now, it might take a minute
to get all the way through.
And what we have here is similar to think
think about correlations.
There's an analogy here where we numbers
that go from negative one to positive one,
where is the middle value of zero
indicates no linear relationship
and this is breaking it down
into several components,
several factors,
ways of grouping the variables
based on the data.
It decided that seven components
seemed like the right answer.
And we know that based on that
there's supposed to be five.
But this lets us know what shows up
according to the settings
we have in the analysis.
And now what's nice is right now
it's organizing the ten extra
version items together.
The fact that some of these are negative
and some are positive, that's irrelevant.
It's the value of the coefficient
that matters.
And you can see the neuroticism
all tenure together.
Same thing for agreeableness
and conscientiousness
and things to fall apart
a little bit here with openness,
I can actually tell you that based on
the research, openness is generally
the least coherent
or least cohesive, the factors.
So this is not too surprising,
but we have a few options.
Number one is if you know
about principal component or exploratory
factor analysis, you have the option
of rotating the answer.
That's a complex thing, but what it does
is it can make the results
a little easier to interpret now
very max is one that's common by default.
But I actually prefer Promax,
which allows you to have
what are called oblique factors
where they can be correlated each other.
They don't have to be all right
angles in the dimensional chart.
So I'm going to change that to Promax.
You can see it.
Same we got Promax down here now there's
a few other things I'm going to do.
One is I can hide the loadings.
You see how we have a lot of blank space
here.
There's actually numbers on all of these,
but most of the numbers are really small.
And what some of it does is it covers up
the ones that are low.
Now, let me show you.
If I were to change, it's like point five,
then it's going to redo the table.
It's going to hide a lot of the stuff
that you wouldn't
usually put a number that big, but
it makes it easier to read the table
when you hide the low values.
There's a few other things we can do.
And you see, for instance,
it deleted this one.
And on the other hand
we're losing almost all the other
that are off to the other sides.
I'm going to put it back to the point
three where it was.
But what I'm also going to do is I'm going
to look at the assumptions here.
Now, one important assumption
in principal component analysis
is something called sphere tricity.
And you can think of it
as sort of an analog to normality.
And we just need to run through that
and see, well, we load
now we've got a Bartlett's test
as veracity and it lets us know that
our data seem to differ
significantly from the null hypothesis
and he needs to take that
into consideration
when you were interpreting the results
of your principal component analysis.
But let's do a few other things.
Let's do a component summary
that's
going to give us some statistics
for this component.
I'm also going to ask
for component correlations
and get a chart
that's called a script lot.
It's going to take a moment
for those all to load up.
What the component statistics tell us
is how much variance
in the total dataset could be accounted
for by each of these components.
Now there's 50 variables,
so there's basically 50 units of variance
to account for,
and the first one accounts
for more and drop down as it goes through.
You can also see how the components
are correlated with each other.
If we use
what's called an orthogonal rotation,
then it forces things into right angles.
We wouldn't have any correlations at all.
And there's our test a series city,
this one down here at the bottom,
the eigenvalues, those are the
values that correspond roughly
to how much of variance
each of our components accounts for.
And it's called discrete plot, by the way,
because scree is the rubble
that's on the side of a cliff.
And it's a little bit
like what we have building up right here.
And we have 50 components
because we have 50.
So we have 50 potential components.
And the real question is
how many do you want to use?
And there are several different rules.
One rule right here is to only keep
components with an eigenvalue.
That's this thing that talks about
how much variance each of these components
accounts for,
maybe an eigenvalue greater than one.
You can do.
What we have
right here is called a parallel analysis
that's shown by these yellow dots.
That's
where it looks at a random structure
and tries to see if we have something
better than what's random.
There's also
what's called the elbow test,
where you look at where things curve.
And because I happen to know that
there are five factors supposed to be in
this I'm
actually going to come here to fix factor
and I'm going to hit five.
And when I do that,
we're going to get
a very different factor structure
that actually should correspond
very closely with what's intended
with the data where we have ten variables
on each of five different
well, wait a second.
For that to load up,
we've lost the one reference line here.
So this plots exactly the same
just without the line we had before.
But let's come up to here
and now you see that
the component structure
is much clearer all the way down
to openness, where can see
those ten items that are supposed to go
together are in fact here together.
Now, this is probably
one of the most important things
you need to do when you're analyzing
survey data or, a number of variables
that might potentially be correlated
with each other.
A principal component analysis
is going to allow you to determine
the underlying structure
and see what you can
with each other to simplify the data
that you have to deal with
and hopefully have more reliable
information at the same time,
sometimes you're analyzing data.
You have to draw distinctions
that don't make much of a difference.
And one of those distinctions
is between principal component
analysis and exploratory factor analysis.
Now, these are based on profoundly
different mathematics,
and they also have a different philosophy
about the relationship
between the individual items
that you got data from, from people
and the implied
or implicit factor behind them.
But the fact is they look really,
really similar
and people use them to do the same things.
And there's so much commonality.
There is sometimes hard to remember
which one you're doing.
I've showed you
how to do principal component analysis.
I'm now going to show you how to do
the same kind looking for structure
with exploratory factor analysis,
and you'll see that it looks very similar.
What I have here is Big five data
that's included in the folder
that you downloaded from DataLab Dot CC.
I'm going to come up here to factor
and go to exploratory factor analysis
and. Mostly it's the same.
I pick all the variables
that I want to use in my factor analysis.
This is my 50 variables that people use
to assess big five personality factors.
I put them over here and you can see it's
crunch and we are ready.
I'm going to change my rotation
from oblivion to Promax.
I can also do Bartlett's tests for Essity,
which is one of the assumption checks.
I can ask for a factor summary factor
correlations and a screen plot.
Well,
truthfully, the major difference here
is that the second factor is up on top.
In the order it's a little different.
Otherwise it came up with seven factors.
When we did PCA, we had seven components
and they're sprinkled
around a little bit differently,
but it's basically the same result.
This is our openness factor right here
and things are scattered
a little bit for this last item,
but if you come down here,
you'll see that the factors also have
approximately the same amount of variance
they go through.
The correlations are going to be similar.
The screen looks nearly identical.
And in fact,
I'm going to do two things, and in fact,
I'm going to do one thing here.
And that's because
based on the screen plot and based on
what I know about this data,
I think a fixed number
of factors, five, you see it
actually is calling them components.
Even though we're doing factor
analysis might be a little more useful
for what we're doing.
Now that I've done that, you can see we
have just five factors that are correlated
and now
things are lining up much more neatly.
But fundamentally,
we're getting the same results that we had
with the PCA analysis,
principle, component analysis.
And so take your pick one or other.
I generally do principal component
because I prefer that
it starts with the individual variables
and then infers something about a factor
that goes to them as opposed to
the idea that the factor is first
and it leads to the individual variables,
but fundamentally they're going
to accomplish the same thing.
They're going to help you find
which are your variables,
go with the others and give you the option
of then combining them
to get more stable, reliable data
and the smaller number
of variables that you have to deal with
when you're your analysis.
Either
one of these will help you find the sense
and the commonalities in your data
and help you improve your analysis.
One of the most amazing things
about your movie
is that this free, simple, friendly,
open source analysis package
includes
some incredibly high end analyzes.
In fact, the most surprising one for me
is the inclusion of confirmatory factor
analysis, something that, for instance,
not even possible to do in SPSS.
You're on a macintosh,
and if you're doing it in other programs,
it gets really,
really complicated, really fast.
And this is by far the easiest and fastest
and cheapest way
to do a very sophisticated procedure.
What confirmatory factor
analysis or CFA is
is an attempt to data and say we know how
the data is supposed to combine.
We know that these ten variables
should go to this factor,
these ten should go to this other factor.
It allows you to specify those factors
and see how well your data
fit your hypothesized factor structure.
It also allows you, by the way, to compare
the fit of factor structures
across two different samples.
That's a different thing.
But let's go and take a look
at how to set up
a confirmatory factor analysis in JAMA.
We come to Factor and we come down here
to confirmatory factor analysis.
Now I am working with the Big Five data
set that you can download
from the sample files on DataLab Dot CC.
And what I have are 50 different variables
with ten each for the five different
five personality factors, extroversion,
agreeableness, openness and so on.
And what
we have to do is we have to tell Jamovi
which variables go and what
the name of that factor should be.
So for instance, E one through ten
come first.
I need to come here and say that
that is extroversion.
So I just click on it and type that.
Then I come in, select these ten
and you can see that
the names have highlighted over here
and I put them in right
after that air
and one through ten,
which is for neuroticism.
So I'm now going to add a new factor.
I scroll down a little, we'll see
if I can spell neuroticism correctly.
And we select the ten variables
and put them into neuroticism.
There they go.
We're going to add another factor
because there's five total
and this is agreeableness.
I select those variables,
put them in
after
that is C, which is for conscientiousness
scroll down here
country and justness.
I think I got that right
C one through ten feed those over
and then the last factor is
O for openness,
come down to the bottom
and type in openness
and put those ten in.
And now we've specified the important part
of our confirmatory factor analysis.
We've told you movie,
we've got five different factors.
We said what the names are
and we said Which variables go with which.
What's interesting is
we don't even have to tell it
which ones are positively associated,
which ones are negative.
We don't have to look at the reverse
scaled items.
It's going to be crunching away on this
for a little while
because this is a pretty mathematics
intensive option.
But let's take a look
at a few other things we can do now.
If we had specific other variables contain
what are called residual covariance
as things that don't necessarily
go into the factor but help explain
some of the leftovers.
We could specify those and.
What you do is you would say,
you take this one variable
and then you specify another way
for the residual covariance.
We don't have that.
So I'm going to ignore that.
Under options, we can change how.
We deal with missing values.
We only have a very small number
of missing values.
I'm just going to leave it like this.
We can do constraint.
Factor variance is equal to one
that sounds good
underestimates.
We can look at a few different ways
of calculating results.
I'm going to do a standardized estimate
right here.
I'll close that
under model fit.
We have several choices.
CFI stands for Comparative Fit
Index Tallies for the Tucker Lewis Index.
Our MSE A is for root
mean square error of approximation.
And this over here a chi squared test.
We've seen that in several other places.
I'm going to leave those defaults
right there.
And then the additional output.
We've got a couple of really nice things.
One is the residual observed
correlation matrix
because what the movie is going to do
is it's trying to reconstitute
a correlation matrix based on,
I said, how the variables went together.
And so I'm going to ask for that.
And it's also going to highlight
any residual values
that are greater than 0.1, going to say
this is where the model is off
more than in other places.
And then finally, I'm
going to ask for a path diagram
and then we'll just wait a minute
for Jamari to finish
crunching all the data
and see what it has for us.
I actually paused the recording
for a minute
because it takes a while
to get through all this calculation.
But here's what we have.
We have our factor loadings where we said
extroversion is the first factor and
the indicator is the name of the variable
that we say goes into that factor.
The estimates are like regression
coefficients and they say,
multiply this number against the variable
to get the factor loading.
We have standard Z scores, the P value.
And by the way, you can see that
everything here is highly significant.
And then finally, the standardized
estimate again, like a Z score
and that a good way of assessing the
relative contribution of the variables.
We have the same thing for neuroticism,
agreeableness,
conscientious ness, openness,
and we got a lot of numbers there.
We come down to the factor estimates.
It passes it up a little bit differently
where it's looking at the connection
between, the factors
in terms of extroversion as a function
of these other things,
the model fits an important one.
This is where we have things.
Again, the comparative index and so on.
But I like these two things at the end.
I'm going to close this so I can make
a little more space on the screen
and open up.
I'm not going to be able
to get the whole thing.
This is a really,
really big correlation matrix.
These are correlations, again, from
negative one, which a perfect negative
linear association to zero, which means
no linear association two plus one,
which is a perfect positive association.
And this correlation
matrix is reconstituted
based on the way that we said
the variables went together.
And these are residuals,
which means compared
the actual correlations
which are computed in the background.
This is how far off our reconstituted
matrix is.
The important things here are the ones in
and that says
we're off a little bit
on that combination of variables
and I can scroll down you can see this
thing is really kind of huge
and so you can take that as an indication
of how close or how far away you are.
If you want to go back to the fit indices,
I can tell you that these numbers
that our fit is adequate.
It's kind of okay.
It's nothing spectacular,
but it looks like we're not too far off.
Maybe we would want to see
which variables are loading best,
which ones seem to be contributing
the most to the fit.
But we may have a go ahead here
in terms of confirming structure
that we think we have.
And then the last thing
is the path diagram, and it's not putting
the coefficients on this, but
it simply says these are the associations.
We say that we have five major factors
extroversion, neuroticism,
agreeableness, conscientiousness
and openness to experience.
And it says that we have all of them
associated
with each other and that each of them
feeds into its own ten variables.
And so that is in a nutshell,
this is the functionality
of confirmatory factor
analysis, again,
a very sophisticated procedure
that a lot of programs
don't like to do at all.
And it's of the really
a special present from Timothy
that it makes it possible to do this.
You're going to have to do more research
on how it all works
and how to interpret the results.
But the fact that you have a tool
that can do it and that does it so easily
is a huge boon to researchers everywhere.
So now we've
come to the end of our introduction to Jamovi
and it's time to talk a little bit
about both what we've accomplished
and what you might want to do
next, your next steps.
First off, here's what we've learned.
We learned about installing Jamovi
and sharing files and wrangling
data, exploring data visualizations, t
test analysis of variance
regression models, analyzing frequencies
and finding factors.
We've learned how to do almost everything
that's necessary
for the vast majority data projects.
And really, I just need to know, have you
learned how to use spreadsheets before?
Do you know how to use either
Excel or Google Sheets?
Because if you know how to use
spreadsheets and if you've learned
how to use your movie, then tool wise,
maybe you're there now.
Maybe you have what you need.
I'm firmly of the belief
that spreadsheets into movie cover
the analytic necessities for the vast
majority of people who work with data.
Now it's possible that you might need
some more tools
depending on the kind of work you do.
But not everybody needs it.
If you're going to do something
that is advanced
than what Jamovi does and Jamovi
has a lot of capability.
Then you might need to do some programing
for data analysis,
and that usually means either
are the statistical programing language, R
or Python with the collection of data
packages that are available for it.
Those two are very,
very popular in data science
and I like to use R a lot,
but I much prefer working with Jamovi.
For the vast majority of my analyzes,
there are other helpful tools.
If you're looking for something
to add to your toolkit.
First, there's sequel structured
query language
for data access,
data manipulation, data cleaning.
If you're working in
an organizational setting,
then sequel can be really, really helpful.
And truthfully,
you only have to learn about 20 commands
to get most of what you need
out of sequel.
Second is Tableau is a proprietary
desktop application.
Now there's Tableau Public, which is free.
All the work you do is available
free on the Internet for everybody.
And there's Tableau desktop,
which if you're a regular person
or if your company
is extraordinarily expensive
if you work for a nonprofit,
you can get it for free.
Tableau really is the tool of choice
for interactive visualization, even for
data scientists who are handy with code
and then third presentation software.
Because remember,
you do all this analysis,
you're going to have to communicate it
to somebody, you have to share it
with them and knowing how to use
Microsoft, PowerPoint or Apple Keynote
or Google Slides
is going to go a very long way in terms
of making your work professionally,
meaning For now,
you may have seen this chart before.
If you're coming from the world of data
science, you've seen
this is called the data science
Venn diagram, and it was created by Drew
Conway several years ago.
And he said that data science
consists of three different
fields put together at the top
left is coding.
That's working with computers at the top
right is stats
and statistics in mathematics,
and at the bottom is domain knowledge.
You actually have to understand
the field that you're working in.
And when you take the three of those
and combine, then you get data science
and it applies to a certain extent
with what we're doing.
Even in this primary situation.
We've been talking about the tool
that's going to be that red circle
on the top left.
We have not talked
very much about the statistics.
That's the conceptual element,
nor the domain, the application.
And so even if you have
the greatest toolset in the world,
there are these other areas
that do need your attention.
And so I would say probably the single
most important thing is data fluency.
And seriously reading a bar chart
and a line chart is if you know
how, to ask a meaningful question
and know how to read
even these very simple analyzes
to get something that is insightful
and actionable out of it, you're
going to have huge value in what you do.
I actually believe that bar charts
and line charts and scatter plots
probably cover
98% of the data visualization needs.
For most people, the simple tools
are often the most effective.
So one of the reasons
I really liked your movie,
even though it allows you
to do some complex things, but data.
And so here at DataLab,
we're developing courses to teach data,
fluency, the concepts and the principles
that the tools help you with.
But the tools are not a substitute them.
And of course separate from the principles
and the tools
is the ability
to work in a particular setting.
So much of the real work
in any data project is not the actual
working with the numbers, but
is in talking with people to understand
what you're trying to accomplish
and seeing how you can make sense of it
and what to do with it.
And the best way to do
this is to work together with other people
on real data projects
to answer real questions.
You can do that at your current job.
You can do it with a volunteer group,
you can do some online freelancing.
Any of these are great ways
to get the experience you need.
Movie is an excellent data tool,
but You need to have
some understanding of these statistical
concepts, the data fluency
and more than anything,
the ability to apply it
when working with
real people on real settings.
So we've been talking about a tool
and you have these other possibilities
that we talk about a data lab as well,
but take them together, take them together
and really you're good to go.
You've got what you need.
I'm so glad you joined me here.
I'm thrilled to show you to movie
one of my favorite new tools.
And I really hope that you'll start
finding really interesting and exciting
ways to use these in getting inside
out of the data that you're working with
and doing something amazing it.